to, audhubillah, this is the big one.
Fakhr and Kibr.
Kibrun, Fakhr.
Fakhr is, it's pretty basic, boasting.
Boasting is a disease of the heart.
Now, Fakhr is different from, Fakhr is different
from, say, Mubaha or something like that, in
that, Fakhr is generally understood here to be
boasting about something that you have not earned.
So, it's when you boast about, ah, Naseb,
like, you're, that, you know, oh, I'm a
Sharif, or my father's, or my father's, you
know, one of the things that they did,
it's so beautiful, ah, on the Battle of
Uhud, that's what the Arabs used to do,
they'd shout out, ana ibnu fulan, as a
way, and the Prophet, sallallahu alayhi wa sallam,
would say, ana ibnu al-awatik, which means,
I'm the son of the, the, the women
named Atika, and the Arabs didn't boast with
their mothers.
So, he, it's like doing the opposite of,
of, you know, what their intention is.
I'm the son of so and so, and
he said, ana ibnu al-awatik, I'm the
son of Atika, all those Atikas, because many
of his grandparents were named Atika.
Right?
So, the boasting about the parents, sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam, Allahumma salli alayhi wa sallam, boasting
about, ah, parents, ah, boasting about these things,
ah, will Khuddam, mentions, ah, in there, he
said, ah, that, yeah,
he said, la'in fakhartu bi aba'indu
wi sharafin, laqad sadaqta wa lakin bi'sama waladu.
If you boast about your parents, or your
ancestors that have honor, it's true.
If it's true, like if they were Bani
Hashim, that's, it's true what you're saying, but
he said, it's, yeah, bi'sama waladu.
It's, they left behind really lousy children.
Right?
If, if, if you're boasting about your parents,
and you haven't done anything, and that's what
the Arabs say, you know, wa laisa alfata
man qara kana abi, innama alfata man qaraha
ana.
The, the man is not the one who
says, my father was.
It's the one who said, here I am.
In other words, you do something, and, ah,
Jalal ad-Din al-Rumi has a poem,
where he's mentioning all these great people that
went before, and then he said, but don't
be content with stories of those who went
before you.
Go out and create your own story.
In other words, be one of those people
that people after you, they'll talk about you.
Right?
And, and this is something that's part of
our teaching, you know, the idea of, of
really being significant people.
You know, it's not wanting it for dunya,
but it's, it's wanting to be, ah, somebody
who does something.
Right?
No, absolutely.
Now, this is boasting.
This is saying, my father did this.
It's what little kids do.
Ah, really.
Right?
Little kids do this.
Little kids say, my dad's a fireman.
Well, my dad's a spaceman.
You know, and it's, it's this type of,
right?
I mean, it's a childish thing to do.
But to mention the parents, what, you know,
ahsani ilayya, something like that, that's a different
thing.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that.
This is boasting.
I mean, we all recognize boasting.
And, and now, here he says, the mountain,
right, the, the mountain of this, fawduhashamikh, this
high mountain, ah, he said, I mean, of
course, kibrun, it's arrogance.
Right?
Deem that mountain insignificant if you desire to
sink it to the ground.
So, ah, kibrun, in Arabic, you have kibur,
kibar, if it's maftuh, it's old age.
And kibrun, if it has a sukoon over
the ba, it's arrogance.
And the root of it is kabura, or
kabira, there's two, two roots.
So, kibrun is arrogance.
And the root kabura is to, to grow,
to be big, kabira, to grow old.
Right?
And, and the idea is, kabir, is to
be great.
Like the Arabs, kabirahum, you know, Ibrahim A
.S. said, afaruhu kabirahum, you know, the great
one did it.
So, kabir is great.
Kibrun, is to have something in your heart.
When it manifests on the limbs, you call
it takabur.
Takabur.
So, kibrun and takabur are really the same
thing, only takabur is the action.
Takabara alayya.
He was arrogant towards me.
In other words, he did something that showed
me that.
And there are many signs of kibru.
There's a lot of signs of kibru.
And I guarantee you, unfortunately, this is the,
of all these, I find this the most
frightening one.
Because, you know, you have some degree of
it.
All of us have some degree of it.
And it just gets, it's a continuum.
It can be really bad, it can be
less, and you'll rarely meet somebody that doesn't
have any.
And when you do, you really feel it.
Right?
When people don't have it.
But, everybody has.
And the most frightening thing about this is
the hadith in which the Prophet ﷺ said,
لا يدخل الجنة من كان في قلبه مثقار
ذرة من كبرا.
No one will enter Paradise.
Or, kama qad, no one will enter Paradise
who has even, like an, the weight of
an atom in his, in his heart of
kibr, of arrogance.
So, arrogance actually prevents people from getting into
Paradise.
And this is based also on the ayah,
سَأَصْرِفُ عَنْ آيَاتِيَا الَّذِينَ يَتَكَبَّرُونَ فِي الْأَرْضِ بِغَيْرِ
الْحَقِّ I will divert my signs from those
who show arrogance in the earth without right.
بِغَيْرِ الْحَقِّ indicates the ulema say that there
are times when تَكَبَّر is actually the proper
thing to do.
And this was the idea of Abu Dujanah
when he was doing his تَبَخْتُر it was
with a haqq.
He's doing it with a haqq.
And, and that's why in normal circumstances that
would be detestable.
But in that circumstance it was praiseworthy.
So, now, a couple of things.
That Allah will divert His signs.
Allah says, I will divert my signs from
those who are arrogant in the earth without
justification.
They don't have a haqq.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala also says,
كَذَٰرِكَ يَطْبَعُ اللَّهُ عَلَى كُلِّ قَلْبٍ قَلْبٍ مُتَّكَبِّرًا
جَبَّارًا Allah will seal the heart of every
arrogant tyrant.
He'll seal his heart.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala also says,
إِنَّهُ لَا يُحِبُّ الْمُسْتَكْبِرِينَ Allah doesn't love those
who have استكبار.
And استكبار is really the same as كبر.
Only it has the idea of deeming oneself
great.
يَسْتَكْبِرُ He thinks he's great.
And it comes, the root of it is
عُجَب which he went through, of having this
عُجَب.
مُعْجَب بِنَفْسِهِ He's very impressed with himself.
And another is the hadith in which Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, according to the hadith,
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam says, يَقُولَ
اللَّهُ تَعَالَى الْكِبْرِيَاءُ رِدَائِ وَالْعَظَمَةُ إِذَارِ فَمَن نَازَعْنِي
فِيهِمَا قَصَمْتُهُ كِبْرِيَاءُ Greatness is my إِذَار my
رِدَاء my cloak.
And عَظَمَةُ is my cloth for the lower
part.
And whoever tries to challenge me in one
or the other, I'll break his back.
So these are two attributes that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has left for himself.
And He does not want people to claim
these attributes.
Yeah, you know that's something in the subcontinent.
There are certain names that are given that
are probably better not given.
Ibn Hajj said that Shaytan got into this
Ummah two ways.
He said with the eastern Muslims, he got
in by giving them names of grandiosity.
And he said with the western Muslims, he
got in by causing them to actually pronounce
good names improperly.
So for instance, in some countries like in
West Africa, عَبْدُ الكَبِير they'll call him الكَبِير.
Or they'll call عَبْدُ القَادر they'll call him
القادر.
You know, something like that.
Or like in Sudan, they say عَبْدُ القَادر.
Which is I mean...
القادر means the slave of the treacherous one.
القادر is from غَدَر.
And Allah's name is القادر.
So that's one of the things that he
said.
Ibn Hajj said Shaytan does that.
Or he said with the eastern Arabs, he
got them names of showing things like فَخْرُ
الدِّين شَمْسُ الدِّين جَمَالُ الدِّين That's why Imam
Yahya al-Nawawi, his name was مُحْي الدِّين.
His father named him مُحْي الدِّين.
He refused that name.
And he demanded that he be called Yahya.
He completely refused that name.
So those names are like أَكْبَر عَظِيم عَظِيم
عُزْمَة Those type names.
No, that's a name.
The easterners use that.
If you name him after Salahuddin, well, the
problem is it's a تَزْكِيَة.
The Prophet had a wife named بِرَّ and
he named her زَيْنَب.
And he said لا تُزَكُوا أَنفُسُكُمْ He said
أَصْدَقُوا الْأَسْمَا حَارِثُ وَالْهُمَامُ Those are the truest
names.
حَارِثُ وَالْهُمَامُ Because all of you will يَحْرِثُ
He'll sow.
And all of you have concern.
So those are the truest names.
And the best names are names that have
عَبْدَ اللَّهِ عَبْدَ الرَّحْمَنِ or have أَحْمَد and
yeah.
So, I mean, if your name is one
of those names, you know, that's your name.
That's what your parents gave you.
So be that name.
Right?
I mean, I told somebody, you know, the
problem is you have people like أَصْدَقُوا الله
and they're مِلْعَقَةُ الدِّينِ A spoon of the
Deen.
Right?
Just eat all the time.
Now, this is amazing and I need to
confirm this hadith.
Because if it's true الله أكبر I mean,
the transmission is true but I just it
just amazed me.
يَحْشَرَ الْمُتَكَبِّرُونَ يَوْمَ الْقِيَامَةِ فِي مِثْرِ صُورَ الْذَرَّ
تَطَّأُهُمَ النَّاسُ ذَرًّا فِي مِثْرِ صُورَ الرِّجَالِ يَعْلُوهُمْ
كُلُّ شَيْءٍ مِنَ الصَّغَارِ ثُمَّ يُسَاقُونَ إِلَى السِّسْنِ
فِي جَهَنَمٍ يُقَالُوا لَهُ بَوْلَسٍ I just thought
that was so amazing.
It said that the people of arrogance It's
in Tirmidhi.
The people of arrogance are raised up on
Yawm al-Qiyamah and they're turned into atoms.
And then everybody walks on them.
SubhanAllah.
And then it said after that they're taken
to a prison in Jahannam called Bolas.
And it sounds like police, you know, the
Arab, they say خُذُوا إِلَى الْبَوْلَسِ That's what
they say, right?
جَبَّارُون خُذُوا إِلَى الْبَوْلِسِ You know, and if
there's a place in Jahannam I have to
make sure that's a correct I'm gonna check
in the Tirmidhi.
If it is, that's just amazing.
Well, Azhar is an ant.
Yeah, it can be an atom or an
ant.
Yeah.
You've heard that with Bolas?
No, I know that hadith is much more
but this, this, I never heard that Bolas.
Yeah.
Bolas, Bessin.
Bolis, it's almost exact.
That's what they say, Bolis, huh?
No, that's what I need to check.
Yeah, I wanna find out.
It's in Tirmidhi.
It's not in there.
Now, a couple of things here just about
استقبال There are two types of استقبال.
Alright?
استقبال, the worst تكبر is تكبر of a
refusal to accept truth and worship Allah.
That's the worst تكبر.
And then there's degrees under that.
So the worst أعظم التكبر امتنع قبول الحق
Right?
وإذعان للعبادة and to submit to عبادة.
And that's why one of the Sahaba came
to the Prophet رضي الله عنه and he
said, يا رسول الله إني امرأ أحب الجمال
Right?
And he said, so I'm a man who
loves beauty.
And he said, so I wear good shoes
and I wear nice shirt.
He said, أهذا من الكبر Is this from
كبر?
And the Prophet صلى الله عليه وسلم said,
لا إن الله جميل يحب الجمال وإنما الكبر
بطر الحق وغمص الناس In other words, he
said, and this is an important hadith because
the man, first of all, he explained why
he wore them.
He said, I love beautiful things.
The ulema say what that means is if
you wear something because you want to تكبر
على الناس to show that you're better.
And this is very famous like in this
culture, people try to outdo other people.
I mean this culture.
Right?
Go to some Muslim weddings.
And where people are obsessed without doing the
other.
And then, if one wedding is everybody talks
about it, then the next people are giving,
we have to outdo, you know, so and
so.
Right?
Abdullah and Khadija will really show them what
a wedding is.
And this type of, that is, you know,
that is, that's a type of كبر because
you're trying to تتكبر عليهم Right?
That's what it is.
And it comes from كبر.
Right?
So, this idea of استكبار is that you,
on the one hand, there's two faces of
it.
One face is that you want to do
things, you want to be great.
And what Imam Raghu ibn Isbihani says, if
it's for something that's great in the time
that it's appropriate for the reasons that are
appropriate, then it's a good thing.
So, استكبار is not a negative thing.
And this is the idea again of turning
these diseases into things that are beneficial.
So, a desire to be great for the
sake of Allah is a good thing.
A desire to to do great things is
a good thing.
The Sahaba, their himmah was high.
You know, their himmah was high.
The Prophet ﷺ's himmah was the highest and
he pulled them all up to...
They saw Thuraya, Pleiades, right?
I mean, they were looking at the heights
when they did things.
And Allah made them great people.
So, that is a good praiseworthy.
But, the one which is blameworthy is that
you try to show people, يظهر من نفسه
أنه أفضل من غيره.
That he tries to show people that he
is better than they are.
And that is what is blameworthy.
Unless you want to show the non-Muslims
that Muslims are better.
Because Allah commands us to do that.
Allah commands us to do that.
Allah commands us to show them.
And in fact, you know, somebody asked me
about this last night about the Christians.
The Christian answer to the world's problem is
very simple.
And unfortunately, because of the Muslims capitulation, there
is a ring of truth to a lot
of people in it.
And that is what they say that the
reason people are the way they are is
because they are incorrigible.
They are corrupt from original sin.
There is nothing you can do about.
They are horrible.
And that is it.
What Allah says is show them that that
is not true.
كَذَٰرِكَ جَعَلْنَاكُمْ أُمَّةً وَسَطًى We made you a
just people لِتَكُنُوا شُهَدًا عَلَى النَّاسِ So that
you can be witnesses to mankind that all
their other ways are wrong.
وَيَكُنَ الرَّسُولَ عَلَيْكُمْ شَهِدًا Now the thing about
that is the Prophet was a witness to
us.
He showed us that it was true.
And his Sahaba are witnesses to us because
they showed us that it was true.
And the followers were witnesses to us.
And each generation gets more and more watered
down.
And then in the end of it there
is no more shuhada.
Which is why so many people in the
end of time become kuffar.
Because they don't see truth anymore.
So they lose it.
And one of the signs of the end
of time is that Allah will give the
dunya to all of the kuffar and the
Muslims will leave Islam because they want the
dunya of the kuffar.
That's the sign of the end of time
according to Imam al-Biqa'i.
He said that's the meaning of the ayahs
in surah al-Zukhruf.
That had it not been that Allah did
not want everybody to be kuffar, then he
says he would have made their houses from
silver.
And he would have given them staircases that
they could just go up on.
Right?
Now you look all there.
It's amazing.
You know they have, that's what they have
now.
All their houses outwardly look amazing and people
watch them on television in Mali and in
Niger and they want to have those things.
Right?
All this stuff.
So it's a real problem.
Yeah.
Can you penetrate that?
Yes.
Because Allah says that even the rock can
be penetrated and water can flow from it.
So seals can be broken and the way
the ulama say that they're broken is by
the power of the warid.
And so in other words, a prophet, by
the pure strength of him, he can penetrate
that.
It's by the permission of Allah.
But that ran that's over the heart can
be penetrated.
And what Sidi Ahmed Zarroq says is that
people who have these seals over their heart,
he said if they hear the truth, depending
on the source that it comes from and
how powerful the source is, depending on the
strength of the truth itself and depending on
the power with which it reaches the heart,
it can penetrate the seal.
And he said it can shake the heart
up and cause a crack in the seal.
But if something is not done in order
to break it, in other words, tauba, then
it can seal back up again.
And so they lose it.
And this is what happens.
Some people they'll go to a khutbah, for
instance, and something will happen to the heart,
but then they go out and they go
back to what they were doing and it
seals up again.
So there's a closure.
Now let me just quickly, before we're done
here, go over...
There are different types of kibar.
And each one of them has qualities and
characteristics.
Now, the first quality is that kibar is
in the heart mustaqar.
It's fixed in the heart.
And the person sees that he's better than
other people.
That's how he considers himself better than other
people.
Now there's a hadith in which a man
was mentioned as being a good man in
the presence of the Prophet ﷺ.
And then he came into the gathering and
the sahabah said, Ya Rasulullah, هذا الذي ذكرناه
لك.
This is the man we mentioned to you.
And the Prophet ﷺ said, إني أرى في
وجهه صفعة من الشيطان.
I see in his face some traces of
shaitan.
And so, the man said salam and sat
down.
And then the Prophet ﷺ said, أسألك بالله
حدثتك نفسك أليس في القوم أفضل منك.
I'm asking you by Allah.
Did your nafs tell you when you came
into this gathering that nobody in here is
better than you?
And he said, yes.
So they saw him outwardly that he was
like really good.
But the Prophet ﷺ saw the kibar in
his heart.
And so he wanted to show the sahabah
that you have to be careful.
Because kibar is very subtle.
And there are many stories of the ulama
and fighting kibar.
Because Imam al-Ghazali says, of all people,
people of ilm have more danger for kibar
than anyone else.
That is the biggest danger of people.
And students of knowledge as well.
People who are studying knowledge like ourselves.
That's a major danger of studying knowledge, sacred
knowledge.
So that now, if you fight it and
force yourself, even though you see that, then
what you're doing is you're preventing the bitter
fruits of that from...
The tree is there and it has roots.
But you're preventing the fruits of that tree
from emerging.
Right?
And the next is where you begin to
actually manifest it in your actions.
So the first one, there's kibar, but he's
fighting it.
The next one is you actually show it
in your manifesting.
You manifest it to other people.
And so you look down on people.
You turn your cheek away from them.
Like if he's a worshipper, he looks down
on other people that are doing worship.
They frown in people's faces.
That's a sign of kibar.
To frown in somebody's face.
Not to give the person the time of
day.
And the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam never did
that.
And that's one of the signs.
Adi Ibn Hatim said that he knew that
he wasn't a king because the old woman
came and she was talking to him and
he just stopped on the street and started
talking to her.
And that was how he did that.
So...
And then...
So that one who becomes mutakabar because of
his worship, the abid, and he's showing off
that way and yatakabar an-nas because he
has worship.
The third is takabar because of hasab and
nasab.
Hasab is your qualities that you have and
nasab is your lineage.
And traditionally, they often went together.
In western culture, they have the idea of
noblesse oblige, right?
That if you're...
If you're somebody from the nobility, you're obliged
to behave nobly.
And you find that in most traditional cultures.
The Arabs definitely had that.
If you were a sharif of nasab, like
if you were from ta'i clan, you
had to be generous.
You had to be generous.
As a ta'i, they had a reputation
of being generous.
If you were a Qurayshi, you had to
have dignity.
You had to be za'im.
If you were a Yemeni, right?
You had to do this.
So each one of them had their qualities
and because of their nasab, they felt necessary
to do that.
Now, because of hasab and nasab, people become
arrogant.
So somebody has good lineage, they become arrogant.
And they see themselves as better than other
people.
So they say, like for Arabs, because they're
Arab, they'll see themselves as better as an
Indian.
Very common.
الحق يقال There's a lot of Arabs that
think, مجرد أنا عربي I had an Arab
come to me once.
He said, I never thought a non-Arab
could ever be a real Muslim.
He told me that.
He said that to me.
He said, I never thought a non-Arab
could be a real Muslim.
If you're in Pakistan, the Indian, right?
Because they didn't make hijra or whatever, I
don't know.
I mean, they see them as less, right?
If you're from Hyderabad, right?
I'm a Hyderabadi, you know?
There's some Hyderabadis, they think, because they're from
Hyderabad, they're automatically better than the rest of
the Indians, just by being from Hyderabad.
Right?
So this is like نسب and حسب and
things like that.
Americans, very common, we're number one.
Because they're from America, they're number one.
If you go into Hausa land, Hausas are
convinced that they're a superior race.
Right?
Many Hausa people feel that they're better than,
certainly better than Yoruba and Ibo.
And probably better than the Fulani.
But the Fulani will see themselves as better
than the Hausa.
If you go to Mauritania, the Kunta will
see themselves as better than the Massouma.
Or, you know, if you're from Tejikana, you're
naturally better than...
And this is a disease, it's a human
disease, widespread affliction.
The Damasicans deem themselves better than the Halabees.
Right?
And the Shami, they even call Damascus Sham.
They won't even let anybody else be a
Shami.
Right?
So, this is a problem.
This is a disease in the heart.
Deeming yourself better simply because of some quality
that you have.
Like the quality of being from Damascus.
Or the quality of being a Nejdi.
Right?
Like the Nejdis will deem themselves better than
the Hijazis.
Right?
They call them Akhlaf al-Hujjaj.
And often in their language, you'll see all
this type of arrogance.
Right?
In this culture, they have a lot of
these type terms.
A lot of racist terminology.
But you'll find them in all cultures.
You'll find them in all cultures.
And these are all...
This is Takabbur.
Because Allah says, إِنَّ أَكْرَمُكُمْ عَنْدَ اللَّهِ أَتْقَاكُمْ
The best of you with Allah are the
people of Taqwa.
And what this does is deludes you into
thinking that somebody doesn't have Taqwa simply because
he can't.
How could he have Taqwa?
You know, he's a Hindi.
Or he's a...
You know, he's a Nejidi.
Or he's whatever.
What about the people...
No, that's not a modern phenomenon.
That goes way back.
Yeah, I mean there's people who are Sada.
And they have Takabbur.
They're human beings.
You know.
People who are from the family of the
Prophet ﷺ, I mean of all things to
have Takabbur for, that's a pretty good one.
I mean I'd put that up there with...
In Nasab, that's number one.
Do you know what I mean?
And that's the danger because sometimes these things
do have validity.
And this is the danger of it.
Right?
In other words, there is something to be
said about being from the family of the
Prophet.
It's a great honor.
But there are many Hadith that put fear
in your heart.
The Prophet ﷺ, there's a Hadith says his
Nasab benefit.
But there's a Hadith that says, you know,
إِذَا أَبْطَأَكُمْ الْعَمَدِ لَا يُصْرِعَكُمْ النَّسَبِ If your
actions hold you back, your Nasab, your lineage
won't speed you up.
Right?
In other words, if you have Nasab, if
you don't have action to go with it,
it's not gonna get you anywhere.
No fuel.
Good car, no gas.
Right?
So, if you're a Sharif, it's a Mercedes.
But the action is still gasoline.
You're not going anywhere.
Right?
You have to put something in there.
So, that's a real serious one.
And there are many Hadith warning us about
the danger of it.
Now, how you cure yourself, one of the
cures is to recognize, first of all, what
are you from?
And your source, Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta
-A'la says, Right?
That, you are from ماءٍ مهين a vile
fluid.
Your source is a vile fluid.
One of them said that, that you, somebody,
كان يتكبر and one of the Salaf, he
said, سُبْحَانَ اللَّهِ يَحْمِلُ بَيْنَ جَنْبَيْهِ الْعَذِرَةِ you
know, he's carrying between his two sides a
bunch of feces.
Right?
I mean, in other words, where's the تكبر?
Where's the source of the تكبر?
That he's just a bag of blood like
everybody else.
Right?
And, you know, they have crude colloquials in
this culture that I won't go into.
But, I mean, people do have, in every
culture, they recognize.
Nobody likes تكبر.
Right?
The problem is, the متكبر does not see
his تكبر.
And that's why he hates, even تشمري to
be متكبر عليه.
Which is why تكبر عند المتكبر عبادة.
التكبر في وجه المتكبر عبادة.
It's a حديث that to be arrogant with
somebody who's arrogant is a type of عبادة.
So, and this is what we call throwing
it back in their face.
You know, you give them a little taste
of it.
Just, and as a cure.
It should be done as a دواء.
Just to let them see how it feels.
Mm-hmm.
That's كبر.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's a big problem.
And, and this is what, if you, if
you feel you're a righteous person, that's كبر.
Right away, off the bat.
If you feel you're righteous, you're in a
state of كبر.
And that's why if you look at the
early people, they were people who really, one
of the companions of Abu Hanifa, somebody was
sitting with him and he, he moved his
foot, and the man moved his foot away
out of respect, out of deference.
He said, why did you do that?
He said, out of deference.
He said, لِمِثْلِ You know, for somebody like
me.
And he said, والله لا أرى أحد هنا
أشر مني.
I don't see anybody in this gathering worse
than me.
And that's the way those people were.
You know, it wasn't a joke.
They really did see themselves as, and that's
why, look at Sayyidina Ali.
It's a sound hadith.
Sayyidina Ali, a man asked him, who's better,
you or Abu Bakr?
He said, Abu Bakr.
He said, then what about you and Omar?
He said, Omar.
And then he said, I didn't want to
say Uthman.
Because I was worried he'd say Uthman.
So I just said, what about you?
He said, ما أنا إلا رجل من المسلمين.
I'm just a Muslim man.
No claim, no maqam.
And that's not, you can say that's humble.
For us, it's humility looking at it.
But for the Imam, he's not thinking, oh,
I better say, in order for me to
be humble.
No, seriously, that's a disease in itself.
Ibn Atayla says, if you're aware of your
humility, you're متكبر.
And that's why, Uriah Heap.
You know that character?
Dickens.
He's an amazing character.
In David Copperfield.
Right?
David Copperfield.
Uriah Heap.
Oh, in my very humble opinion, sir.
You know, he's always, he's a complete hypocrite.
But he's always, in my humble opinion, sir.
You know, and he's always doing this thing
of, being, you know, Uriah Heap.
I know I'm nothing in society, sir.
But in my humble opinion, you know, and
meanwhile, he's stealing all their money, and he's
doing all these, you know.
So, it's a character.
In other words, if you think, that you're
humble, you're متكبر.
Because you're looking at your humility from a
place of height.
I mean, humility means to be low.
So, if you can see how low you
are, you can only see it from some,
from some higher place.
It's the kabbalah.
We're diseased.
We just have to chill.
And this is why, our scholars, gizal malach,
and they said, you know, if you're not
like the real people, at least pretend to
be like them.
You know, seriously, because there's even some benefit
in faking it.
And even the imam says that.
That, you know, just, it's better to fake
humility than to be an outright متكبر.
And that's very clear.
One of the things that imam al-ghazali
radiallahu anhu says, is that, if you want
to learn how to master calligraphy, you go
to the master calligrapher.
And you repeat what he does over and
over again.
And it's totally unnatural for you, but eventually,
you will become a master calligrapher.
And it's interesting, my sister went to a
brain, this neurosurgeon in Stanford, and one of
the things he said, is that, the brain
learns by repetition.
And those things that you do most consistently
with repetition, become completely embedded in the brain,
like driving.
What he said is that, most people drive
in a completely subconscious state.
They're unaware of their driving.
And this is the idea of being unaware
of your humility.
That it's just part of your nature.
It's not something you're faking.
If you're faking it, you're aware of it.
Whereas when it's genuine, there's no, the brain
is not conscious of it.
So when you drive, because you've done it,
when you first start out driving, the best
drivers, right, are often people that haven't become
good drivers, because they're so nervous.
These poor people that learn with the thing
on the top of the car, they're like
Blinker, and they're looking around, they're really fearful.
But then there's people driving down, listening to
the singing, and doing all this stuff, thinking
about all these things, talking on the cell
of your phone, and they're the ones that
get into the accident, right?
Because it's become, the driving is completely, they're
doing it.
Now what this neurologist said, that the interesting
thing about stroke people that lose their brains,
and people that go into dementia, often they
will retain things that they did most repetitiously.
In other words, they can still drive, even
though they forgot how to do everything else.
Because the brain has, it was so repetitious,
and the pathways are so fixed in the
neurology of the brain, that they're still able
to do that.
And this is the idea of repetition.
إِنَّ مَلْعِلْمُ بِالتَّعَلَّمِ تَعَلَّم You do it بالتكرار,
over and over again.
You have to force yourself to be humble,
until it really does become your nature.
Because most people don't have these things naturally.
We're diseased.
If we weren't, we wouldn't be studying any
of the things we're studying, right?
Seriously, that's why we're studying this, because we
all recognize it in ourselves.
All of us.
So, that's the...
Now, the fourth one is التفاخر بالجمال.
كبر because of beauty.
And one of the cures for that is
one, it's the old adage, beauty is only
skin deep.
Beauty is an illusion, right?
First of all, you don't retain your beauty.
Everybody loses it ultimately.
Second of all, Allah gave it to you.
It's not something that you earned or something
like that.
So, being happy with the كبر because of
beauty is a very superficial type of كبر
and it's really a stupidity.
And the other thing that I find really
fascinating is there was a study done on
beautiful people and what they found is that
beautiful people were actually average.
They did all these pictures and looked at
them and found what people were identifying as
beautiful and they found actually people in this
culture, beauty is an average, it's a mean
when it's all put together in one face.
So, it's an average nose, average eyes, average
mouth, but they're all put together on the
same face.
I thought that was so amazing that beautiful
people are average looking.
It's a mean.
And that's the idea, I mean, there's a
truth to it, that median, there's something great
deal to be said for it.
So, it's just a foolish type thing to
do that.
And there's a very frightening hadith about Aisha
رضي الله عنه in which a woman came
in and the Prophet صلى الله عليه وسلم
asked who it was and she indicated the
short one and the Prophet صلى الله عليه
وسلم said اختبتها that's backbiting.
And the ulama say the reason is because
it was تكبر because in other words, had
she not seen her height, that she was
taller than she was and so there was
a type of تكبر there which is actually
quite frightening because that's an اعجاب مُعجَب بِقَامَتِها
or بِقُولِها and then she sees the other
one.
So, the Prophet صلى الله عليه وسلم rebuked
her for that.
The fifth one is كِبْرِ بِالْمَالِ and this
happens with kings with all their storehouses and
merchants with their commodities and also people who
own a lot of land or people who
own a lot of clothes and horses or
cars now and they look down on poor
people or even rich people that are less
rich than them like Helmsley, that woman who
said about taxes only the little people pay
taxes.
And I read an interview it was a
really fascinating interview it was one of these
I can't remember even who it was one
of these famous what they call beautiful people
in this culture and they were on a
helicopter going up on a ski place and
they were like the place down below was
a ski lodge for less wealthy people and
they were having a private helicopter taking them
up the mountain and this woman said she
looked down and somebody said at that point
Oh, look at all the little people down
there and right at that point the helicopter
tipped over and they actually crashed.
But the point is she got the message
some people wouldn't see that be very careful
about how you look at other people because
we're all little people it's what the homeless
on the street looks up at the CEO
and the CEO is looking down saying look
at all the little people and the homeless
guy is up there look at that little
guy up there it's all perspective it's all
just perspective so we're all little people and
that's why the mutakabirun are turned into ants
because they looked at everybody else like they
were ants that could be crushed it's a
very dangerous thing and then another one is
the the quwa kibur bil quwa somebody who
is very strong like Raqqana the Musarek when
he told the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam wrestle
me the Prophet threw him twice he still
didn't become Muslim and then there's a riwayah
that he did inshallah he did I don't
know the point is that he saw nobody
could throw him he said I've never been
thrown ever to kibur so this idea of
somebody who is strong have muscles and the
amazing thing they're gonna get old it all
then they can't do it now the seventh
one is takabur bil atba' with ansar, with
talamida, with ghilman and by having a lot
like a teacher who has a lot of
students and so he sees himself as better
than another teacher who has less students somebody
who has a lot of friends somebody who
has a lot of powerful relatives influential people
somebody who is from the royal family not
the king but he is from the royal
family takabur because of strength but it has
to do with more like that type of
jah and things like that very dangerous one
now of all of these and then also
takabur because of knowledge which really is that
is the most according to the imam he
says it's one of the most insidious because
again like being a sharif having knowledge is
so honored and having knowledge the nature of
knowledge is that people respect knowledge many people
are often in awe of knowledge so when
somebody does have knowledge especially if it's a
good deal of knowledge then people will show
them deference and so it becomes dangerous for
the heart because they'll start thinking I'm somebody
you know I'm important and this is what
shaitan will do to them Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says in the quran how man
has been killed what is more of an
ingrate than man and then Allah says what
did we create him from you know let
man think about what we created him from
he came from a fluid he didn't even
exist before that fluid he wasn't even a
thing that anybody had on their tongue 50
years from you know 50 years ago you
weren't even an idea in your parents mind
you were nothing non-existent and then you
came into existence and when you first came
into existence you know I mean changing diapers
7, 8 times a day that's all they
do they just defecate, urinate, sleep and cry
every once in a while and suckle at
the breath that's it it's unbelievable that's human
being and then they grow up and get
to a point where they have strength and
they become arrogant and then they're gonna go
because it's curvilinear if you live long enough
you'll end up where you started right you
reach that 40 year point and that's you
know people think right, I'm at the top
it's all, everything's alright and then Allah says
من نطفة خلقه فقد در He created him
from a nutfa this emanating, this fluid ejaculated
fluid that Allah made فقد دره right so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that he
and then he measured out everything for him
man didn't do that for himself and then
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says أَوَلَمْ يَرَى
الْإِنسَانِ أَنَّا خَلَقْنَاهُ مِنْ نُطْفَةٍ فَإِذَا هُوَ خَصِيمٌ
مُبِينٌ hasn't man thought about it we created
him from a nutfa and now he's this
manifest enemy of ours right, Allah it's amazing
I mean Allah made the human being and
then he goes into rebellion against Allah and
he's nothing right, I mean Allah can stir
up a little it's a storm in a,
what do they call it a hurricane in
a tea cup Hurricane Mitch I mean it's
nothing nothing, it's just nothing little wind in
one part of the planet in our solar
system in the midst of a universe it's
nothing, and yet for those people that were
hit by it completely devastated all these people
lose their houses, their wealth everything gone from
a wind that Allah sent and Allah says
that in the Quran when they see the
wind they say this is a good wind
coming to give us some rain and it's
an torment so human beings the point of
all of this is we're just fools to
be in rebellion against Allah and Allah says
we gave him a tongue, we gave him
two eyes we gave him this ability to
think, all these things and then we guided
him and showed him two roads and we
told him at the end of this road
is a painful punishment and at the end
of this road is a reward and you
choose and people choose to go down this
other road and it's Takabbur, and you can
look at the Sira I guarantee you, you
look at every single one of those people
that refused to submit it was all Takabbur
it's very clear, the reason people can't submit
is Takabbur and if you look at the
prayer the amazing thing about the prayer and
I mentioned this before there's a type of
slavishness in the prayer that some people find
very offensive and there are western people that
have a really hard time with the concept
of being a slave of God Abdullah they
have a real problem with that concept because
they have this idea I'm free but then
he's a slave to his private parts his
stomach his petty goals in life he's a
slave to all these things he can't control
them he's a complete slave to them but
a slave to Allah?
No I'll be a slave to my genitals
but I won't be a slave to Allah
I'll be a slave to my stomach but
I won't be a slave to Allah so
it's a completely delusional state that the human
being goes into and that's where it is
so he's saying that the way to get
rid of this disease is first knowing your
Lord and knowing yourself now obviously that is
a big task some of them say the
only way you can know your Lord is
to know yourself in your own selves don't
you see so Allah tells us to reflect
on ourselves if you reflect on the self
what you come to realize is that you're
completely bound you are and even Messiah Ibn
Maryam he was not he was not arrogant
to say that he was Abdullah he accepted
that he was Abdullah he accepted that so
even the Prophet the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam said ana sayyidu wal bi Adam wala
fakhra I am the best of the children
of Adam and I'm not boasting wala fakhra
so that was not takabbur the ulama say
the reason he said that is he was
making sure that the sahaba did not understand
from that that he was because that's what
the jahadi arabs used to do they would
like make takabbur he was doing it because
he was commanded by Allah to inform them
of that and that's why he said wala
fakhra I'm not doing this out of fakhra
but the ulama take from that another ishara
that not only was he not there was
no fakhra but his fakhra was in his
abudiyah to Allah it wasn't in his siyadah
of creation that he was the master of
creation it was that he was the most
perfect slave of Allah that was where his
honor and glory was right which is why
there's a hadith some people don't accept it
but mulla alil qari said it the meaning
is true my empowerment before Allah is my
glory right so knowing yourself knowing that and
feeling that those that whoever knows those two
is humbled and feels insignificant yatawada wa yahoon
and man tawada lillah rafaahu Allah whoever is
humbled for the sake of Allah Allah raises
him up Allah will raise him up man
tawada lillah rafaahu Allah so that idea of
being low for the sake of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and then he says also
another thing maqamahu yanfi maqamish shukri that the
station of kibar negates the possibility of showing
gratitude to Allah because the way you show
gratitude to Allah is through abudiyah and if
you're mutakabbar you're not an abd because the
abd by his nature can't be mutakabbar that's
why he's abd the abd by his nature
cannot be mutakabbar and therefore you can't be
shakur to Allah if you're mutakabbar it's impossible
so he's saying it negates it all together
and and then he says kama tawada lahu
dhu jari the nature of humility is that
it takes you to gratitude because when you
when you're in a state that tumbled before
Allah everything you see it in it's right
perspective that Allah has been so generous to
you that Allah has given you so much
that you don't deserve it you're undeserving of
it and that feeling of undeserving engenders in
you a feeling of gratitude because if you
feel you deserve something like the Moroccans say
la shukr alal wajib there's no thanks for
something that you deserve right and if you
feel that this is my wajib then that
by it's nature does not engender in you
a sense of gratitude towards the person you
just feel like la la la ataani ma
huwa haqqi he just gave me my right
you see so you have to once you
understand that and recognize you are undeserving and
that's why he's saying haqqirhu you know this
big mountain of kibar see it for what
it is it's insignificant meaningless and when you
do that you'll bring it down you'll bring
that down and Allah we say allahu akbar
and that's why even traditionally the Muslims anytime
they saw something in somebody or somebody that
you know mashallah take it back to it's
source allahu akbar Allah is greater it's a
reminder constantly allahu akbaru minni allahu akbaru minkum
allahu akbaru min al dunya wa ma fiha
allahu akbar and he's al kabir al muta
'ali and one of the things he says
to the muta'ali dhuq innaka anta al
aziz now you taste you're the aziz now
you're this one so taste the punishment tahakkur
min quran so the last thing here is
dhul and da'a now uh huh oh
you have to prepare for it so we'll
do that next week if
you're Allahumma
salli ala Sayyidina Muhammad wa ala aali Sayyidina
Muhammad kama sallita ala Sayyidina Ibrahim wa ala
aali Sayyidina Ibrahim wa baraka ala Sayyidina Muhammad
wa ala aali Sayyidina Muhammad kama baraka ala
Sayyidina Ibrahim wa ala aali Sayyidina Ibrahim wa
fi al alamin innaka hamidun majid Allahumma la
ilmah illa ma alamtana innaka antara hakeem al-'alim.
Allahumma a'allamna ma yanfa'una wa anfa
'ana bima a'allamtana wa zillna ilmah.
Allahumma inshara alayna rahmatak wa inshara alayna hikmatak
ya zalal jalali wa l-ikram.
Wa salillahumma ala Sayyidina Muhammad wa ala alihi
wa sahbihi wa sallam.
Inshallah, we're going to...
Actually, this section that you just received is...
That's to the end of this class.
So, we're almost done.
And, in terms of the second half of
the book...
The second half, I mentioned that last night
for some people.
It deals with the opposite.
After dealing with the diseases of the heart,
it deals with ornamenting the heart.
With the states and stations of certainty.
So, inshallah, I'm going to do that next...
After in February, starting.
We looked at Fakhar and Kibrun.
And, these are serious illnesses of the heart.
One of the things that has been pointed
out is the idea of the mean.
What's called al-wasyapa in Arabic.
Al-wasyapa is the mean.
And, one of the things, the dangers of
virtues...
Is that virtues are means between extremes.
With the exception of the extreme.
With the exception of justice, which is the
opposite of injustice.
So, it has an opposite, but it doesn't
have extremes.
Now, the next disease that he talks about
is a disease that is an extreme.
The virtue is humility.
Ziyadah leads to arrogance.
And, naqs, deficiency, leads to a state of
abasement or humiliation.
Which is not a virtue in Islam.
Some might argue, actually, in Christianity that it
is a type of virtue.
But, in Islam, it's definitely not a virtue.
So, he calls it a dhul.
And, in the Qur'an, Allah, subhanahu wa
ta'ala, says that...
Dhulla was actually part of an affliction given
to Bani Israel for their disobedience.
So, it's actually the result of disobedience, often,
that Allah afflicts the people with this abasement.
For being arrogant, He abases them.
So, the sun never sets on the British
Empire, and then it sets.
And then, the British Empire, the lion of
Great Britain, becomes the tail of America.
So, that's a humiliation for the Anglo-Saxons
of Britain, who have always seen the Americans
as the colonies.
I mean, these are like the low people
of...
And now, those low people are now dictating
for them their own foreign policies, etc., etc.
So, that's what Allah does with people.
And, it'll come to the Americans as well,
just like it comes to everybody else.
Their turn is coming as well.
It's just a matter of time, and it's
already a lot of signs and indications for
that.
So, you can have dhul as a social
phenomenon of a people.
Many of the Muslim countries are in this
status now.
You'll find Muslims, unfortunately, who will do unbelievable
things, just lie, cheat, steal to get a
visa to a European country or America.
Inside their countries, they'll do things that are
just shocking in terms of their own human
dignity.
And, it all has to do with this
lowliness, humiliation.
So, you can have it afflicted with a
people.
Now, despite that, you can also have a
people that are afflicted with great tribulations, and
they maintain their human dignity, which is a
whole other thing.
So, al-mu'minu la yudhillu nafsa.
The mu'min never humiliates himself.
He never abases himself.
There's a hadith, al-mu'minu la yudhillu nafsahu.
He does not abase himself.
So, when we talk about humility, it's not
humiliation.
You don't humiliate yourself.
You humble yourself.
And, so he says, adhulla wa ba'ata.
Ba'a is to be low.
And, the Prophet ﷺ said, Nothing raises itself,
illa wa ba'ahu Allah.
Except Allah will abase it.
That's the sunnah of Allah and His creation.
If you raise yourself, Allah will abase you.
And, so that's really important.
Because, these are wisdoms, you know.
And, now, with Allah, you should have dhul.
With Allah, you should be dhalil.
But, not with His creation.
So, before Allah, you should be dhul.
You know, you should have a sense of
dhul, wal hawan, wa ba'a.
Before Allah, subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And, that's why, Sidi Abu Qadir al-Jilani
said, He saw all of the doors to
Allah.
And, they were all crowded, except for one.
Dhul wa tawad'u.
The door of humility and humbleness.
And, so, he said to people, Halumma ir
'a rabbikum.
You know, come, you want to get to
your Lord?
This is the door.
Because, nobody is there.
So, it's hard on the nafs.
And, so, he warns just not to do
that.
And, then, he says, Wakbur alil ghaniyil mustakbiri.
Not only that, be proud in front of
a rich, arrogant person.
Right?
Somebody said, you know, The noble things of
this world are a ghani mutawad'i.
Right?
A rich man who is humble.
That's a nobility.
And, a sunni sharif.
A sharif who is a sunni.
It's like, that's one of the noble things.
There's other ones that they mentioned.
But, al ghani al mustakbir is the norm.
Rich people.
Inna al-insana layat'ghaa arra'aahu astaghnaa.
Haven't you seen how the man, when he
becomes wealthy, independent, he deems himself independent.
When he becomes rich.
And, that causes him to transgress.
So, he transgresses the boundaries of Allah.
Because, he has wealth.
And, that's why, like Nimrod.
You know, because Allah gave him dominion in
the earth.
He thought he was God.
You know.
Or, he argued with Ibrahim.
And, this is what wealthy people do.
Right?
They think, because they have wealth, it gives
them a right to have an opinion about
everything.
To be an expert on everything.
To, etc.
etc.
It's a big, it's a serious thing.
So, he said, you know.
At-takabburu fee wajha al-mutakabbiru f-sadaqa.
It's a hadith.
And, in riwayah, ibadah.
The second person is ibadah.
The next disease is, karahat al-dhim.
Dhim is blame.
Insan, it means to blame him.
You know, ahummah.
Dhim is to blame.
The nature of the human being is, he
does not like to be blamed.
That is part of our nature.
It's inherent in the human being.
We don't like to be blamed.
We teach it to our children early on.
We praise them for things.
And, we blame them for other things.
And, they start seeing that the praise is
nice.
Because, it goes with it.
Smiles, gifts, ah, love, hugs, whatever.
And, the blame is painful.
Because, usually, it goes with that.
Ah, frowns, anger, raised voices, sometimes, ah, physical
abuse.
These type things.
So, we teach early on, ah, children about
praise and blame.
And, they learn very quickly to want praise
and to, to dislike blame.
The problem is, is that, it becomes a
disease.
Karahiyatu dhim.
Because, there's a lot to be learned, ah,
first of all, in them.
But, also, ah, some other things, which he's
going to clarify here.
He says, karahatu dhimmi banan ma'lufu.
It's a well-known disease.
Wannathuru al'ibadi walwukufu ma'hum.
Hijabun an maqam al-ihsan.
So, what he's saying is, displeasure with blame
is a well-known disease of the heart.
Concern with creation's opinions and desiring their praise
and displeasure with their criticism becomes a barrier
between you and the station of ihsan.
Because, what you start doing is you start
doing your actions in order to be blamed
or praised.
And, one of the things in the seerah
class, Sa'd ibn Mu'adh, radhi Allah anhu,
when they bring him to do, the Prophet
says to the Aus, will you accept, because
the Bani Quraidah were confederates of the Aus.
And, because the Khazraj got Bani Nadir off
the hook by the intercession of Abdullah ibn
Ubaid, the Aus want to get the same
for Bani Quraidah.
So, the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam, Bani
Quraidah was actually much worse what they did
than Bani Nadir.
Right?
I mean, it's all relative, but the fact
that they were joining the army.
Bani Nadir were attempting to assassinate the Prophet,
which is actually worse.
You know, in the big picture of things.
But, the point is is that Sa'd ibn
Mu'adh said a really important thing.
When he came out, they were telling him,
please you know, have the Prophet forgive him,
just like the Bani Nadir got off.
And, he said, I have reached a point
where in my mawqif, I have no fear
for the I'm not worried.
He was about to die.
He said, I'm not in a position to
be worried about what people are going to
say.
See, because what Aus was worried about was,
what are people going to say?
These are our confederates and if they all
get killed, they'll say the Khazraj got their
confederates off, but the Aus didn't get their
confederates off.
You see?
So, they were thinking about what people are
going to say.
Sa'd ibn Mu'adh said, I'm not worried
about, I'm about to meet my Lord.
I'm not concerned about what people are going
to say.
So, he said, al-ana you know, now
wajittu nafsi fi maqamin laa khafu fihi laumata
la'im.
I found myself in a place, which is
right before death.
I'm not worried about what people are going
to say.
The point of that is, the reality of
it is, you are in that moment at
every instant of your life.
You know, death is, it's just a veil
to think that you, that's thool al-amal,
which is another disease.
It's a veil from Allah to make you
think, oh, I'm going to you know, be
around.
It's a complete illusion.
You have no guarantees whatsoever.
And so, what this is saying is, Ihsan
is, that's where Sa'd was.
He was in maqam al-ihsan.
All he could see was Allah.
He wasn't concerned about creation.
And that's the point with this karahiyat al
-dham.
You start worrying about what other people are
going to think, and that will often prevent
you from doing the right thing, because very
often the right thing is what everybody else
is going to be against.
And that's the nature of the world.
So, taking the right position often means taking
the position that you will be blamed for
by others for doing it.
And very often, courageous stances, they become known
later on.
I mean, for instance, Geronimo is a good
example.
Geronimo was this evil, horrific barbarian when he
was fighting against the US cavalry.
Now, he's seen as a hero by both
the whites and the Native Americans as this
great freedom fighter, fighting for his land.
At that time, even his own people betrayed
him.
So, he was taking a position at that
time when even his own people were against
it, because they'd already mostly had surrendered.
He kept fighting till he was finally betrayed
by people around him.
But the point is that, you know, people
like Malcolm X, another example.
See, Malcolm X, once the enemy even co
-opts, and this is what they'll do, because
then the enemy will praise him because he's
no longer a threat now.
Enough time has passed where he's no longer
a threat, so we can co-opt him
now.
Right?
And this is what they'll often do.
But at the time, he was taking positions
in a society where everybody was against him.
You see?
And then later, when society maybe catches up,
or whatever, or he's no longer, then they
can say, but at that time, had he
worried about them, he wouldn't have been able
to say the truth.
And that's what people, that's what happens when
people are concerned with what other people think.
They're not able to take those positions that
are courageous for the very reason that they're
unpopular, and they're ones that you'll often be
attacked for.
And then he says, overcoming that barrier, so
getting beyond that is through the realization that
there's no benefit or harm.
Again, this is, if you notice, this is
often a cure for a lot of these
diseases, is really recognizing Allah, two names of
Allah.
These are two names of Allah, An-Nafi'
wa Dharr.
Nafi' is the one who benefits, and Dharr
is the one that harms.
And those are attributes of Allah, and no
one else has those attributes.
No one.
No human being has those attributes.
It's only Allah that can benefit, and it's
only Allah that can harm.
So if you're worried about what people think,
and it's preventing you from doing what you
should do for the sake of Allah, then
you're not seeing reality.
You're deluded.
You're in a delusional state, and you're seeing
things in a way that's not conducive to
your Iman, but it's also, it's simply not
in accordance with reality.
It really isn't.
So that's what you have to realize, all
of us have to realize, is Allah is
the only one that can harm or benefit
us, which is why the Prophet ﷺ said
to Ibn Abbas رضي الله عنه, when he
told him, he gave him some advice.
He said, إذا استعنت فاستعين بالله.
When you seek help, only seek help from
Allah.
وإذا سألت فسأل الله.
And if you ask, only ask from Allah.
And then later he says that you have
to know that even if all of creation
got together to harm you, they couldn't harm
you except with what Allah decreed for you.
And if they got together to benefit you,
they couldn't benefit you except with what Allah
has decreed for them to benefit you for.
So, creation can't do anything to you.
They can't harm you, and they can't benefit
you.
Now this obviously does not mean not recognizing
the أسباب and saying, oh well, you know,
the Prophet ﷺ on the Battle of Uhud
wore two chain coats of armor.
These are أسباب.
Now he knows more than anybody else, there's
no harm and there's no benefit from Allah
except from Allah.
But that doesn't negate using the intellect and
recognizing we are in a world of أسباب.
Right?
And also this means also diplomacy.
Because sometimes, like the poet said, أَقَدْ خُطُوا
حَقٌ وَلَكِن مَا كُلُوا حَقٍ يُقَالُوا.
I said the truth but it shouldn't always
be said.
So, it's discreet and it's intelligent not to
say the truth.
You have to look and see things.
I mean, I know a friend of mine,
a Libyan delegation that was in Iraq and
they were at this big thing.
He was an Azhari graduate and they were
all toasting and one of these you know,
sheltane is making a toast to the Ba
'ath party.
Right?
And this Libyan man, he's an older man
you know.
He died recently.
But he said لَعْنَ اللَّهِ حِزْبِكُ وَمَنْ دَعَلَهُ.
And he started cursing.
This is a big, they were official delegation.
He said, may Allah curse your party and
curse anyone that calls, that prays for it
and curse.
They were there with him.
They suddenly thought this is it, you know.
And they start telling him, you know he's
you know, he's a little he's got some
screws loose and we brought him along.
He's a good family and everything but don't
pay any attention to him.
And nothing happened to them.
But the point is I mean, you shouldn't
have gone there in the first place.
Right?
There's no reason to be there supporting those
people but that was not really a very
sagacious thing to do.
Simple as that.
You know.
So you have to, Allah reward him كلمة
الحق أمام سلطان الجائر.
So, Allah reward him.
He was a strong man.
He was a good man.
But the point is is that, you know,
that you can do that.
And the Prophet ﷺ said he said, عَظَمُوا
جِهَادًا The great and the Sultan is speaking
the truth in front of an oppressive tyrant.
That is the greatest jihad.
And if you die for it, you know,
you're shaheed.
There's no doubt.
But that's not always called for in certain
instances.
In other words, if there's benefit in long
term, if there's benefit and this is the
nature of الحرب الخدع that war is strategy
and things like that.
So there are situations where you really have
to do, weigh things out measure things out.
And then he says يَسْتُمَّ الْحَرَامُ مِنْهُمَا جَرَّ
إِرَاءً مُحَرَّمًا كَمَا الْغَزَّالِ فَالصَّلَاءُ الْغَزَالِ And then
he said, the impermissible from this disease is
what in turn leads to the prohibited.
Just as Imam Al-Ghazali has clarified.
So in other words, what is haram from
because it's a natural thing to not like
to be censored or blamed.
But what he's saying is haram is what
will lead to the haram.
So for instance, if you should do أَمْرُ
بِالْمَعْرُوفِ النَّهِيَ عَنِ الْمُنْكَرِ But you're worried about
what are they going to say or what
are they going to think or what.
And so it stops you from doing an
obligation out of fear of لَوْمَةَ الْلَائِمِ Right?
The blaming one, the one who blames you
out of fear that you don't do what
the obligation.
Or you're in a place where you should
pray but your co-workers, you start thinking
what are my co-workers going to think
if I ask to go out and pray
because it's not very popular thing in America,
right?
To pray.
So you start thinking you know, oh what
are they going to think?
They might talk about me or they might
say I'm...
That is clearly كَرَهِيَةَ ذَمْ where it's not
appropriate.
In other words, being worried about having people
think badly of you for doing things that
are not good things that is a good
thing and it's a normal thing.
Alright?
So what is haram from this and the
disease is those things that will prevent you
from fulfilling your obligations.
Now another thing about this disease which is
important is the fact that real Iman does
not get established in the heart.
According to the tradition of Ibn Mas'ud
لَا يَمِنُوا حَتَكُمْ حَتَّى يَسْتَوِي فِيهِ الذَّمُّ وَالْمَدْحُ
until blame and praise is the same.
In other words, you're doing it for Allah
and you don't really care what other people
think.
That is real Iman.
That when you are doing something for the
sake of Allah and if somebody praises you,
big deal.
If somebody blames you, big deal.
I did it for the sake of Allah
and Allah knows that.
And that's what you're concerned with.
You're not concerned with the eyes of others.
So that's a really important point.
The perfection of sincerity.
You know, another thing just a little side
track.
One of the things that I learned in
West Africa which was really good, I thought
was one of the things they never do
in the desert is they never have little
children do displays of like their memorization of
Quran or you know like oh come on,
let's hear you say this or that and
then everybody says Ahsanta!
They don't ever do that.
They don't display the children.
And I think that's really a harmful thing
for children to do that personally.
Because it leads to a desire for doing
these things for praise and it begins the
roots, the early roots of Riyadh and a
desire for showing off and things like that.
And obviously, I mean there's people that want
to show off their children which is natural.
And I think even Sayyidina Umar r.a,
when Ibn Umar, he was in a gathering
and the Prophet asked which tree is like
the palm tree?
It's like the mu'min in the desert.
And so they all started mentioning all these
different trees.
It's amazing the obvious is often hidden from
everybody because the most obvious thing was the
palm tree.
And nobody could get it.
They're saying, you know, the Qalha, you know,
Zainab, all these different trees and Abdullah Ibn
Umar was there and he was thinking it's
the palm tree.
But he was too embarrassed because there were
big Sahaba there and he was a young
boy.
Abu Bakr was there, Umar and Uthman and
so he didn't want to say anything.
So when he went out, he told because
nobody got it.
Finally the Prophet told him and he told
Umar, you know, I knew it was the
palm tree.
And he said, I would have loved for
you to have said that.
You know, in other words, he would have
been proud for his son to have said
that.
Because he's Ibn Al Khattab.
The next disease is antipathy towards death.
Karahiyatul Mawt.
And he says about it, Karahatul Mawti bi
haythu yanfiru minhu wa ya'nafu idha ma
yudhkaru.
Hatta ka anhu bi dhawqi kulli nafsin lahul
ladhi ata dhu jahli.
So he says, antipathy towards death, this dislike
of death, having a natural dislike, is when
one flees from it and becomes annoyed when
it happens to be mentioned.
As if he is completely ignorant of Allah's
words, kullu nafsin dha'iqatul mawt.
Allah says, every soul will taste death.
So it's our inevitable end in this world,
is death.
And each one of us will taste it.
And so a dislike of death, he's saying,
is when one flees from it.
Qul inna hadha al-mawtalladhi tafirruna minhu fa
innuhum wa laqeekum.
Thumma turadduna ila alam al-ghayri wa shahada.
Say that this death that you're fleeing from,
you're going to meet up with it.
Tu laqeel.
You know, you're going to meet it.
And then you'll be returned to the knower
of the seen and the unseen worlds.
And he will tell you, inform you.
So death is inevitable and if you flee
from it, or there's people like in this
culture, which some people term it a death
denial culture.
I mean Muslims, this is less so for
Muslims than it is for non-Muslims.
Non-Muslims actually will avoid mentioning death.
They don't like to talk about it.
They don't bring it up in conversation.
It's actually considered almost a bad manners to
bring up death in this.
You know, I was on a I had
to go get a passport and I was
in the federal building and I was going
up and there were these two guys I
don't know who they were but they looked
kind of like bureaucrats.
One of them said, well I'm just waiting
for that guy to die.
And anyway, he's about to drop dead anyway.
And the other guy said well he's pretty
sick isn't he?
He said yeah, he's going to die any
minute, you know and I'm really looking forward
to it.
And then the guy said he said he
said why?
And he said well it's just going to
be nice being in a world without him.
And then the other guy said maybe we'll
die before him.
And he said no, he's almost dead.
You know and that's, it's interesting.
That's a real death denial where you only
see death in terms of illness or you
know and I'm healthy and I'm you know,
I'm young.
He's in his deathbed.
You know, what if we're in Los Angeles
and we get an earthquake and suddenly you
know, so there's a deep ghafla that people
go into about death.
It's a deep ghafla.
They really don't believe that they're going to
die.
And if they do, it's just lip service.
Oh, well that's a long way off.
So, So, when you hear death and it
literally bothers you.
I don't want to talk about that.
Let's not talk about that.
Let's change the subject.
This is depressing.
This is morbid.
That's not from our tradition.
And in fact, the Prophet ﷺ the Prophet
ﷺ once passed by a group of people
who were laughing in a majlis and he
said, Mix your gatherings with remembrance of the
destroyer of pleasures.
Right?
In other words, it brings a type of
sobriety and weight to a gathering that sometimes
gets a little too frivolous.
Which is not to say people can't enjoy.
I mean, you don't want to be morbid
and be, right?
But the point is that people can get
together and that's all they do.
It's just a frivolous gathering where there's no
substance and there's no tathkir.
And that's what the Prophet ﷺ was warning
us about.
Of being in majlis al-ghaflah.
Because the Prophet ﷺ said that there's no
hour in this life that you will regret
except one that you spent without remembering Allah.
In the akhirah.
There's no hour in the dunya.
And he also said in another one that
anyone who sits in a gathering and then
gets up from that gathering and has not
remembered Allah, it's as if he got up
from a dead carcass.
It's just carrion.
It's jifa.
So it's important that as humans we were
created to worship Allah.
And as humans we're inclined to intimacy, to
gatherings and things like that.
So our gatherings should not just be for
pure enjoyment.
There should be some purpose getting together to
discuss things of importance to us.
Things like that.
So that's important.
To make dua for people, things like that.
Now then he says this is ma'dudatun min
jumrat al-amradi.
This is reckoned to be among the diseases
of the heart.
farda bimallahu ta'ala qadi.
So be content with what Allah has decreed
for you.
Be content with what Allah the Exalted has
decreed for you.
That apostrophe shouldn't be there.
So the point is that if you are
in a state of death acceptance, it won't
bother you.
And accepting death is accepting the decree of
Allah.
Because Allah, you know like one shaykh told
me once, he said we're all on death
row.
We were in a gathering and he said
we're all on death row.
We're just waiting for the executioner to come.
Right?
Huh?
Allahu Akbar.
Right?
I mean we're all on death row.
We've all been condemned to death.
We're just waiting.
Right?
And so once you realize that the one
who condemned you to death was the one
who gave you life in the first place.
So you should be content.
Because he's done it for a wisdom.
There's a wisdom in it.
And you know from another point of view
death is a celebration for the Muslims.
Right?
Death is a celebration for the Muslims.
Like the man who said, His death was
Allahu Akbar.
That's the end.
Shaykh Ibn al-Habib said, In death, for
the mu'min there's a thousand just repose.
He said, In this world, as long as
you're in this world there's not a cell
in your body that can't have pain and
disease in it.
Once you're out of this world, all of
that ends.
So there's a raha in death.
And another time he said that death for
the mu'min was like going from the third
class compartment to the first class compartment.
Right?
I mean it's just the conductor comes and
he tells you, No, no, you shouldn't be
here.
Come up to first class.
What do you say?
No, no, no.
I don't want to go.
I like it here.
I'll stay here in third class.
You can say, Oh, great.
It's like when they get you on the
airplane sometime, they bump you up to first
class.
You're not upset about it.
Right?
Alhamdulillah.
So that's it.
For the mu'min it's not a bad thing.
Right?
And that's why our morning is only three
days.
I mean I had a professor, I had
a course called Death and Dying and this
professor said that one of the worst things
about this country is the industry of mourning.
And he said it's a disservice to people
that they, there's this whole industry of mourning
that goes around death and this idea of
dragging on the mourning period.
A lot of people will go into mourning
for like years and they'll go to therapy
and do all these things to get over.
That's all love of dunya and connect to
dunya.
People of Allah, you know, when you accept
Allah and you accept, if Allah takes your
beloved, khalas.
Allah took that person.
Allah took that child.
Allah took and it's painful.
The professor felt pain.
He cried.
But it's Allah who did it.
And we have to be pleased with what
Allah does and that's why the mu'min is
the one who's able to go through that.
And another thing about the Muslims, which is
amazing.
No, as far as I know, definitely not
the Europeans, but no people can deal with
death like the Muslims do.
And if you look at calamities and tribulations
when they befall the Muslims, you see where
the Muslims are at.
And when you see the opposite happen to
the non-Muslims, they're committing suicide.
They fall apart.
The Muslims are able to, because of that
that strength with Allah and that connection that
they have, a divine connection with Allah.
And that's why they're able to do things
that other people can't do.
And that's why we're able to deal with
death.
And Maurice Boucaille, the French doctor, one of
the things that he said that got him
interested in Islam was how Algerians died in
France compared to the French people.
He was so impressed with North Africans, the
way they faced death.
And if you've seen, because I've worked on
hospital wards where people were dying, and it's
amazing.
You see people in this culture, a lot
of them, they can't die.
They don't know how to die.
They don't have a clue.
And if you watch a Muslim, especially a
devout Muslim, if you watch a devout Muslim,
he's been practicing for death his whole life.
Right?
So when it comes, he's ready for it.
You know, and Shaykh Uthman Bashir Uthman, Rahimullah,
who is a close friend of mine, he
was in his early 80s, and he grew
up in Eritrea, and he came to the
U.S. actually, and I told him about
Darul Islam, and he said, we have to
go there.
And he wanted me to go with him,
because he couldn't speak Arabic, and take it
all.
And so we went, and then he went
back to Medina, and he died right after
that.
And one thing he told me, he told
me that he knew he was going to
die in Medina, because he told me his
Shaykh, when he was in Eritrea, when he
was a young man, he told him, there's
going to be a lot of fitn in
this country, there's going to be, the communists
will take over, and you're going to have
to flee.
But Allah, Inshallah, will open up a place
for you in Medina, and you'll go live
there, and you'll die there, and you're going
to be buried in Baqiya.
He told me that, I heard that from
his lips.
And this is what they call kashf, which
happens.
Some of the people of Allah, Allah give
them, it's not like a revelation, it's not
revelation, it's just Allah give them a type
of opening, and they see things, and they
can tell people sometimes.
And he told me, he always thought his
Shaykh was just kind of saying nice words
to him, and he said, after he died,
sure enough, communists took over, he was a
wealthy businessman, he had to flee, and a
place was open for him in Medina, and
he ended up getting citizenship there, and he
lived his whole life, he traveled all the
time, and he told me, he said, I
really feel, Inshallah, I'm going to die in
Medina.
They took him back to Jeddah, and he
was in the hospital there, and I have
the card from Dr. Omar, told me everything,
how he died.
He was in the hospital in Jeddah, and
he had cancer, and he was going to
die, and he had almost no strength, and
they had him hooked up to all this
stuff, and then he was there for a
while, and then one day, he told his
son, we have to go to Medina today,
and he said, the doctor said, no, no,
he can't leave, and he said, no, I'm
leaving today, they're going to drive me, my
son will drive me, and I'm leaving the
hospital, and his doctor was totally, said, no,
you're too sick, and you need to stay
here.
He said, no.
They took him that night, he went all
the way back, got to Medina, he did,
just said, La ilaha illallah, the whole night,
right before Fajr, he told his son to
say a few things to certain people, and
this and that, and then he said the
Shahadah, and died.
He was buried in Baqiyah, and the place
he was buried, when they went in, he
gave me a piece of the, from the
road that covers the Prophet's grave, because they
cut it up when they changed it, and
he gave me a piece of that, but
he, and he was buried with that.
But he, the place that he was buried
is right next to Imam Marik and Nafia,
where people aren't buried anymore, because it's in
the old Baqiyah.
But when they came in, they found there
was a dug grave there, and so they
just, they put him in that grave.
But he was prayed on, on Jum'ah,
he was the only person that died that
day, or that was, had Janazah that day
at the Prophet's Mosque.
So that, I mean, I'm just telling you
that story, because that is an example of
how you know, Muslims who know how to
die, die.
I mean, there's a story, Allah-u-An
'am, of it's truth, but it's, you know,
it's a story told in Persia about Faridur
-in-al-Ataar, who was a perfumer.
And he actually tells a story, I think,
that he, the way that he made his
tawbah to Allah was a man once came
begging for alms, and he told him, like,
why don't you get a job?
And he said, this is my job.
And he said, what do you do?
And he said, well, what do you do?
He said, I sell perfumes.
And he said, the most important thing that
you're ever going to do is die.
And he said, and I know how to
do that.
Ash-shadu an-la ilaha illallah, ash-shadu
an-mahlum bi-rasulillah, and he died.
So, there are people that do know how
to die, you know.
And whether that story's true or not, there's
a truth in it.
Huh?
Yeah.
I mean, there really is, there are people
that know how to die.
And when the time comes, they will know
what to do.
And there's other people that don't.
And when the time comes, they go into
a real state of confusion.
So, and that's one of the blessings also
of doing dhikr of death.
And another thing that our scholars have recommended
and the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam, based
on his hadith of remembering death, is to
go through the states of the akhira.
To actually go through visualization of dying, of
being washed, of being wrapped, of being put
into your grave, of having the dirt cover
you, and then being asked by the angels,
and then resurrection.
Of actually going through the states and the
mizan.
To reflect on those things as a practice
to do.
It's a very sobering type of practice to
do that.
Just to really get you out of the
sleep that we're in, in life.
Now, another thing he says here is that,
أَمَّ إِذَا قَلَاهُ لَا لِذَاتِهِ وَلَا لَلْإِنْسَرَامِ عَنْ
لَذَّاتِهِ بَالْخَوْفَ قَطْعِهِ عَنْ إِسْتِعْدَادِهِ بِطَاعَةِ اللَّهِ إِلَىٰ
مَعَادِهِ If he doesn't like death, not for
its death, because it's death, nor because it's
going to cut him off from the pleasures
of dunya, but if he doesn't like it
out of fear that he hasn't had enough
time to prepare for death, then that's a
good reason.
And the Prophet ﷺ encouraged you to desire
a long life, because he said, if you're
a bad person, you have time to make
up for the wrong you've done, and if
you're a good person, you have more time
to increase your good, and to strengthen your
صحيفة, or your scroll on the يوم القيامة.
So, we should have, and he mentioned that
about طول الأمد, that it was good to
desire, if you were in good deeds, it
was a good thing to desire a long
life for that reason.
And the Prophet ﷺ, about death, he once
said to Aisha رضي الله عنه من أحب
الله أحب لقاءه Whoever loves Allah loves to
meet Allah, and she said, يا رسول الله
الموت نكره الموت We don't like death.
And the Prophet ﷺ said that that was
normal.
That was a natural thing.
But rather, it was a dislike of the
akhirah, of meeting Allah.
You see.
So, the point is, is that the dislike
of death is obviously natural.
I mean, Allah has put it in our
body.
It's at a cellular level, that you don't
want to die, right?
And that's why, in certain instances where your
life's threatened, you go into a hyper state
of functioning, and you'll do things that are
really not at the conscious level to protect
yourself or others from death.
Right?
So, that is normal, and Allah has put
that in us.
That's a good thing, and that's why Ibrahim
ﷺ when he said, أَلَا تَأْكُلُونَ when he
offered them the food, the angels, and they
didn't eat, فَأَوْجَسَ مِنْهُمْ خِيْفًا You know, he
felt fear, and that fear was that they
were going to rob him and kill him,
or something.
So, that's a natural thing to have that.
And that's not what he's talking about there.
And then he says, أَوْفَوَّضَ الْأَمْرَ إِلَى مَوْلَاهُ
فَمَا يَشَٓى أَرْضَهُ أَوَبْقَاهُ If on the other
hand, also, if he completely entrusted his affair
to his master, and whatever he wills, either
felling him or giving him respite, contents him.
So, in other words, you don't mind.
Whatever Allah wants to do with you, you're
just content with that.
That's fine.
And so, both those positions are good positions.
And that's why he says, فَذَانِ مَمْدُحَانِ مَحْمُدَانِ
وَالْكُرْهُ لَا يُغْعِضُ مِنْ كَدَّانِ He says that
both those attitudes towards death are commendable and
praiseworthy in any way.
A dislike of the reality of death in
no way distances you from your death's proximity.
So, even if you don't like death, it
doesn't, you know, it's not going to do
anything.
It's not going to make it any more
distant from you.
It's much better to accept it for your
own state.
And the other thing that's important about this
is that one of the, well, he mentions
it here.
And then he says ذَاكِرُهُ يُكْرَمُ بِالْقَنَاعَ وَبِنَشَاطِ
قَلْبِهِ لَطَاعَ The one who remembers death much,
he's ennobled by certain characteristics, four things.
One of them is قَنَاعَ Because of your
remembrance of death, you tend to be more
content with what you have.
In other words, if you really think that
you could die anytime, there's going to be
more of an impetus to enjoy enjoy the
experience of life now instead of always thinking,
you know, eventually I'm going to get it
together as they say in America.
And that never happens, right?
So the point is قَنَاعَ And this is
the Prophet ﷺ said القَنَاعَةُ كَنزٌ لَا يَفْنَى
Contentment is a treasure that is never exhausted.
So قَنَاعَ is really important.
And the Prophet ﷺ said اللَّهُمَّ أَرْزُقَ آلَ
مُحَمَّدَنَا القَنَاعَ وَالكَفَافِ Oh Allah, give the family
of my family the family of the Prophet
ﷺ contentment and enough to live their lives
with.
So just give them enough to get by
and then make them content with it.
And that's why the قَنُوع, a person who's
in a state of قَنَاعَ, he's the only
wealthy person.
So a poor man whose content is a
rich man in reality.
A rich man whose discontent is a poor
man in reality.
Because فَقَر is want.
And قَنَاعَ is you have no want.
If you don't have want, you're rich.
Because the definition of a rich person is
that without need.
So if you don't have need, you're wealthy.
And that's why الغينة غين النفس The Prophet
ﷺ said real wealth is the wealth of
the soul.
Right?
الغينة ليس عن كثرة العرض It's not having
a lot of stuff.
وإنما الغينة غين النفس It's the contentment of
the soul.
And so when you remember death, Allah, one
of the blessings, He's telling you this is
a given, you're given قَنَاعَ.
And this is an age where people, there's
so many false needs and wants that are
inculcated in the hearts of people.
I mean that's what media is doing constantly,
just يَغْرِس You know, it's just planting the
seeds of فَمَع, of desire, of شَهْوَة, of
all these things in the heart.
And then He says, it also will give
you energy, right?
His heart's activity is directed towards obedience.
Right?
So, by remembering death, it will give you
a type of نشاط You become نشط, which
is to be energized, to do good deeds
because if you think about death, then it's
going to make you want to be more
obedient to Allah سُبْحَانَهُ وَ تَعَالَى.
وَبِبِدَارِي تَوْبَةٍ وَيُبْتَرَى.
And then also, the other thing that you're
given is you're given a a state where
you'll hurry to تَوْبَة.
If something does occur, if a slip does
happen and you do something wrong, it will
cause you to quickly make تَوْبَة, which is
rectifying things.
So تَوْبَة rectifies wrong actions and that's a
gift of remembrance of death because if you
do something wrong and then you say سُبْحَانَ
اللَّهُ, I'm accountable for this.
أَسْتَغْفِرُ اللَّهُ.
Then it causes you to actually ask Allah
سُبْحَانَهُ وَ تَعَالَى forgiveness.
Now, the opposite is true.
The one who forgets his death, he's given
those three opposites.
He will always want more.
He'll never have قَنَاعًا.
And he's also going to be يُرْسِلُ جَوَارِحَهُ
فِي المَعْصِيَة.
He'll do wrong actions because he's not worried
about death.
He's not thinking about death and the يوم
القيامة and the حساب and these things.
And then finally, he won't have remorse when
he does things that are wrong because he's
not really worried about what's going to happen
in the Akhirah.
Now, the next thing, this one really is
one of the most important in the whole
thing because شُكَر really is essential to the
deen of Islam.
And gratitude and the meaning in Arabic for
كافر, a كافر, one of the meanings is
كفران النعمة.
And this is why a Muslim can be
a كافر.
Right?
Because there's a كفر دون الكفر.
There's a كفر that's less than كفر.
Right?
And كفران النعمة, like one of the things
the Prophet ﷺ warned women against was كفران
المعاشرة, being ungrateful for their spousal companionship.
Right?
If Allah gives them a husband and then
they're ungrateful towards him.
Right?
So, they don't see that there's a blessing,
there's a نعمة in that.
Protection, taking care of the needs of the
person, etc.
etc.
So, the next disease is called oblivion to
blessings.
من عيوب النفس نسيان النعم وأصره الغفلة عما
بكم That's an ayah in the Quran.
وما بكم من نعمة فمن الله And there's
no نعمة that you have except that it's
from Allah.
So, you know, in this culture they say
you should count your blessings.
Right?
Count your blessings.
And, people that do that are actually quite
rare.
Because Allah says وَإِن تَعُدُّ نِعْمَةَ اللَّهَ لَا
تَحْصُوهَا If you count the blessings of Allah,
enumerate them, you will never encompass them.
So, just to go into this, one of
the things, وَبِدَوَامِ ذِكْرِهَا He's saying you should
always remember that ayah.
وَمَا بِكُم مِّن نِعْمَةَ فَمِنَ اللَّهِ Now, in
the Quran begins بِسْمِ اللَّهِ الرَّحْمَٰنِ الرَّحِيمِ Some
of the مُفسِّرون say that الرَّحْمَانِ is the
giver of جَلَائِلَ النِّعْمِ the big blessings.
الرَّحْمَانِ means المُنْعِمِ بِجَلَائِلَ النِّعْمِ and رَحِيمِ means
المُنْعِمِ بِتَقَائِقَ النِّعْمِ رَحِيمِ means the giver of
subtle blessings.
In other words, الرَّحْمَانِ the blessings of الرَّحْمَانِ
are easy.
Like health, it's obvious.
If all you have to do is say
to somebody Oh, thank God you're healthy and
they say you're right, you know.
الحمد لله على الصحة والعافية الحمد لله على
الإيمان But then there's all these other blessings
دَقَائِقَ النِّعْمِ For instance, the blessing of the
eye, the fact that the eye is lubricated.
Now there's some people that have to have
these vizine type things because they get dry
eye.
And what happens when your eyes are dry,
you blink what the blinking is doing is
cleaning the eyes.
Right?
And it also protects it because you've got
these eyelashes and it's very fast.
If the eye, if you look just a
slight piece of hair gets into the eye
it's really troublesome.
So, Allah made this eye, you have this
blinking that protects your eye from being harmed
and then he also put sockets in there
so the eye is slightly back in the
skull in order to be protected from blunt
wounds and things like that.
People that don't get the lacrimation of the
eye they have to put drops in the
eye because it hurts so much.
Or people that can't close their eyelids or
people that lose their eyelids.
There's actually people that lose their eyelids.
So that, I mean there's all these and
then just the eye itself.
If you look at the all the colors
that the eye gives.
So, if you start looking at the body
and realizing that the whole thing is all
ne'am, the fact that you're balanced because
people that lose their ear, they get a
disease in the ear because balance is actually
part of it is related to the ear
and the nerve in the ear.
So, if you have 8th ear damage people
actually start losing their balance and they can't
stay up because they're not.
So, balance itself is a ne'am from
Allah.
The fact that you actually when you're standing,
you're balanced.
There's people that don't have that.
Right?
And then the way you eat all of
that is a ne'am from Allah.
The digestive juices that you're not even aware
of that are going in and then breakdown
of the food and all the separation of
all these things are hidden ne'am.
That are hidden from.
We don't even think about it.
The cerebellum and the the the whole way
the brain is working at a subconscious level.
Breathing.
You don't have to remember to breathe.
You don't have to do anything.
These are all ne'am that Allah has
given you and often time we're not even
aware of it.
Right?
The thumb itself.
The opposable thumb.
Other animals can't do that.
Right?
And Allah says, قَدْ كَرَّمْنَا بَنِ آدَمْ We
ennobled Bani Adam.
Some say it was that He gave us
the thumb.
And the word in Arabic for thumb is
ibham which is the strange thing.
Mubham.
You know, it's a strange thing.
Because other creatures don't have that.
So, the thumb is a big ne'am
of Allah.
Right?
You know, the great used to cut off
his enemy's thumbs.
Right?
So, they couldn't fight him again.
Because you lose your thumb, you can't do
anything.
So, and then all the pleasure that Allah
has given you.
Your taste buds.
That's a ne'am.
Allah could have made your food rocks and
He could have made your water brackish.
He says that in the Quran.
It could have been horrible to taste and
you'd still have to drink it.
But He made it sweet.
He could have made all the foods taste
the same.
But He gave like lemons for people who
like sour things.
And honey for people who like sweet.
He gave all these different things.
And then He gave you different taste buds.
To where you could actually enjoy the different
things in it.
So, all of these, this idea of reflecting
on the ne'am.
One of the things Imam al-Ghazali says,
he said, look at your food.
Allah says that in the Quran.
فَلِنظُرْ الْإِنسَانُ إِلَىٰ طَعَامِ إِنَّا صَبَبْنَا مَا أَصَبَّ
ثُمَّ شَقَقْنَا الْأَرْضَ شَقَّا We brought down the
rain and then we split the earth.
And you can see it when the rain
reaches and the seed it says اختَرَتَ بِهِ
نَبَاتَ الْأَرْضِ.
It mixes with the seeds of the earth.
And then when it splits open.
فَارِقُ الْحَبْ وَالنَّوَى Allah is the splitter.
When Allah splits that open, it causes the
earth to break forth.
So Allah is doing all that.
And so He tells, فَلْيَنظُرَ الْإِنسَانِ Let a
man look at his طَعَامِ رَطَعَامِ نَصَبَ بْنَمَا
صَبَّةٍ مَّا شَقَقْنَا أَرْضَ شَقَّةً فَأَنْبَتَنَ بِهِ حَبًّا
وَعِنَبًا وَقَبًّا وَزَيْتُونًا Right?
All these things Allah has given, the inab,
the grapes, the zaytoon, olives, the dates, all
of these things, the fodder, the animals eat
and we benefit from, secondarily, right?
It's in there, abba, how we benefit from
abba, benefited secondarily.
They didn't know that then, you know, the
transformation of all that through meat and the
animals eat it and then we eat the
meat and we get that secondarily.
So that's Allah saying, look at those things,
reflect on them and realize that's all from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The more you do that, then the less
inclined you are to forget the ni'ma of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and you'll honor
the ni'ma and the importance for this cannot
be underestimated.
Why?
Because He says here, وَذِكْرَ الْآيَةِ الْمُرْجِفَاتِ غَيْرِهَا
Remember the other ayahs that should put fear
in your hearts.
إِنَّ اللَّهَ لَا يُغَيِّرُ مَا بِقَوْمٍ حَتِّي يُغَيِّرُ
مَا بِأَنفُسِهِمْ Allah does not change the blessings
of a people and turn them into the
opposites until they change themselves by not showing
Him gratitude for them.
That's how that verse is interpreted by the
scholar.
إِنَّ اللَّهَ لَا يُغَيِّرُ مَا بِقَوْمٍ Allah gives
you a ni'ma and He won't take it
away from you until you show ingratitude for
it.
Allah says, ذَلِكَ بِأَنَّ اللَّهَ لَمْ يَكُون مُغَيِّرًا
مُغَيِّرًا نِعْمَةً أَنْعَمَهَا عَلَىٰ قَوْمٍ حَتَّى يُغَيِّرُ مَا
بِأَنفُسِهِمْ That is because Allah will not change
the blessing that He has given a people
until they change themselves through ingratitude.
And the poet said, إِن كُنْتَ فِي نِعْمَةٍ
فَرْعَاهَا إِنَّ الْمَعَاصِي تَزِيرُ النِّعْمِ If you're in
ni'ma, guard it because disobedience takes away your
ni'ma.
If you're disobedient to Allah, you lose your
And that's why Al-Waqi' when he was
asked when he was young, when he was
old he could move so quickly and somebody
asked him the secret of that and he
said, ثِرْكَ الْجَوَارِحْ حَفِظْنَاهَا لِلَّهِ فِي سِغْرِنَا فَحَافِظَهَا
لَنَا فِي كِبْرِنَا These are limbs that we
guarded for Allah's sake when we were young,
and so Allah has guarded them for our
sake as we're old.
So if you protect the ni'ma that Allah
has given you, then that's the way you
maintain them.
قَيْدُ النِّعْمِ They say قَيْدُ النِّعْمِ الشُكَر That
keeping the ni'ma with you is gratitude.
تَأَذَّنَا رَبُّكَ لَإِن شَكَرْتُمْ لَأِزِيدَنَّكُمْ Allah has announced
to us, He's told us, if you show
gratitude for My ni'ma, I will increase you
in them.
I'll give you more.
So oblivion to ni'ma is a disaster.
It's a disaster.
And the other thing about this is what's
known as استدراج.
And استدراج is that Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala will allow you to continue on in
disobedience and increase you in blessings.
And you think that it's because Allah likes
you.
And that's what the man says in the
Qur'an when he says that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says that the man who
He's given blessings and things, he says رَبِّي
أَكْرَمَنِي My Lord, He's given me ikram.
And then فَإِذَا قَدَرْ عَرِزْقَهُ قَالَ إِنَّ رَبِّي
أَهَانَنِي فَيَقُولُ رَبِّي أَهَانَنِي When Allah makes it
constricted for him and difficult, he says, My
Lord, أَهَانَنِي He's insulted me, He's denigrated me.
So people see that if it's difficult, they
think that that's a sign that Allah hates
them.
If it's easy, they think Allah loves them.
Now this is an important point because there's
a few things happening.
In terms of ni'mah, first, what is a
ni'mah?
In other words, how do we identify a
If you look, there are things that will
benefit you.
They'll benefit you short term and long term.
An example of that would be like علم
and حسن الخلق, good character.
So things that benefit you in short term
and long term, that is a true ni'mah.
That is a true ni'mah.
Something that will benefit you in your dunya
and your akhirah.
That is pure, unadulterated ni'mah.
And then you have something that is نافع.
You have something that is ضر في الحال
والمآل.
It harms you in the short term and
the long term, like ignorance and bad character.
سوء الخلق And then you have something that
is beneficial in the short term, but in
the long term it's not good for it.
And there's a lot of things like that.
شهوات are generally like that.
If you eat a whole bunch, you're enjoying
it while you're eating, but then overeating is
bad for you.
It's just bad for you, simple as that.
So it's beneficial short term, long term it's
harmful.
And then there's other things the opposite of
that.
They're harmful in the short term, beneficial in
the long term, like suppressing the شهوات.
So stopping before you're full, that's difficult.
So يضرك في الحال, it's something you don't
really like in the short term, but in
the long term it's good for you.
And ignorant people see this as a ni'mah.
Ignorant people see the short term benefit that
has long term harm, they see it as
a ni'mah, and they like it.
And that's why they're not very intelligent.
Because people, intelligent people, the difference between intelligent
people and ignorant people is intelligent people look
at the عاقبة.
They always look at the long term.
Children can't look at long term.
And that was why one of those tests
that they did on the EQ test, which
I thought was really interesting, is the man
who did all the studies on children that
were successful later on in life.
I mean they have different criteria for success
than we do.
But the point of the test was, is
that they would take a child and say,
I'll give you, they'd leave cookies out and
they'd come in, oh can I have a
cookie?
And they'd say, I'll tell you what, you
can either have one now or you can
have two later.
And consistently the more intelligent ones would pick
the two later.
In other words, they were willing to put
off the short term gain for a long
term greater gain.
And that is intelligent.
That is a sign of intelligence in Islam.
العاقبة للمتقين The kuffar look short term, fourth
quarter.
The Muslims look long term.
Now, there's dunya, like for instance, one of
the things about the Jews, is that the
Jews are good at that.
They're good at thinking long term benefit.
And this is one of the problems with
the Muslims now.
Muslims are very short sighted.
Which is a sign of our own stupidity.
We've lost the intelligence we had because we
left guidance.
And our intelligence is based on our guidance.
Because Allah won't give us tawfiq with other
than Islam.
Sayyidina Omar said, أعزنا الله نحن قومون أعزنا
الله بالإسلام فإذا طربنا العزة في غيره أذلنا
الله We're a people, Allah gave us dignity
with Islam.
And if we seek dignity from other than
Islam, Allah will humiliate us.
You see, so it doesn't work for us.
The rules are different for the Muslims and
the kuffar.
They're different.
I mean, there are sunnah that are fabric
for everybody.
But Allah will not give Muslims tawfiq except
with Islam.
It's impossible.
Whereas with the kuffar, He'll give them temporary
successes with their kuffar, with their disobedience.
Right?
But the long term, they're going to fail.
The long term, they'll always fail.
They have to.
So, Now, another thing that he mentioned, Imam
al-Ghazal, Oh, anyway.
Did I finish with this?
Yeah.
So, another thing about this is, there are
two types of ni'ma.
There are what are called usool al-ni'ma
and furoo al-ni'ma.
Usool al-ni'ma are the roots of the
ni'ma, which are the most important ones.
And then there's furoo al-ni'ma.
There's branches.
The usool al-ni'ma are things like health,
iman, Islam, safety in your body, and where
you live, and in your well-being, and
those things.
Those are the most important ones.
And then there's other ones that are embellished.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says about about
Talut in the Quran, when the Bani Israel,
you know, they say, how can he be
a king?
He doesn't have any money.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, He says,
inna Allah astataahu wazadahu bastatan fil ilmi wal
jismi.
Allah chose him, but not only that, He
gave him bastaa.
He gave him increase in knowledge and in
his body.
So this is, this is something that Allah
embellishes people with.
And that's why Sayyidina Umar said, idha ba
'athum rasoolan fa ba'athu hasan al-wajh.
If you send a messenger, send somebody with
a good face.
Right?
Because you want somebody to present, in this
culture, they call it personable person.
Somebody who's, you see them and there's an
automatic attraction to that person.
The reason for that is there's a wisdom
in it, that Allah has inclined the hearts
towards those people.
And so that's why the messengers were all
attractive to look at.
Leadership, one of the qualities that leadership has
is height.
Right?
To be actually tall.
That's something that many leaders have in history.
Napoleon is a serious exception.
To that rule.
But generally, people tend to follow, you know,
with kids, the tall one will often be
the leader of the gang and things like
that.
It'll either be the tall one or the
clever one.
Right?
One of the two.
Like Napoleon was clever, but he wasn't tall.
And he was in the end a very
stupid person.
But he was militarily at points.
So, you know, I could go on and
on about this one because it's a really
important one.
And I think everybody gets the idea.
One man once said to the Prophet, in
front of the Prophet, he asked for Allah,
subhanahu wa ta'ala, Allahumma inni asaruka tamaman
ni'ma Oh Allah, I ask you for the
completion of ni'ma.
And the Prophet said, Atadri ma huwa tamamun
ni'ma Do you know what tamamun ni'ma is?
And he said, la, he didn't know what
it was.
The Prophet, sallallahu alayhi wa sallam, said, dukhul
al jannah, to enter into paradise.
That's completion of ni'ma.
So, if you had a good life in
this world, it's a ni'ma from Allah.
And if you had iman, that's the greatest
ni'ma in the dunya.
But the completion of that ni'ma is to
enter into paradise with Allah, subhanahu wa ta
'ala.
Fadhkhuli fee ibadi, wadhkhuli jannati, enter amongst my
servants into my paradise.
That is the ni'ma.
And then Islam is the ni'ma of Allah
that He gave us.
Right?
Wa atmamtum alaykum ni'mati I have completed my
ni'ma of Islam.
Alaykum.
Right?
So, in this world, Islam is the ni'ma
that Allah has given us.
And then another thing that Sheikh Muhammad al
-Hajjar, who I met in Medina, I was
walking out with him to his car and
he said, right next to the Bab as
-Salam, he said, man asbaha mu'afan fee
bednihi, aaminan fee sirbihi, anduhu qutu yawmihi, faka
annama heezat dahu al-dunya bee hadhaafiriha.
Whoever wakes up in a healthy state, mu
'afa, right?
He's in a good state in his body.
And he's safe in his possession, in his,
what he has.
And he has enough to get through the
day.
It's as if he has the world and
everything in it.
Right?
That's a hadith from Tirmidhi.
So if you really reflect on that, if
Allah, if you woke up this morning with
aafiyah, with good health, and you're protected, you
don't, you're not fearing anything, and you have
enough just to get through this day, it's
as if you have everything in the dunya.
And so that's, that's a ni'ma that you
should be, all of us should be grateful
for.
So, branches would be things like ornamented ni'ma,
blessings that, you know, for instance, a house,
you need a place to live.
But if you have extra things in the
house, and furniture, and all those, those are
like furu'a ni'ma.
I mean it's, they're accessory ni'mas.
You don't really need them, they're more.
And the more ni'ma you have, the more
hisab you have.
And that's why when the Prophet once went
to a house and they had meat and
dates and cool water, and Allah said, ثُمَّ
لَتُسْأَلُونَ يَوْمَ إِذَا عَنِ النَّعِيمِ And then you
would be asked about the ni'ma, the blessing.
And the Prophet said, هَذَهُوَ النَّعِيمِ This is
the ni'ma we're gonna be asked about.
So some of the sahaba came to the
Prophet and they said, Ya Rasulullah, we realize
we don't have any blessings to be asked
about.
Because they, they weren't eating meat and dates.
So, Jibreel alaihi salam told the Prophet that
Allah wants to know, do they wear sandals
and do they drink cold water?
And the reasoning behind that is, is that
you can walk without shoes.
So that is a ni'ma to have shoes
on your feet.
And you can drink water that's not cold.
So if you drink cool water, the coolness
in it is a ni'ma that you'll be
asked about.
And you can just continue on from there.
To do, yeah, Sayyidina Ali, he said, أَعْقَلُ
نَاسَ الزُهَادِ The most intelligent people are people
that do without in this world.
And he said, وَأَحْمَقُ النَّاسَ الْبَخِيرِ And the
most stupid of people is the bakhir.
He said because he said his his maal,
maalahu, he said حُرِمَ مِنْهُ فِي الدُّنْيَا وَعُقِبَ
عَلَيْهِ فِي الْآخِرَةِ He doesn't get to use
it in this life and then he's punished
for it in the next world.
So he's an idiot.
Like the miser who won't spend even on
himself, he just hoards the money, that is
the stupidest person.
Because he's not enjoying it in this world
and it becomes a punishment for him in
the next world.
But the point is the zuhad, the zahid,
and that's a maqam.
He goes into that maqam.
Maqam is zuhad, doing without.
Now, the Prophet ﷺ was somebody who was
balanced in that in relation to our time
now, he would have been considered living you
know, way below poverty level.
In terms of modern, the way the modern
world looks at it, his actual, what he
was living with would be so little.
It's unbelievable.
But by no means was he impoverished, you
know, in the sense that he, his needs
were taken care of.
Right?
So, and he didn't worry about anything and
there was there was some difficulty with food
but Aisha r.a. said that there was
always dates and yogurt and milk and people
would send barley bread.
Sometimes two months would go by they didn't
see smoke and they asked her what they
were eating and she said, we used to
eat al-aswadayn, dates and water.
Good point.
I'm glad you said that.
Marad Tarhaaj, when I asked him, can you
be a zahid and have a lot of
wealth?
And he said, كان عثمان أزهد الناس وكان
عبد الرحمن بن عوف زاهدا Like Abdurrahman bin
Auf was a zahid and they were very
wealthy.
So here it has to do with the
heart.
If the heart's not connected to it, in
other words, if you have all this wealth
and you could lose it tomorrow and you
would be the same person, then that's a
sign you're a zahid.
But if you fall apart and go into
despondency and people can see that that person's
a broken person, they'll say, well, he used
to be rich and poor guy, he lost
everything and now that's what happened.
That means, you know, that his whole thing
was, it was all in the heart.
Whereas the zahid is the one, if it's
there with him, خلاص, he has it and
if he loses it all, الحمد لله And
that's why the Prophet said, he chose to
be hungry one day and full the next
day.
To keep him in that state where he
would never get used to one or the
other.
Right?
Because it's all about disattachment.
It's not being attached to all this stuff.
Right?
The next disease is الهزء And this
is derision, deriding people, making fun of people.
In the Quran, when Ibrahim, when Musa Alayhi
Salam tells the Bani Israel to sacrifice the
cow, they say, تستهزئوا بنا Are you making
fun of us?
Is this huzu?
And he said, أعوذ بالله أن أكون من
الجاهلين I seek refuge that I should be
from the ignorant ones.
From that, the ulema took it that استهزاء
is from جهل.
It's ignorant to have استهزاء towards people, to
make fun of people.
That's a type of ignorance.
And this can be lampooning.
Right?
Making caricatures of people, drawing funny things.
In this culture, you have comedians that make
fun of people and anybody that they take
as their target.
What he says about this, first of all,
that its cure is the same cure for
arrogance because it's a type of arrogance.
If you see them as less than you,
then it's kibbutz, then you're arrogant.
And this is why the Moroccans say this,
but it's actually from Sayyidina Ali.
They say, لا تحقر عبدنا عسى يكون لله
وليا Don't belittle anybody because he might be
a wali of Allah.
And the reason for that is, even if
you see a man drunk, vomiting on the
street, you don't know what his seal is.
Right?
And that's why Imam al-Qurtubi said, Umar,
when he was bowing down to idols in
Mecca, was still the beloved with Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Because Allah knows what the seal is.
So that Umar, who was bowing down to
idols that the Muslims could have looked at
and made fun of and what a stupid
idiot and a polytheist, etc, etc.
They didn't know Umar.
Right?
They were just seeing one stage.
And that's why it's very dangerous to judge
somebody where they are or make fun of
them or things like that.
And that's why Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says, In the Qur'an, يَا أَيُّهَا الَّذِينَ
آمَنُوا لَا يَسْخَرْ قَوْمٌ مِّن قَوْمٍ عَسَىٰ أَن
يَكُونُوا خَيْرًا مِّنْهُمْ Don't let one people mock
another people because maybe they're better than them.
وَلَا يَسْخَرْنَا النِّسَاءُ وَلَا تَسْخَرْنَا النِّسَاءُ عَسَىٰ أَن
يُكُونَا خَيْرًا مِّنْهُمْ And don't let a group
of women mock another group of women because
maybe they're better than them.
And he said that he did not say
anything and said even he really laughs at
them.
What did he say?
Allah Allah.
I don't know.
It might be.
But what I know is the Prophet was
commanded not to curse their God.
لَا تَسُبُّوا الَّذِينَ يَدْعُونَ مِنْ دُونِ اللَّهِ فَيَسُبُّوا
اللَّهِ عَدْوًا بِغَيْرِ عِلْمٍ Don't curse those who
call on other than Allah meaning the idols
because they will curse Allah out of ignorance.
And that's called صَدَّ الذَّرِعَة So, things like
burning the Israeli flag publicly.
Muslims do stuff like that or burning the
American flag.
What you're gonna do is have them go
and take Qurans or something and burn them
or stomp on them.
Or you're gonna have them go and take
a Saudi Arabian flag that has لا إله
إلا الله محمد رسول الله on it and
stomp on it and burn it.
So, you incite them to do something that
is not only bad for them but it's
also sacrilegious to us.
Right?
We don't want people cursing Allah.
So, you shouldn't do that.
There's no reason to do it.
And that's why the Prophet ﷺ in his
victories he was never boastful.
When he went into Mecca he went with
his head bowed down.
He didn't go in triumphant leader.
He went with his head bowed down.
Total humility.
And that, that's the great, that's the warrior.
I mean, that's the great.
Not that other one.
Because that's Jahiliyyah.
And that's Abu Jahal.
That's what those people do.
And we're supposed to be above that.
We're supposed to be in a real way.
Not, not in a, in a false way,
in a deep way.
No, no, no.
You can pray against your enemy.
It's mustahab to make dua for people.
For guidance.
That's mustahab.
It's not a wajib.
It's mustahab to make dua for people.
Some of the ulema said, don't curse Israel.
Because it was the name of a prophet.
The name of a prophet.
So, you know, but, I mean, the point
is, is that, and then also, you know,
a lot of Jews become Muslim.
They have throughout history and they still do.
Right?
And there are Jews that become Muslim.
There have been Israelis that have become Muslim.
So, they're human beings.
I mean, they're not demons.
They're human beings.
Right?
The Serbs are human beings.
I mean, there's been some good articles recently
just about the demonization of the Serbs.
The Serbs are our enemies and they did
some horrible things.
But they're human beings that can become Muslim.
What the Jihadi Arabs, Hind ate the bits
into the liver of Hamza.
And that's, it doesn't get much more barbaric
than that.
She became a Muslim.
Wahshi who killed him became a Muslim.
So, people can make Tawbah and they can
become Muslim.
And those people that did all those things,
you know, it'd be interesting to see what
they're like now, how they're sleeping at night,
you know, because people do things in war
and they pay for it for the rest
of their lives.
And more Vietnamese, more veterans of the Vietnam
War have committed suicide than died in Vietnam
in this country.
Right?
A lot of people don't know that.
So, they paid their price.
And the people at the Gulf War who
saw that carnage, you know, they'll pay their
price.
They're human beings.
They have hearts, you know.
I mean, all of you have worked with
non-Muslims.
They cry.
They have tears.
Allah said, you know, إِن يَمسَسْكُمْ قَرْحُونَ فَقَدْ
مَسَرَقَهُمْ وَقَرْحَ مَتْلُهُمْ If you're afflicted with something,
they get afflicted with it too.
Right?
So, we all bleed red.
Uh-huh.
Well, I mean, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
there's du'as in the Quran against the
Zalimeen.
So, anybody who oppresses, which is why the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said, رُبَّ قَرِئَنَّ الْقُرَانَ
وَالْقَرَانَ يَلْعَنَهُ Maybe a man's reading the Quran
and the Quran's cursing him.
Right?
Because Allah says, عَلَىٰ إِنَّ اللَّعَنَةَ لَعَلَىٰ الْكَاذِبِينَ
Isn't it that the la'na of Allah
is on those who lie?
If you're reading the Quran and you're a
liar, you're reading a curse on you.
Interestingly enough, that's all of the diseases.
Just this last thing here, he says, to
treat it with the same treatment that you
do with kibr, which we already went through.
And then also knowing that with the knowledge
that one's purpose in doing it is to
humiliate somebody else.
That's the reason you make istihzaa with another
person, is to humiliate them.
Yet, by doing that, a person is humiliating
himself with Allah and is recompensed with ignorance.
Allah says, لَا تَنَابَزُوا بِرَالْقَابِ Don't throw names
at one another.
Don't make fun of each other.
And then you'll be recompensed with
evil.
Now the next and final section on this
one is he goes into a comprehensive treatment
plan for the diseases of the heart.
Actions that purify the heart.
The root cause of the heart's diseases.
The source of good and bad character.
And then treatment with dhikr of Allah.
So inshallah, that will be the last section.
And then like I said, basically we've covered
that whole section.
Oh, there's one more thing before we end
the class.
I'm glad I remembered this.
Does anybody know the seven deadly sins?
Any ex-good Catholics in here?
Okay.
Pride.
There's an order.
Are you going in order?
No, pride is not.
Pride.
Anger.
That's not the three.
I know, but it's not three.
Envy.
It's not, gluttony is not.
Slaw.
Good.
Greed.
Gluttony.
And lust.
Now, of all these diseases, which ones did
he cover?
He covered pride.
He covered anger.
Envy.
Qasm.
Laziness.
Greed.
Now, did he cover those two?
He did?
Yeah, he deals with the cause, but he
doesn't deal with it as a disease.
Right?
He talks about a cause, but he doesn't
talk about the disease of Shehuah in there,
right?
Now, why do you think those two weren't
dealt with?
That's a good point.
These both are fitrah inclinations.
And this is why even in the Catholic
tradition, they were the last ones.
These were considered worse than these two.
Right?
Now, Imam al-Ghazali deals with these two
in an entire book that's been translated.
And I would really recommend the book because
it will augment this course that we did
called Breaking the Two Desires.
And it's actually two books.
And one of the books is translated by
Abdel Hakim Winter, T.J. Winter.
It's a brilliant translation with a lot of
really good notes also.
But he deals with these two separately.
And he calls it, Kasr al-Shehwatain, Breaking
the Two Desires of Gluttony and Lust.
Breaking the Two Desires of Gluttony and Lust.
Gluttony is fuel for lust.
In other words, lust generally will follow gluttony.
Not necessarily so causally, but generally.
Even people that do a lot of fasting
can still have trouble with that.
But generally, you can break it that way.
And that's why the Prophet s.a.w.
mentioned for the young people who couldn't afford
to get married, he said, فَعَلَيْكُمْ بِالصِّيَامِ Then
you should fast.
فَإِنَّ لَهُمْ فَإِنَّ لَكُمْ وِجَاءً Because it will
act like a...
The wija was a little bag that they
put on the goat so that it wouldn't
impregnate other goats.
It will act as a...
It will kind of repress that desire.
So gluttony and lust are two problems.
But they are fitra problems.
Hunger and the desire for food is part
of human nature.
And what one has to do is learn
to control it.
And then lust is also part of human
nature.
It's a natural inclination of human beings.
And the way to work with these two
is balance.
Not to eliminate them.
You don't want to eliminate shahwa and you
don't want to eliminate shahiya.
They are from the same root.
Desire for food, desire for sex.
They are not meant to be eliminated.
They are meant to be controlled.
That's all.
And the book is worth reading.
But I just wanted to mention that, about
that.
Because if you look out of those seven,
the first five he deals with and they
are really important.
But those two, he doesn't really go into
any detail.
He does mention shahwa in relation to causes
and things like that.
Inshallah, we are coming to a closure on
the diseases now.
And what he is going to deal with
now is actually a general or comprehensive treatment
plan for the diseases of the heart.
So he says, وَقَبُّوا أَمْرَادِ الْقُلُوبِ
الْجَامِعُ فَهُنَّا نَهْيُ النَّفْسِ عَمَّا تَتْفَعُ that the
treatment plan that's comprehensive and general for the
heart's diseases is to prohibit the self from
its own desires coupled with and then he
gives us وَالصَّغَبُ وَالسَّهْرُ اللَّيَالِ وَالصَّمْتُ وَالفِكْرَةُ وَهُوَ
خَالِي coupled with hunger, vigilance in the night,
silence and meditation in private.
Now, he says, رحمه الله that in order
to treat the self or the heart itself,
you have to prohibit the self from what
it desires.
Now, there's a hadith in which the Prophet
s.a.w. said, لا يؤمن أحدكم حتى
يكون هواه تبعاً لما يأتوا به In other
words, none of you truly believes until his
hawa, his caprice or his desire is in
accordance with what I have brought.
So in other words, the way you purify
your heart, all those things are haram, the
diseases that he just mentioned, so they're not
in accordance with what Allah and his messenger
have given us as guidance.
So Allah's messenger s.a.w. said, the
iman is not complete, in other words, your
heart is not sound until your hawa, the
desire of your heart is in accordance with
what I brought, which is huda.
And the way that you do that is
by prohibiting it from those very things that
aren't in accordance with it until you no
longer desire them.
And that's the idea of وَنَفْسُ كَطِفْرِي إِن
تَهْمِلْهُ شَبَّعَ لَحُبَّ الرَّضَاعِ وَإِن تَفْتَمْهُ يَنْفَطِمِي The
nafs is like an infant, if you neglect
it, it grows up, loving to suckle, but
if you wean it, it loses its desire.
Because the child, there's people in this culture
that, like Leche Leak, they breastfeed until 4
or 5 years old.
The child keeps desiring it.
Right?
And they just keep going.
But if you wean a child at 2
years, or even a year, or half a
year, whatever age you wean the child, I
mean Sharia prefers that it goes to 2
years.
And there's a wisdom in that.
And there was actually a study done in
Israel that proved, this is just a sidetrack,
that proved that they did a statistical analysis
of breastfeed children, breastfed children, and children that
weren't breastfed, and commendations in statistics are always
the problematic aspect of it, but they found
that there was an increase in the IQs
by 3 points for every month of breastfeeding.
That's what they found.
And...
I mean there's obviously a lot of variables
in a study like that, but I thought
it was interesting because the Prophet said in
a Hadith, Beware of the...
He said, إِيَّاكُمْ وَالْحَمْقَىٰ فَإِنَّهَا تُغَذِّي Beware of
the wet nurse who's not very intelligent because
she's nourishing the brain.
Right?
So that...
Traditionally they used to look for sagacious people
to hire as wet nurses and things like
that.
And obviously Halima, and really fascinating thing about
Halima Sa'diyah, رضي الله عنه, read her Hadith.
If you don't know Arabic, read her Hadith.
And it's one of the most sophisticated Arabic...
Every collection of Hadith that has that Hadith
in it, they always have to comment on
all the words she uses because they're so
difficult.
Right?
And in her, she was incredibly eloquent.
عَلَيْهَا السَّلَامُ She's the mother of the message
of Allah.
So...
So that's what he's telling us.
And that's where you get in the Qur
'an وَالْحَامَ مَقَامَ رَبِي وَنَهَى النَّفْسَ عَنَ الْهَوَى
فَإِنَّ الْجَنَّةَ هِيَ الْمَأْوَى The one who نهى
النَّفْس عَنَ الْهَوَى The one who fears Allah
مَقَامَ رَبَي And then actually prevents himself from
doing what it desires.
Right?
From doing what it desires.
So, that is something مُجَهَد قَمَعَ النَّفْس Literally
suppressing the nafs desire.
And this is self-discipline.
مَنْ دَانَ نَفْسَهُ You have to discipline the
soul.
If you discipline the soul, you'll be happy.
If you don't discipline the soul, you'll be
miserable.
And in this culture, you look at all
the self-help, all the things, it's all
about people who can't control themselves.
And that's why Islam gives us prayer to
learn how to become disciplined in our time
and in our days.
It gives us washing, becoming disciplined in cleanliness
and ritual.
It gives us the اَللَّهُمَّا صِرِعَتَ سَيْنِ مُحَمَّدٍ
fasting, which is all about learning discipline, of
disciplining the tongue, disciplining the stomach, the genitals,
all of the things that Islam brings, it
really relates to learning how to discipline yourself.
Because I guarantee if you don't have discipline
about time, you won't pray on time.
You have to have some, in order to
pray on time, you have to, especially in
this culture, because you don't have the Adhan
and you don't have mosques everywhere.
So you really have to keep that in
mind.
It's actually, it's so easy whenever you go
to the Muslim world from here, it's amazing
how easy it is to pray.
Incredible.
This is a huge difference.
Whereas here, there's a vigilance you have to
maintain.
But that's still a disciplining aspect.
So you have to discipline the soul, the
tongue, learning how to stop, you know, learning
how to, when you desire to backbite, catching
yourself, I don't want to do this.
You have to learn to do that.
It's a process.
And if you do it enough, it'll get
to the point where you're not doing it
anymore.
And that's where the Hawa becomes in accordance
with what the messenger brought.
So that's what he's telling us.
Now, then he gives us the way to
do that.
How do you, okay, what are the key
things that the soul wants?
Right?
Saghab, hunger.
In other words, the stomach, kasra shahwatain.
The stomach, by getting the stomach, you get
the genitals as well.
The stomach is the key impulse of people.
In other words, if you can learn to
control your food, and this is why one
of the Salaf, according to Imam al-Qashayri
said, for me to raise my hand from
the plate while I'm still hungry, is better
than spending the whole night in prayer.
Because that, if he can discipline that aspect
of himself, everything else will be easy.
Because it's very, and people, you watch people
don't get food.
Right?
Have big food naps.
Food naps.
There's some people have really big food naps.
If they don't get food, they start getting
angry.
Right?
They'll blame it on hypoglycemia.
No, there are people that do really have
that.
I'm not gonna make fun of that.
But, you know, there's people they get really
angry that the food's not on time.
You see them at restaurants, waitresses, and waiters
have to deal with that all the time.
Where's my food?
You know, well, there's 500 other people in
the place, and we do have a number,
and you came in to us, and, you
know, just take time.
People don't have that time.
They have to wait.
That's why fast food.
Right?
Go to the box, get this fast food.
That's America.
Quick, I need it now.
Give me my food.
And this is the infantile nap.
Because the baby, the first thing it does,
ah, what's it want?
Food.
The mother, the milk starts flowing when they
hear the baby scream.
Right?
So the baby is screaming because it wants
food.
And when it gets the breast, ah, it
just goes into a state of complete relaxation,
and the world is wonderful.
And so that is the infantile nap.
Right?
And this is what you have to, and
I have to, all of us have to
discipline in our souls the idea of being
able to do without food, and not getting
grumpy about it, and not worrying about it,
and recognizing you're not going to die from
missing a meal.
You will not die from missing a meal.
People say, I'm starving.
I'm starving.
You're not starving.
Really.
I mean, there are people that are starving.
They're dropping dead.
Really, there are people all over the place
that are, actually, they are hungry.
And that's part of what, you know, sahab,
and that's why the early, ah, shuyuk, all
focused on hunger more than anything else.
This does not mean become anorexic.
All they're saying is learn to discipline yourself.
Right?
You really, if you eat, I mean, two
meals a day is enough.
I guarantee you.
Two meals a day is enough.
You don't need more than two meals a
day.
Morning, late afternoon, that's all you need.
If you want morning, afternoon, then something light
at night.
But three meals a day.
And one of the amazing things in the,
there is a, a man, ah, who, he
was, um, Allahumma sari'a ala Sayyidina Muhammad.
He was from Yemen.
He was actually a Hanifi, from Bani Hanifa.
Ah, and I can't, his name, I can't
recall it right now.
He came to the Prophet, sallallahu alaihi wa
sallam, and, ah, the Prophet gave him, it's
in Al-Bukhari.
The Prophet gave him seven, ah, he gave
him a bowl of milk.
And he drank it.
And, ah, the Prophet said, would you like
more?
He said, yes.
And he kept giving to him seven bowls.
He drank all seven.
And then, after that, he became Muslim, the
next day.
And he came back, and, he could only
drink one.
And all the Sahaba were amazed, because the
night before they saw him drink seven, and
that night they only saw him drink one.
And he was, he was tough, you know,
desert Arab.
And they asked the Prophet, what's the wisdom
in that?
And he said, وَالْمُؤْمِنُ يَأْكُرُوا۟ الْكَافِرُ يَأْكُرُوا۟ مِنْ
سَبَعَةِ أَمْعَةٍ That the Kafir eats from seven
intestines.
وَالْمُؤْمِنُ يَأْكُرُوا۟ مِنْ مَعِينٍ وَاحِدٍ But the Mumin
only eats from one.
So, Iman, actually, will decrease your appetite.
Now, obviously, I don't want people to get
worried about, so, hunger, is, ah, is a
big, big one.
Now, obviously, ah, in that early community, that,
you know, another interesting thing, to point out
something really important, people eat much more now,
common people, than they've ever eaten at any
other time in history.
Alright, there is a massive surplus of food.
Traditionally, they were not able to produce food,
and a lot of this is agro-business.
Ah, there's, people are eating meat now, that
never used to eat meat.
You ask any, people who are from immigrant
countries, even people from this country, right, ah,
because, people, African American people, who are from
the south, ah, know about what they call,
soul food, which is all the leftovers, of
hogs, ah, because people were very poor, and
they couldn't afford, ah, to buy, ah, meat,
even pig meat, right, and the same is
true in most Muslim countries, you ask your
grandparents, if they're still alive, how often did
you eat meat, and if they weren't from
a wealthy family, they probably ate meat, maybe,
once a week, if they were city dwellers,
if they lived outside of the cities, in
villages and things like that, even less than
that, and I've asked many, like Yemenis and
things, some of them, they would eat meat
only on their Eids, right, so, meat consumption
has increased massively, ah, and everything else, and
even, people, people in this country, ah, who
are older, will remember, that, yeah, there's people
in this country that can remember, that, you
just didn't have snacks all the time, children,
didn't have access to all that stuff, you
ate, you know, at times that you were
supposed to eat, and other times, off limits,
and there weren't convenience stores everywhere, where you
can go and buy a Coke, and buy,
so this is all part of the modern
culture, which is making people more like animals,
cause what, if you notice about the animal,
it grazes, and Allah mentions, that, these people
are like an arm, they just graze, in
fact, they put them in these, some of
these, ah, co-op type stores, you know,
no grazing, they have a little sign there,
where, where they have open things, with bulk
food, no grazing, you know, and, and so,
people have become grazers, they, the sociology is
called food context, and they say, like, average
American has 20 food contacts a day, in
other words, during the day, they're going to
put, have food, 20 different times, throughout the
day, and there's even people who recommend that
now, having these smaller meals throughout the day,
as a healthier way, if you go into
all the traditional cultures, they have meals, specific
times, and they don't, they don't eat between
meals, one, there, there's no refrigeration, things like
that, and, so, they're much more disciplined about
those things, you know, you take a Bedouin
from Mauritania, they can go days without food,
very little food, because they're disciplined in that
area, people here, it's interesting, in the American
army, they have now hot food, all you
have to do is pour water on it,
and they've got these things with chemical reactions,
and it becomes hot, and not only that,
they have, for Indian, like Sikhs and things,
they have Indian curries in the army now,
right, and for the different ethnic groups, they
actually, you can request different sea rations and
things like that, and this is all complete,
it destroys their army, there's no fortitude there,
there's nothing, they're just going to be complete,
and the other thing about the American army
now, is they need, for every one man
in field, they need 17 men to back
them up, right, 17, to maintain, and they
plan by the year 2003 or something, to
have every American soldier to have a personal
PC, a personal PC, and it's just, you
know, I mean, it's unbelievable, but that's a
whole other thing, anyway, the point is, is
about food, is that if you, if you
have Muslims, fasting is disciplined, the Muslims can
deal with, with times when there won't be
food, just from the fasting, they're used to
not eating during those periods, now, one of
the things about Ramadan that's been ruined, is
that Muslims eat more in Ramadan than they
eat in other times, and there are Muslims
that will spend the whole night eating, because
I've seen it, it's, I'm not joking, there
are Muslims that will literally, the night becomes,
not for Ibadah, for, it just becomes eating,
and huge feasts and things like that, and
all these things, traditionally, they, you know, I
mean, it's in, if you invite people over,
you want to feed them and things like
that, we've gotten into these walima, extravagant things,
and, and so a person can't even invite
somebody over unless they make this massive thing,
and all these things is one of the,
you know, things that the Prophets of Allah
have warned us again, doing all these things,
and he used to feed his guests sometimes
with dates and water, right, I mean, you
don't have to do that, but, you know,
it's, you shouldn't expect things when you go
to people's houses, don't expect this extravagant thing,
be content with what they bring, and don't
see it as an insult or anything like
that, because there's people that don't want to
be extravagant, and if they're misers, have a
good opinion of them anyway, that maybe they
want to follow the Sunnah, it's always good
to have a good opinion of people, so,
in any case, you don't lose.
So, hunger, I mean, there's a lot about
that, but in terms of, for us, what,
what I would recommend personally is, if you
do have a problem with food, then begin
to discipline yourself, begin to lower the portions,
preferably eat together, because if you eat alone,
you'll eat more, there's less barakah, the more
people at the plate, the more barakah descends,
the less food you need, and people who
know that, know that, if you eat from,
and one of the things about Sheikh Khapri,
when he went back to Mauritania, somebody asked
him, like, what was one of the strangest
things he saw, or tell him about the
strangest thing, he said, one of the things
that shocked him the most, was they all
eat from separate plates.
He, he, that just completely shocked, and, and
when he was telling these people about it,
they were all saying, Keith, you know, like,
like they couldn't understand it, like, how would
they do that?
When he said, everybody takes their own portion
and goes to, and they were like, they
just couldn't imagine, it just seemed so bizarre
to them, to do that.
And he said, Maraz, Fabahtu Nafsi, he said,
so many times, I made a fool out
of myself, because they put a big plate
there, and I start eating from it, and
then they'd all come up with their small
plates.
You know, so really, eat together, you know,
it's good for the family to eat together,
and things like that.
There's Baraka in it.
You eat with the people, there's more Baraka.
And then also, just to, you know, to
control yourself, to eat, preferably two meals.
I mean, if you really, if you can't
do that, then just, don't eat real heavy
meals.
Just, eat enough.
And also, the better the food is, the
less you'll need of it.
So, the food that these people eat, part
of the reason why they eat so much,
and I guarantee you, if you go to
a restaurant in this country, they give, they
put down in front of one person, what
ten people would eat in West Africa.
I guarantee you.
Ten people.
And most of them clean their plates.
So, you know, the portions of food, if
it's good food, you'll need less.
If it's bad food, you're gonna eat more
and it won't, you know, and by good
food and bad food, I mean food that's
nutritious, you know, good grain food, vegetables, things
like that.
If you're eating all these empty type foods,
fast food type thing, I wouldn't even eat
in a fast food restaurant.
I wouldn't even go near one of those
places.
Even if it's a McFish burger or whatever
it is, I wouldn't.
I may say it's more nutritious to eat
the stuff that it came in.
Like the, the cardboard box.
Throw the thing, the hamburger out, you see.
They're more roughish.
Allahumma wafiqna.
You know, if you want to bring the
heart to life, give the night some time.
And, they say even if it's two rakaats,
you know, that Sheikh, Sheikh Muhammad Ali bin
Malik, he said, don't leave Qiyam even if
it's just two rakaats.
And one of the things Sheikh Abdul Khadim,
Hafidhullah says, is that in this age where
it is difficult for a lot of people
to do these things, don't, you know, it's
worse to try, like one night you get
up and you pray ten rakaats and you
read longer surahs and these things, maybe you
spend an hour or half, but then the
next night you don't do it or the
night after that you don't do it or
whatever.
It's better to get up just five minutes
before the prayer and just pray two rakaats
consistently every night.
Just, just make it a habit.
Consistently do, give, give some prayer to the
night and to do it consistently and you'll
get a result.
But if you, if you do a little
bit here, a little bit there, a little
bit, it doesn't get you results.
See, Ahmed Zarro says, it's like drilling a
little bit here, a little bit there.
He said, you'll never get water.
Right?
So, some portion to prayer and a few
things just about the prayer.
The Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be
upon him, when he went to Medina, Abdullah
bin Salam, may Allah be pleased with him,
the rabbi who became a Muslim, he said
that the, that he gave a khutbah there
when he first came, descended upon Quba and
he said, O people, spread peace, spread peace,
greetings of peace and peace amongst yourselves.
Spread peace, and feed other people food.
وَصَلُّوا بِاللَّيْلِ وَالنَّاسُ النِّيَّامِ And pray in the
night when others are sleeping.
تَدْخُلَ الْجَنَّةَ بِالسَّلَامِ You'll enter Jannah without any
difficulty.
Now, just look at the, how easy that
is, just in terms of, of the statement.
أَفْشُوا السَّلَامِ Spread peace, don't be a dissembler.
Be somebody who unifies people, brings them together,
keeps those in.
Feed other people, be generous.
In other words, أَطَعِمُوا طَعَامُ All the things
that go with that.
Because if you feed them, you're concerned about
them.
You know, so be concerned about others.
Spread peace, be concerned about others.
وَصَلُّوا بِاللَّيْلِ وَالنَّاسُ النِّيَّامِ And then, take care
of your own soul.
You know, correct yourself.
If you do those things, تَدْخُلُوا الْجَنَّةَ بِالسَّلَامِ
That's what تَدْخُلُو is a جَوَاب شَرْطِ If
you do those things, that's the condition.
خَلَاص That's all.
Just that one hadith, if we took that
one hadith, every one of us, and just
made that a practice, that's a guarantee from
the Messenger of Allah you'll enter Paradise.
And one of the occasions, and they said
about a man who used to do some
things during the day but he prayed at
night, he says سَتَنْهَاهُ It'll stop him if
he keeps doing it.
On the other hand, there's another hadith, quite
frightening, about a woman who used to pray
at the night and give صَدَقَة but she
was mean to her neighbors.
كَانَ تُؤْذِي جِرَانَهَا She used to be foul
to her neighbors.
And he said هِيَ فِي النَّارِ And it's
a صحيح hadith.
She's in hell.
And then another one, they said they don't
pray at night, they don't give صَدَقَة they
don't do other things وَيَحْسِنُوا إِلَى جِرَانِ But
he's good to his neighbors.
سَيَدْخُلَ الْجَنَّةَ So, you can get up and
do all the night prayers you want.
If you don't have good character, forget it.
So, put things into perspective, you know, but
tahajjud is a big thing, right?
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has encouraged
that for all the believers.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says وَمَنِ اللَّيْلِ
فَتَهَجَّدْ بِهِ نَافِرَةً لَكَ عَسَىٰ أَن يَبَعَثَكَ رَبُّكَ
مَقَامًا مَحْمُودًا And from the night, spend some
portion of it in tahajjud as a نافلة
Right?
Extra act.
And perhaps your Lord will raise you to
a praiseworthy station.
So, doing those, it will help purify the
heart.
And Allah says about those people the مُؤْمِنُون
تَتَجَافَتْ جُنُوبُهُمْ عَنِ الْمَضَاجِعِ They're people who will
raise their sides up in the night when
they'd rather sleep.
So, sleep is something the nafs loves.
It loves sleep.
We all like sleep.
Sleep is something the nafs loves.
And that's why to prohibit the nafs.
Not all night.
You don't want to go into a psychotic
state.
You know, you don't deprive yourself of sleep
and things like that.
You put it in the banner.
And just in the same way when they
say hunger here, they're not talking about you
know, the Buddha with his spine showing because
his stomach, there's no, you know, there's a,
they call it the starving Buddha.
It's a famous statue.
A picture of the Buddha.
That's not, we're not those people.
Right?
That's not our tradition.
The point is, is that you you learn
to control your food nafs.
The same with the night prayers.
It's not that you spend the whole night
in in prayer.
There was a ta'ifa amongst the sahaba
that spent a good deal of the night
in prayer.
Not the whole night.
A good deal of the night in prayer.
That was a ta'ifa from amongst them.
A group, ta'ifa according to our Rabiul
Isbihani is less than a thousand.
So there was a number of the sahaba
that were spending a good deal of time.
But not all of them were doing that.
And the famous hadith about about the man
who the prophet said here's a man for
paradise and you know, one of the sahaba
followed him and asked if he could keep
company with him.
He didn't see him doing anything.
And so he asked him, what are you
doing?
He said, all I know is every night
before I go to sleep, I make sure
I don't have any rancor in my heart
towards any Muslim.
So he wasn't praying at night, he wasn't
fasting, he wasn't doing anything.
And so, you know, not all the sahaba
were praying all night.
But Allah says about a group of them,
كانوا قليلا من الليل ما يهجعون كانوا قليلا
من الليل ما يهجعون There was a small
group of them, they didn't use to sleep
at night in one recitation.
In another recitation, كانوا قليلا من الليل ما
يهجعون that they only slept a small portion
of the night.
It can be both interpreted both ways.
So the point is, is that for some
people that was their practice.
For us, I think what's what's rational and
reasonable is to just have some steady practice
of doing something.
What Walid Al Khadim says is it's good
to do the short suwar now that have
a lot of reward with them because of
the nature of the age.
And I mentioned last night about إذا العشرون
من شعبانا ولت فواصل شرب ليلك بالنهار You
know, when your life is coming towards an
end you know, start trying to get as
much actions as you can.
So, he actually recommend even just doing قره
الله واحد ten times even short rakaat and
getting a lot of reward for that.
So, even if you do short rakaat.
If you make it your practice to do
that some portion of the night and you
happen to oversleep until fajr then it is
still permissible and acceptable as tahajjud to pray
before you pray your fajr prayer.
Right?
So, in other words if your practice is
to pray ten rakaat and you wake up
one time late then just get up and
pray those ten rakaat before you do your
fajr prayer.
As long as you won't miss your fajr
prayer or the isfar comes in.
There is still some darkness.
And you can pray ten rakaat easily with
قره الله واحد وطمأنين in seven or eight
minutes.
I mean they won't be fast they will
be reasonable rakaats and you can do that
in maybe ten minutes.
There is enough time to do that.
A minute of rakaat.
For women who can't pray then if it
is perfectly acceptable like to get up in
the night and you know you can read
something that is beneficial or you know meditate
whatever you want to do.
Do some ad'ia some du'as.
Yeah you can do it in every rakaat.
I mean the ones that have a lot
of benefit اذا زلزلت الارض زلزالها قره الله
واحد موعودتين قرعوا ذو رب فرق قرعوا ذو
رب الناس لإيلاف قريش الحاكم التكاثر You know
those surahs the Prophet ﷺ used a lot.
وَتِّينُوا زَيْتُونَ Another one.
مَرَطَّرْحَجْهِ Recite all the time اِذَا زُلْزِلَتَ الْأَرْضُ
زِلْزَالَهَا He recited that one وَضُوحَا وَاللَّيْلِ اِذَا
سَجَى I mean he doesn't it's a bid
'ah to do the same one in every
rakaat in a farb.
You shouldn't make it a practice to do
and there's some khilaf about this like the
shaf'is I think they'd permit it the
malikis would be considered a bid'ah so
don't you know you have to be careful
if you say it's a bid'ah for
some imams it might be a bid'ah
for other imams it might be acceptable but
for him Imam Malik it's a bid'ah
to say do قُرْهُوَ اللَّهُ أَحَادُ for every
maghrib prayer whereas you know I've seen in
Shaykh Abdullah al-Haddad one of his treatises
he mentioned that it was a good thing
to do and there is a hadith that
one of the sahaba did that so you
have to be a little careful with those
things and there's another hadith also about Sayyidina
Abdullah ibn Omar r.a once walked by
and the prophet said نعم الرجل لو كان
يقوم الليل what an excellent man would and
that's how it's interpreted would that he spent
some time at night praying he didn't mean
what a good man he was it would
be if he prayed at night the sahaba
the ulema have negated that although that could
be understood in the statement he said لَيْلَ
you know word that لَيْتَ لَيْتُهُ كَانَ يَقُومَ
اللَّيْل but when he said نعم الرجل Abdullah
ibn Omar so which the ulema took from
that certain understanding one is that a person
would be good even if he doesn't pray
at night like Abdullah but how much better
would he be if he prayed at night
and so the mu'min who hears that desires
kamal and so Abdullah ibn Omar when he
heard that and he actually narrates the hadith
to his son when he heard that he
never left after that once qiyam al-layl
ever there are also the ulema that he
gives as a proof that it's permissible to
praise somebody who won't be affected by ujjab
like Abdullah ibn Omar the prophet knew that
it wouldn't had he heard that it would
actually encourage him to do more which it
did because had he been mu'ajib he
would have said oh I don't need to
do qiyam al-layl I'm already so good
and and then also the famous hadith of
Aisha which is a sahih hadith in which
the prophet used to pray so much sometimes
he got some cracking and edematous a little
bit of edematous swelling in his what they
call venous stasis the blood if you stand
so long your feet can get swelled up
a little bit which is why people that
have jobs sometimes like nurses often wear certain
stockings that actually keep the blood help the
blood go back up because you can't get
that thing and so it happens to people
but he did that and Aisha said ya
rasulallah why do you do this when your
lord has forgiven you everything you did in
the past and the future and he said
shouldn't I be a grateful servant in other
words ya know that should make me want
even more by that fact to show gratitude
so it is a way of showing gratitude
to Allah and the ulama say that hadith
indicates that one of the greatest ways of
showing gratitude to the ni'mah of Allah is
to do some at night work so sahar
al layali and then they say man qarbal
ya man qarbal ma'ali sahar al layali
whoever seeks high things spends his night awake
and also first learn that people who are
students the night is the best time the
night before the best time if fajr happens
at this time then what you need to
do is you would divide twelve you would
divide it into six parts from maghrib from
maghrib to right so it's going to be
every two hours right is that right no
i'm going to do that's
right right that's right so each one of
these would be two hours there this portion
is the best portion for qiyam al layal
qiyam al layal the last sixth of the
night so for now if it's six p
.m. six a.m. i'm just making it
easy because i'm not very good at fractions
um then one sixth right is going to
be two hours so if it's at six
from four to six p.m. is going
to be the best time to do that
night work although any time after isha is
considered qiyam al layal right and some say
after maghrib so even if you did if
you because some people are different if you're
a if you have like heavy liver it's
very hard to get up in the morning
all right and so uh you can do
that before you go to bed do some
some rakats before you go to bed but
you should do some rakats in the night
um the other thing for some people is
interestingly enough it's actually easier to get up
uh uh like now it'd be like about
four or three o'clock much easier to
get up than it would be right before
fajr that sleep right before fajr is recognizably
the heaviest sleep of the of the which
is a hikmah from Allah and it's actually
the point where the cortisol levels are the
highest the hormones in the brain actually are
the highest at that point uh so and
Ibn Atayla said that the hikmah of that
is that Allah wants you when it's most
difficult to be able to snap out of
that sleep um so it's actually easier to
get up before that time so anyway that
that's uh and then obviously eight or twelve
Marud Rahab said ten there's a hadith of
Aisha eight and ten is a sahih hadith
as well so I was told ten is
the best but two four six eight ten
and then better it's done after Aisha unless
you are somebody that by your nature you
get up every uh night and don't have
any problem with it then uh you can
wait but Sayyidina Abu Bakr who was very
strong and did night prayers most definitely used
to pray before he went to bed um
hmm what if do you have to get
up and pray if you are staying up
late what what do you mean like you
have to sleep for a while and then
get up no you don't I mean obviously
it's better you know to actually sleep and
then get up cause the prophet said that
was the best way the way Dawud did
it he would sleep some get up some
go back sleep some get up some that's
harder on the self than to do that
and he did that as his fast during
every other day so it's the same idea
and that's real Mujahidah that's complete control over
your nafs cause it's hard to go to
sleep and then get up once you're and
then Shaytan Audhu Billah uh never forget you
know always remember he's around as well so
Shaytan Yaqidu Aqd Aqd Tharatha he will bind
three knots on your head at night in
the unseen world and he'll say Amamik Laylum
Tawil you have a long night especially in
winter obviously right Amamik Laylum Tawil right you
have a long night just relax and then
you go to bed and those three knots
they're heavy the prophet said if you wake
up and you and you say like Subhanaka
Alhamdulillah Alladzi Ahyani Ba'da Mamatini Wa Ilayhi Nashor
one of the du'as of waking up
that the first knot gets un un unlocked
if you get up and do wudu the
second lock gets uh knot gets unlocked if
you untie if you if you do some
prayer then the third is and you're freed
from those knots if the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam said Man Nama Hatta Yusbiha uh
no he was asked about a man who
Nama Hatta Yusbiha which is a sign the
sahaba didn't used to do it he said
Daka Rajulun Dala Shaitanu Fi Udhni that's a
man who Shaitan urinated in his ears Alhamdulillah
now that's actually anybody who doesn't pray night
prayers means Shaitan is taking your ear as
a toilet bowl that's that's what it means
so we should not want that really I
mean not not to make light of it
because it's a hadith we shouldn't want that
so the way to get out of that
is at least do something you know get
up in in the night just something and
do some Rakat for Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala inshallah Allah give us Tawfiq to do
that and the other thing about that some
of the ulama said it means Haqiqatan that
Shaitan literally urinate in in in the ear
that is Haqiqa and and Haqiqa in there
is a Qaida that Haqiqa laa tusraf illa
al majaz illa daruratan that you don't take
the Haqiqa to the you don't take the
literal meaning to a metaphorical meaning unless there
is a necessity to do that so that's
why some of the ulama said there is
not a necessity it says that that is
Shaitan that is Shaitan to urinate or urinate
so some interpreted it metaphorically and said what
it means is that he he prevents them
from all the khair the good that comes
out of doing something at night that that's
what it meant wallahu ta'ala ameen can
you remind us of the du'a to
the kiram alhamdulillah
alladhi ahyani ba'da ana matani wa irahi nushoor
ba'da ma yeah ba'da ma amatani wa irahi
nushoor and then also I haven't been able
to do this but Murabbir Haaj always there's
there's a hadith that the prophet recited the
end of Ali Imran when he woke up
and you know I spent many many nights
in Murabbir Haaj's tent every single night when
he'd get up and he always got up
when I was there he usually got up
probably about 4 sometimes 5 hours before Fajr
and and always that was he'd wake you
up reciting those surahs that those ayahs and
he did it every single time Muthabara the
ayahs say inna fi kharqis samawati wal ardi
wa ikhtilaf al layal wal nahari la'ayatan
li ulil albad those الذين يذكرون الله قيامنا
وقعدوا معرجونهم ويتفكرون في خرق السماوات والارض رَبَّنَا
مَا خَطِقْتَهَا لَبَاطِنَا and I can hear him
saying that you know and he you know
inshallah Allah give us Tawfiq it's all Tawfiq
from Allah you know to be able to
do that it's a gift from Allah and
the thing I would say that the thing
that prevents us from Qiyam al-Layl and
these things is ghiba you know eating haram
things all that that's what stops it because
this is a gift from Allah and people
that have done it in their lives and
then lost it they know that the time
that they were given that it was a
gift from Allah and when it's taken away
it's like a punishment so you just make
Tawbah ask Allah to give us inshallah all
Tawfiq but it's a gift from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and the people of the
Qawm they used to have so much muhasaba
of themselves that whenever they were afflicted with
something they knew what caused it and one
of the ulama said I once said something
about somebody I shouldn't have said and I
was deprived to Hajjud for 40 days because
of it so they could see like relations
of why things happened and another one he
said in the end of his life he
went bankrupt and he said he realized it
was from 40 years before he had once
said to a man Ya Muflis and that's
what he said he realized that that was
the source of that Allah gave him what
he had called that other man pointed out
his fault so you know the good actions
of righteous people are the bad actions of
the the short means praise be to the
one who brought me back to life after
he had caused me to die and to
him is my gathering I go back to
him ya just don't do the witr twice
in other words if you do the witr
witr probably should be the last prayer that's
just that's the right but it's a to
do prayers after witr you know if you're
able to get up so if you go
to bed it's better to do your witr
before because witr should be done before fajr
and if you wake up and you forgot
to you can still pray it after fajr
but it's better done before fajr and it's
a sunnah muakkadah it's a strong sunnah it's
wajib in the hanafi madhab so the the
shafa' and witr should be done before you
go to bed and then if you get
up before the night you just don't pray
the witr you would do two two two
qiyam al-mayl matna matna the hadith says
that getting up at night is two two
matna matna you don't do four you do
two two what's that?
I didn't understand I'm saying you can do
tahajjud after witr it's preferable to delay the
witr to be the last prayer of the
night that is preferable that is perfectly acceptable,
put it this way, if you are absolutely
certain, as certain as you can be in
anything in this world, that you get up
before Fajr, then it would be preferable for
you to delay your prayer to Fajr.
If you're somebody who's, every night you wake
up a half hour or an hour before
Fajr and you get up and you're able
to pray your Rita, if that's your practice
and you're consistent in that and you're confident
in yourself that you can do that, it
is better to delay the Rita.
If, on the other hand, you're somebody that,
you don't do that, as a consequence, it
is better to pray your Rita before you
go to sleep, Azam, right, it's better, Abbad.
And then, if you get up during the
night, before Fajr, you do your Tahajjud without
finishing it with Rita, because you've already prayed
Rita and there's only one Rita in the
night.
Do you understand?
Huh?
Oh, okay.
Ingrizi nahi malum hai.
Huh?
That's all the Urdu I know.
They say somebody went to, huh?
They said, this Afghani joke.
They say, Afghani, are you Afghani?
No.
They say this American went to Afghanistan and
he wanted to find out.
the greatest spiritual teacher in Afghanistan, because he
heard that Afghanistan had all these spiritual saints.
So he went to that Afghani man and
he said in English, like Americans do, assuming
that they know English.
He said, who's the greatest spiritual teacher in
Afghanistan?
And the Afghani man, he said, Nami Fahman.
So he said, Nami Fahman.
So he starts going around looking for Nami
Fahman.
And so he sees this, there's a funeral
going by and he sees the funeral and
there's all these people looking.
He goes up to one of the Afghanis
watching the funeral and he said, who just
died?
He said, Nami Fahman.
Nami Fahman means I don't know in Persian,
right?
And then another thing just about taking this
easy and not getting, Shaykh Habib said in
his, in al-Qasida, he said, He
said that, go the
path of ease with yourself.
In other words, don't wipe out yourself because
you need yourself.
You don't want to, your horse has to
get you to where you're going, so you
treat your horse well.
Don't overdo it, right?
He's not saying don't be lazy, but don't
wear your horse out till it can't take
you anymore.
In order for you to move along with
yearning, you see, because if you're not too
hard on yourself, then your self will do
these things, like if you try to stay
up the whole night, that's too hard on
the self.
If you try to stay up half the
night, it's too hard on the self.
And so the self won't, it'll just lose
its energy.
Whereas if you start just doing a little
bit, then there's a shock because you start
tasting it and you get the benefit of
it and then you desire it.
So actually you're looking forward to it, the
self begins to look forward to it, right?
And that's what he's saying.
And then he says, because two rakats done
from a lover is better than a thousand
done without love.
So if you do two rakats with shock,
you want to desire, you really desire some
of Allah's pleasure and if you do those
two rakats, then Allah will love it.
But if you're there doing, I have to
do these and it's important and I have
to, and you're doing that, that's, there's no
love there.
You're doing it with this idea in your
head.
So that's, the point is, is that it's
out of a yearning for Allah that this
should all come, as a mahabba from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, alright?
And then he says, was samtu, silence, one
of the, obviously, led to al-kalam.
Kalam is lazeed for most people, to speak.
And that's why the Prophet said, man ootia
samta faqat ootia al-hikmah, whoever was given
silence, just as part of his nature, he's
been given wisdom, there's a wisdom in being
silent.
Just in being silent.
Even if he's an ignorant person, if he
was given silence, he has a wisdom.
Which is, if you're an ignorant person, don't
make a fool out of yourself.
If you have something to say, then in
that case, speech is better than silence.
If you have nothing to say, then it's
mubah, right?
But there's no, there's no benefit in it,
it's just mubah.
Now, if that mubah kalam is how are
you, where have you been, this and that,
that's fine.
But if it's, did you hear about so
and so, then it moves to either makruh
or haram.
And so, learning how to control the tongue
is, that's a big discipline.
Imam Shafi'i said that when he was
in a gathering and needed to say something,
he always looked into himself to make sure
that he wasn't saying it out of a
desire, from his nafs, to prove something or
to show his knowledge.
He checked first that, is it acceptable to
him that somebody else would say the same
thing?
And he said if he was aware of
that, then he would say it.
If he wasn't, he would remain silent, as
a tarbiyah for his nafs.
And he also said, that I never had
a debate with anyone, except that I prayed
to Allah, he made a dua, that Allah
would make the truth manifest on his opponent's
tongue, so that he could submit to it.
He didn't want to win the debate, he
would actually prefer to lose the debate, so
it would make him humble.
And that's a rajab, that's a man.
So, that's the point, is that, and the
Prophet was the most quiet of people, when
he spoke, he spoke the truth.
So, he was not somebody who was, what's
called farfad, and he said, sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam, inna ab'adukum minni wa ab'adukum
ilayya yawm al-qiyamah, al-farfarin, al
-mutafayhiqeen, al-farfarin, there's three things, al
-farfarin, wal-mutafayhiqeen is the last one, and
they knew the farfarin, and they knew the
second one, they didn't know the mutafayhiqeen, he
said it was mutakaddar.
Farfad is somebody that speaks a lot, farfara,
yutharfiru, they speak a lot.
So, he didn't like people that just spoke
all the time, right, chatterbox, what they call
a chatterbox.
If you're teaching, if you're saying something useful,
it's another thing, but if it's just kalaam,
for kalaam's sake, then it's a waste of
time.
And Imam Marik, R.A., said about one
man, one of his students, he said, ni'ma
ar-rajal, illa annahu yatakadnamu kalaam ash-shahran
fee yawmin wahid, he's a good man, except
he speaks a month's worth of talking in
one day.
And then, al-fiqra wa huwa khali, fiqra
means to, wa huwa khali means literally to
be in a place where there's nobody around,
and you're reflecting, and that's called meditation in
English.
To meditate is a practice, right, not like
a yogic or something like that, but literally
sitting and meditating.
And basically, there's different ways to do that,
and you get into different traditions within the
tradition of Islam, some will do al-tafakkar
fil-mawt, like doing ahwal al-qiyamah, which
is a practice, so you can literally, you
sit and you go through the qiyamah, the
visualization of going through the raising in the
grave and these type of things.
Other is to do tafakkar in the divine
names, so you go through the divine names,
right, ya allahu ya rahmanu ya rahimu, right,
you go through the divine names and reflect
on the attributes, things like that, right.
So, fiqra, wa huwa khali, is useful for
the heart.
And then, sohbat al-akhiyari ahl al-sutqi
man yuhtada bihalihim wa n-nitqi, this is
keeping the company of good people, and it
comes from a Quranic injunction in which Allah
says, ya ayyuha alladhina amanu, faqulla wa kunu
ma'a s-sadiqin, have taqwa and be
with the truthful one, in other words, sohba,
and this is what they call in Persia,
sohbat, you know, keeping good company with the
righteous people in order to purify your heart.
And Imam Ibn Aqayla, R.A. says in
the Hikam, la tashaab man la yunhiduka halahu
wa la yadulluka arallahi maqalahu, don't take as
a companion somebody whose state does not elevate
you, and his speech does not direct you
to Allah.
And Sidi Ahmed Zarrukh says in his commentary,
he's not talking about shuyukh, he's talking about
your friends that you spend time with.
In other words, you should find people that
are going to elevate your state, not to
bring it down.
And by elevating your state, their state is
elevated, so you become elevated.
What it means is, is that their hal
with Allah is that they're in a good
state, they're in a state of gratitude.
So if you're with people in a state
of gratitude, it's hard to complain around them.
Right?
You can't, because they're saying, alhamdulillah, subhanAllah, I
feel really grateful, you know, subhanAllah, Allahu Akbar,
Allah's given us so much, and so you're
sitting there going, yeah, I'm sorry, I can't
agree with you, you know, life's tough, and
blah, blah, blah.
He's in a different hal from you.
So, if you're the one in shukr, don't
be with the one in shakwa.
And if you're the one in shakwa, desire
to be with the one in shukr, in
order for you to become like him.
So don't bring him down, let him bring
you up.
That's what it's saying.
And then, also, that their speech directly to
Allah, there are people that if you did
complain to them, they would say, subhanAllah, Allah
says, وَإِن تَعْدُوا نَعْمُهُ لَا تَحْصُوهَا If you
try to enumerate his blessings, you can't enumerate
them, that's for everybody.
So, maybe you should just try enumerating his
blessings instead of looking at the troubles.
So, you change, they help you change your
focus and remind you.
And it's amazing how a person's state can
be changed by just sitting with somebody who
gives them good and sincere advice.
Really, they can completely turn that heart around,
and a person who is completely black and
negative, because the effect of it was useful
and valuable, they change their perspective and that's
guidance.
So, you want that, and then Sidi Abul
Hasan said, مَن دَلَّكَ عَلَى الدُّنْيَا فَقَدْ غَشَّكَ
Whoever tells you to go to the world,
he's cheated you.
Right, so if they tell you, oh, you
know what you should do with your life?
You really want to do good financial planning
and get, you know, this house and blah
blah and all these, and that's their whole
focus.
They're indicating to you that he's cheated you,
because you could die at any moment.
And this is why the example that I
like to use is the example of, you
know, if there's two salesmen, there's a salesman,
right, and he comes and he says, I've
got two houses for sale.
One of them, if you buy it, the
only problem with it is it could disappear
at any time.
And I can't tell you how long it's
going to be around, maybe 50 years.
Maximum, it'll only be about 70 years, and
then it definitely will disappear.
But anytime during that time it could disappear.
But I have another house that's going to
last forever, and it's guaranteed.
But it's more expensive.
So which one are you going to buy?
Right?
Seriously, which one are you going to buy?
Any man with intellect or woman with intellect,
they're going to buy the more expensive one.
And that's Akhira, and you buy it with
your soul.
It's for sale, you buy it with your
soul.
And the other one, you buy with your
soul as well.
But you buy it by destroying your soul,
not by saving it.
So, keeping good company with people.
And then he said, And the one who
tells you, oh quick, do lots of deeds
and all these things, he's just exhausted you.
In other words, if you think that you're
going to get to Jannah by your deeds,
you're going to exhaust yourself.
وَمَمْدَلَّكَ عَلَى اللَّهِ فَقَدْ نَصَحَكَ But the one
who indicates to how to get to Allah,
which means the contentment of Allah.
Right?
That one, he has given you sincere counsel.
Because if you're content with Allah, a little
action will be enough for you.
But if you're not content with Allah, even
if you do tons of action, it's not
enough.
And then he says, finally taking refuge.
And then he says, To finally
take refuge in the one unto whom all
affairs return.
Because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, To
Allah all the affairs return.
So, seeking refuge in Allah.
Of all these diseases, it's the best disease.
And this is why Sufi Ibn Aisha says,
He says, the only real cure for all
these diseases is To just go to Allah
with complete, please, you know, I have to
change.
You have to help me change.
And there has to be a real sense
of urgency with Allah.
And if that's the situation, then inshallah Allah
will help us change.
And for me personally, I know that, I
really believe that My coming to Islam was
a result of a state that I got
into before I was Muslim In which I
was in that state.
The complete matter.
And I called on Allah, in the name
that I knew, which is God, you know.
But I asked God, just give me guidance,
show it to me.
And I was in a complete state of
iftarar.
And I can remember that.
And most of the people that I met
who became Muslim, They will confirm that.
That they had similar states.
That it was really getting to a state
of just absolute Just show me what to
do.
And then that guidance just opened up, became
very clear.
Khalas.
And then it's easy after that, inshallah.
I think that Allah is merciful.
And if there's sincerity with somebody, inshallah.
That even if in their own limited understanding
of how they perceive.
I mean there's an apocryphal story.
And it's apocryphal, so I'm not going to,
there's no aqeeba based on it or anything.
But it's a wisdom that's been told about
About the Musa alayhi salam meeting the man
Who's telling Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala How
he just wants to wash his feet And
give him a massage And do all these
things.
And he's an anthropomorphist and he doesn't know.
And Musa, you know, scolds him And explains
the real tawhid And this and that And
then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala You know,
reminds Musa that he was harsh on the
man And the man was saying those things
out of love for Allah That he was
ignorant And so the thing to do is
teach the ignorant person Right?
So, you know, the idea is that people
Everybody is at the level that they're at
So even the one who's going to the
idol That's his understanding and that's where he's
at And that's why Allah says وَلَا تَجَعَلُوا
لِلَّهِ أَنْدَادًا Right?
Don't make for Allah andad وَأَنْتُمْ تَعْلَمُونَ And
you know that it's wrong So once knowledge
comes to you That's when Allah does not
That's when shirk destroys you If you don't
have any knowledge Then Allah, if he hasn't
sent his messenger to you He's not going
to punish you مَا كُنَّمُ مُعَذِّبِينَ حَتَّنَا بَعْثَ
رَسُولَهَ So if you don't know about Islam
And you're asking for guidance Then inshallah that
guidance comes وَاللَّهُ تَعْلَ عَنَهُمْ And then he
says بِأَنْ يَكُونَ كَغَرِيقًا أَوْ كَمَنْ ضَلَّ بِتِيهِنْ
لَا يَرَى الْغِيَاثَةِ مِنْ سِوَى الْمُهَيْمَنَ الْعَظِيمِ الْقَدْرِ
وَهُوَ الْمُجِيبُ دَعْوَةٍ مُقَرِّي So here he's saying
You know that You have to be like
Somebody who's drowning Or someone lost in a
barren desert And sees no source of support
except for the God And this is what
happened to Yusuf Islam I heard him say
this in a lecture he gave Of how
he became guided And he said he was
drowning In Malibu That he was being pulled
out by the undertow Which is really dangerous
And he actually said that he completely Called
on God He said just give me guidance
And I'll follow it And I'll do whatever
you tell me And that's the ghariq You
know that's somebody like they're a ghariq There's
nothing else you can do And that's why
Ikrimah ibn Abi Jahl His guidance came On
a boat Right In which there were Habashi
Christians On the boat And it started The
waves started taking it And they thought they
were going to drown And he started calling
on Hubal And these Christians were laughing at
him And they said You're calling on an
idol made out of wood In Mecca to
help you here And he said He realized
How stupid it was That he could only
call on Allah In that place And then
Tawheed came into his heart So that's the
idea Of being like the one drowning Right
And he says that in fact Is the
most beneficial In other words that really is
The one that will help us This must
be to the point of which You're like
a man drowning or someone anyway So that's
That's that Now About Let's
see Then
he says Actions that purify The heart وَمَابِهِ
لَلْقَلْبِ صَفْوً مِنْ عَمَلٍ أَنْفَعَهُ هُوَ الْمُدَامُ وَلَوْ
يَقِلْ So as for the Action that is
beneficial In purifying the heart None is more
beneficial than that which is consistent Even if
it is slight And this is from the
hadith خَيْرُ الْعَمَالِ أَدْوَنْ بَهَا وَإِمْقَلْ The best
actions are the continuous ones Even if they're
a little bit So he's saying The most
beneficial Because what you're doing You see like
if I take If I take a coin
And I polish it really hard For a
few polishes And then I put it down
You take the same coin And just very
slowly With not much pressure Polish it And
just keep polishing it And keep polishing it
And keep polishing it It'll become bright and
shiny Whereas doing it once vigorously Won't do
the work that doing a little bit But
continuously will do And the heart How it
gets encrusted with wrong actions Is the same
situation If you do a whole bunch at
one time It's like doing that vigorous rubbing
But if you do just a little bit
Consistently The heart over time That crust begins
to break off And that's why a little
bit Done consistently is much better Than a
lot done And the proof that the sahaba
They were always consistent in their actions In
other words Even the man who asked the
prophet to fast The fast of Dawood He
regretted it in his old age But the
ulama took that as a proof That they
used to even consider the nasirat Something they
wouldn't leave Not because it was foul But
because it was something They had taken upon
themselves to do And if you read the
hadith About the prophet used to fast so
much We thought he never broke his fast
And sometimes he didn't fast But we thought
that he never fasted And then sometimes he
used to stay So much in the night
we thought he never slept And other times
He would be that we didn't think he
did Much qiyam Remember something very important About
the messenger of Allah The messenger of Allah
Is He is the universal prophet In other
words His being is Accompanying the possibilities of
every good believer So he Every good believer
Has in him a model And there are
people who do not have Qiyam as one
of the openings Allah gives them There are
people that won't have recitation of Quran As
an opening Allah gives them Their opening will
be in hadith There will be other people
whose openings will be in sadaqah And they
won't be in fasting There are other people
whose openings will be in fasting And it
won't be in sadaqah There will be some
people whose openings are in hikmah And it
won't be in other things So people Very
few people ever have all of them And
this is why when the prophet Talked about
the different gates of jannah And one of
them was for the Faster, there is a
gate for the mujahideen He said Ya rasulallah
A yadkhulu ahadun hadhihi Al abwad kullaha Does
anyone get to go in all of them?
And he said Wa arju an takun minhum
There are people who do that And I
hope that you are one of them And
now as they say I hope he was
That is And things like that In other
words keep working And that's to all of
us as well So the point is there
will be people that have these broad based
tawfiq But Imam Manak was somebody He wore
very nice clothes He used the best scent
He used to burn the oud He was
somebody that outwardly When the zuhad looked at
him They thought he was very extravagant And
one of the zuhad wrote him a letter
and said I can't believe your state You
eat the best flour You wear all these
fancy clothes The perfume you have costs so
much money This and that You would be
better giving all that stuff up And spending
less time with people Because he used to
teach a lot So he was talking in
the masjid a lot So the zuhad was
telling Imam Manak You know look Compared to
me you are in bad shape And this
is marjab And Imam Manak wrote back to
him an incredible letter And he said Ya
Abdullah Servant of Allah Allah has opened up
for his servants many doors of khair Allah
has opened up for his servants many doors
of khair And
then he says And then he says Include
action done in the absence of witnesses Include
action done in the absence of witnesses Or
action done for his love or in awe
of him So he is saying also That
it is beneficial To do actions done Where
there is no other people That is good
for the heart Right It is good for
the heart For instance But to give Charity
Nobody knows If you open it It is
a good thing If you give charity openly
It is a good thing But to give
charity secretly is better To do prayers that
people don't see is better It is better
to protect yourself from Riyadh And Ujjab And
these type of things Once Bishr Al-Hafi
was walking He was very well known Actually
It wasn't Bishr Al-Hafi Fubayl Ibn Ayyab
Fubayl Ibn Ayyab was once walking down a
street And somebody said There goes a man
That spends the whole night in prayer And
immediately Fubayl heard it He burst into tears
And he said I can't remember ever spending
one night In prayer The whole night And
he said How great Allah has honoured me
By veiling me And making people think I
am better than I am So That idea
Of hiding And concealing the state Is better
And then action done for love That is
the highest action They say there are two
actions He said Mahabba or Jalal Man khafa
maqama rabbihi It's a Jalal of Allah It's
not doing it out of fear Of the
punishment of Allah Although that's one reason for
doing actions It's the lowest one And it
still shouldn't be belittled Because Allah tells us
to have khafa But if you have Khafa
maqamuhu It's Jalal There's Hayba And you have
a sense of Hayba of Allah And how
great Allah is On the other hand The
mahabba is from Allah's rahma And the mahabba
of Allah And yearning for Allah That you
do things That's the best one And he
tells you that the last maqam Is mahabba
Also the purest of actions Is done by
someone free of worldly wants The zahid He's
doing it not for anything We don't want
thanks Or gratitude We're doing this for the
sake of Allah So that person That's the
highest action There's no zuhid There's no tamah
Even in akhira or dunya is worse But
akhira You just do it for the sake
of Allah That's the highest and best action
for the heart And zuhid Is Is Feeling
It's a lack of want That's what it
is The zahid is not like the ascetic
In Christianity they have the ascetic Who like
wears Harsh clothes Flagellation All this type does
all the fasting and everything In Islam the
ascetic is the one Who the thing is
not in the heart That's why abdurrahman bin
alf was a zahid Even though he was
wealthy And then he says And the actions
of those who strive out of hope Are
higher and more exalted Than one who is
compelled by fear So if you're doing things
You It's not Right Right Right You have
in the messenger of Allah The best example
The one who hopes for Allah I didn't
say Because the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
He said But the prophet is the Habibullah
He is the lover of Allah And Allah
loves him So that's He loved Allah And
Allah loved him So that's the highest And
then he says Particularly action whose benefits extend
to others Action that benefits The heart If
it extends to others it's very good In
other words to give out In charity is
a high action Why?
Because the benefit not only benefits you And
your soul But it benefits another human being
In every moist liver In other words in
every living thing There's a reward To actually
feed animals To a place where birds eat
If you plant a tree Every animal that
eats As long as that tree stands You
get a reward for it Right So all
of those things And
then he says Fasting for the shara If
you're a glutton Fasting is really good for
you If you're somebody actually Who has good
control over his food nafs Right Then fasting
is a good thing But it's not gonna
be the same for the one Who really
needs to control his nafs And discipline that
aspect of himself Alright So it's a good
thing for somebody Or a miser If you're
somebody who's generous You're helping people For a
miser to give out Is better for the
heart And there's more reward in it They
asked him The
best sadaqa is when you're sound You're in
good health You don't wanna give it out
And you have fear of poverty That's the
best one It's like really Rubbing shaitan's nose
You know You're in it I didn't wanna
say that And then he says Are you
spent in avoiding wrongs So obviously There's people
in the ummah They spent their whole life
being horrible people And then they get old
And they make tawbah And they start wagging
fingers at all the young people Right I
mean obviously that person does not have the
same maqam As a young person Who spent
their youth when they had all that energy
To be disobedient Like the old guy He
doesn't have the energy to do wrong things
anymore So tawbah is a lot easier On
an older person Except for the fact That
If you disobey Allah throughout your youth Often
times the heart is so encrusted That you
have a bad seal But for Alhamdulillah A
lot of Muslims do make tawbah as they
get older They hit 40, 45 And they
start getting Like in Tunisia They say You
know The year of responsibility is 40 Because
that's when the wahy came In other words
Do whatever you want before 40 I mean
it's just ignorance But the point is there
are a lot of Muslims That kind of
have that attitude When I go to hajj
Then I'm going to grow my beard And
I'll be a good Muslim There's Muslims who
say that And they go to hajj And
some do, they get better They come back
And these are kind of attitudes That have
accrued in the Muslim world But unfortunately they're
ignorant But they really are They've become like
almost cultural artifacts That indicate how far we've
come From our tradition But anyway So a
youth that raised up in Allah loves the
youth Allah loves that man Shabab is from
Generally from like I mean the Arabs would
generally say It's from 15 to 35 That's
shabab 15 to 35 Some say 15 to
40 So But that's it After 40 you're
no longer a shab, you're a rajul A
man, you're a man Rajul And then he
says And also The
Contributions of a miser For the best of
his wealth When he is in a sound
state seeking it by the pleasure of Allah
All of these Things purify the heart All
of these things purify the heart Moreover, anything
done with discretion and concealment Is also purifying
And the best of endeavors Is the one
that purifies the heart So the best thing
that you can do in your life Are
things that are good for the heart Purify
the heart And that's why we're doing this
class And that's why he's telling us all
these things Likewise And also The worst
things Are those things That harden the heart
And you were constant in or enjoyed doing
it The mess liked it So those things
are the worst things For the heart Things
that harden the heart One of the things
that hardens the heart Is speaking a lot
without mentioning Allah And that's in the Mu
'atta of Imam Marik Sayyidina Isa is reported
to have said Don't speak, sit in majlis
Without mentioning Allah Because a majlis in which
Allah is not mentioned Will harden your heart
and you're not even aware of it So
the hardening of the heart Occurs without being
aware of it Physically and spiritually And the
more the tongue is occupied In remembering Allah
The softer the heart gets Really The more
dhikr somebody does The softer the heart gets
And the more compassion And the more benefit
they get from it Now this comes This
is a really important point Allah said That
a wrong action That leads to a feeling
of shame And Bereftment, impoverishment Before Allah Is
better than obedience That leads to Feeling proud
And arrogant Now And this is the secret
of wrong actions In other words The wisdom
of wrong actions Is that Allah wanted us
To do wrong To bring about this state
See this is the secret Of wrong actions,
right there The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said
If you didn't do If you didn't do
wrong actions I would have feared for you
What's worse than wrong actions Being pleased with
yourself Being impressed with yourself Vanity, thinking how
wonderful you are That's worse And then when
he came to the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
I went through that The point is that
when he said to him If you didn't
do wrong actions You'd be shaking hands with
the angels On the streets Right That's why
little babies You watch the little babies I
mean some people say They know But
if you look at babies
You can see Newborns like they don't look
At your face They're looking around you You
know, it's amazing You watch them, they look
on both sides Of your shoulder They'll be
looking like this And they have this amazing
look Of just like And then the other
thing That they look at is light And
they get this awe It's like they look
at light Like reminding them From where they
came from Because they come out of that
presence You know, their arwah We're in that
presence And these are all reminders It's an
amazing thing So the angels If you don't
have wrong actions The Prophet said you'd be
seeing angels Now Sidi
Ahmed Zarouk Says about that That the good
of Ta'a Is in the essence of
Ta'a And the evil of Ta'a
That he's talking about Ta'a is what
it results in So when he says that
Don't think that he's in any way saying
That obedience is There's bad obedience And there's
good ma'asiyah That's not what he's saying
So don't confuse that What it means is
that Ta'a is good Ma'asiyah is
bad But if the secondary result of it
Was pride When you did a good thing
But the result of Disobedience was Tawbah Then
in reality Exactly You see what I mean?
So he's not saying that ma'asiyah is
better than Ta'a What he's saying is
The results of the actions You might think
it's good and it turns out And that's
why Maybe you hate this ma'asiyah that
you did But in fact it was a
good thing for you Because it brought you
to Allah Right?
It brought you to Allah Just like those
people here in America They killed somebody or
they robbed a store And they go to
prison And they got guidance in their prison
That happens to a lot of people So
that disobedience that they did Actually ended up
being part Of the causative process Of the
means by which They were given guidance And
so even though it was a disobedience It
was actually It led them to guidance So
it wasn't a good thing But it resulted
in a good thing And that's what he's
saying That a good action that results In
an arrogance Is worse In other words what
it results in Is worse than A wrong
action that results in humility And then he
says وَذَرَّةٌ مِنْ عَمِلَ الْقَلْبِ الْعَلِي مِثْرُ الرِّضَى
وَالزُهْدِ وَالتَوَكْرِ أَغْضَرُوا عَنْدَ اللَّهِ مِنْ جِبَالِ شَمَخْنَ
مِنْ ظَوَاهِرَ الْعَمَالِ This is really important And
Adam's weight of high praiseworthy action From the
heart is better than high mountains Of external
actions with no heart And that's that idea
فَإِنَّ رَكَعَتَيْنِ مِنْ مُحِبٍ خَيْرَ مِنْ أَلْثٍ مِنْ
غَيْرِ حُبِّ That to do two raka'ats
with love Is better than a thousand without
Much much better And then he mentions something
That Imam Suhnoon رضي الله عنه said وَتَرْكُوا
دِرْهَمٍ لِكَوْنِهِ حَظَرَ أَظْدَرُ مِنْ تَصَدُقَاتٍ وَعُمَرَ Imam
Suhnoon said Leaving one daniq From what Allah
made haram Is better than doing 70,000
hajj and umrah Daniq is like a penny
Farthing It's like a really least amount Of
money in Arabic tradition They say They say
Imam Yafar al-Sadiq said أَرْبَعَةٌ عِزُّهَا وَظُلُّ
There's four things That even the best of
it There's a There's a A basement in
it He said الدَّيْن وَلَوْ دَانِق A debt
even if it's a daniq Like a least
amount أَبِنْتْ وَلَوْ مَرِيَمْ A daughter even if
it's mariam Right?
They don't have the protection that a son
has If a man has a son You
know he's strong In the society Whereas a
daughter She's gonna be in a situation Where
it would be more difficult To protect herself
and things like that It's not saying That
a son is better than a daughter It's
just saying that in those situations That her
is still She doesn't have the is that
a man has By merely being a man
Just out of strength Physical strength and things
like that And then Because عَزِيز don't forget
in Arabic Also means قَوِي Physically strong Or
politically strong Like عَزِيزُ النَّصَر And then he
says وَسُؤَادْ وَلَوْ كَيفَ الطَّرِيق وَالْوَحْشَةَ وَلَوْ لَيْلَ
Asking a question even if it's How do
I go on this road There's a type
of Even though there's nothing wrong with it
There's a humility that comes with it And
then وَحْشَةَ وَلَوْ لَيْلَ Like being alone even
for a night So anyway Now we go
to the root causes of the disease Let's
see Let me get through these and then
What I'll do Next week I'm gonna do
treatment of the diseases With remembrance of Allah
And Inshallah Shaykh Khatri will be here So
I'm gonna ask him if he'll come And
do this class next week Inshallah So if
you're gonna have questions and things like that
And I read He loves this book and
he knows it He knows this book really
well He spent a lot of time with
this book And I read sections of it
with him I read I read I read
A lot of it with Shaykh Khatri But
I read it with Shaykh Abdullah And I
read the other And we did khatm of
it on the hajj We did on Arafat
We made khatm of the book And then
we made a dua of all the diseases
Name them all That Allah Inshallah would purify
us of them Inshallah And all of us
So he says He says The comprehensive ideology
Of all of these diseases is love of
the temporal world This is the opinion of
both Imam Al Hilali and Imam Ibn Ashar
So their opinion was Love of this world
is the root disease And there's Difference of
opinion Like we saw Ibn Abad said the
root is Tama' Is desire But again you
can see how it's hubb You know You
get in these really semantic Differences, they're all
pretty much agreeing Even Ibn Ashar When he
says it's hubb al-riyasa It's still hubb
al-dunya Because why do you want riyasa
You want power, you want dunya You want
all these things So in the end really
it's hubb al-dunya And there's a hadith
even though it's weak Ra'su kulli khatiyatin Hubb
al-ajira Love of this world is the
reason For every wrong action Ibn Atayla On
the other hand Considered it to be A
man's self satisfaction And that's really interesting So
Ibn Atayla actually Had a different take on
it, it's still similar But it's a different
take And he Was a scholar He died
in 709 It was 1309, the Christian era
And he's actually considered one of the greatest
Masters of this science He wrote the hikm
And he was a Marrakee jurist And he
was, Imam al-Bannani Said had it been
permissible to recite Other than the Quran in
prayer It would have been permissible with the
hikm Which is a hyperbole, it's an exaggeration
He's just saying how great the hikm was
And Ibn Atayla says In the 35th hikm
He says that the Source He says The
source He
says that the source Of every disobedience, indifference
And passion is self satisfaction Whereas the source
of Every obedience, vigilance and virtue Is dissatisfaction
with oneself And then he says It is
better for you to keep company With an
ignorant man Dissatisfied with himself Than to keep
company with a learned man Satisfied with himself
And then he says But what knowledge is
there in a self satisfied scholar And what
ignorance is there In an unlearned man dissatisfied
With himself And then he says here And
he says So he's saying And the reason
for every good character Or quality is lack
Of self satisfaction In other words, even if
this culture If you look at it, the
whole idea of getting rid of shame And
get rid And you have all these things
right But look at the fact That the
reason the guy's in the self help section
Trying to Buying the book of how to
get rid of shame Why is he there?
He's dissatisfied With himself In other words, if
he was happy If he didn't have any
shame If he felt great So the guy
that wrote the book Doesn't want you to
be self satisfied He wants to sell you
the book So he's glad that you're not
there You know They're all just liars And
hoasters, most of them So the point is
that dissatisfaction With the self is what causes
you To want to change If you're satisfied
with yourself If anybody here was satisfied With
themselves, they wouldn't be here Right, inshallah Why
would you be here studying The disease of
the heart if you thought That you were
free of them But the fact that people
have These troubles is what actually Makes them
want to go out And get better And
that's how you go out and seek help
If you feel that you don't have guidance
You seek guidance The one who submits to
Allah He starts seeking guidance Why?
Because now he knows that he needs Allah's
guidance But if you're out there Walking around
Feeling perfectly content I don't need guidance, I'm
guided Then you're not going to Seek that
guidance And that's what he's saying there So
he's saying it's clear How this was arrived
at is obvious Right Now Sidi Ahmed Zarouk
says And this is important There's three signs
To being content with the soul It's seeing
that The Haqq has a right Now it's
interesting in this culture We have a bill
of rights Right But there's no bill of
responsibilities Right And this is a really interesting
phenomenon Because there's much more focus In Islam
on your responsibilities Than on your rights In
fact the Quran is really a bill of
Allah's rights It's the Haqq of Allah on
us It's the Haqq of Allah on us
And that's why Is an alien idea To
the Islamic ethos I mean Human beings do
have God given rights But they're not human
rights Right They're Allah's rights In his servants
So Allah has a Haqq That you don't
oppress His creation That's a Haqq of Allah
So if you kill somebody You kill them
And if you killed him Because he wanted
it By Sharia Then it's a Haqq of
Allah that you took his life Because Allah
demands His Haqq to be fulfilled Now Allah
gives a human being A Haqq In other
words If you're without a gun you have
a Haqq But that Haqq was given to
you by who?
By Allah So it's a Haqq of Allah
And the reason the other person is fulfilling
it Is because he fears Allah And this
is why Fear of Allah is the foundation
Of a Muslim society That's the foundation of
it You have to have fear of Allah,
Taqwa of Allah So the first one Is
seeing the Haqq for the self If you
see all the time They're wrong, I'm right
It's a very common psychological disease You think
they did it to me It's all their
fault The Mutman always think And there's a
story I might have told you before But
it's important, it's a Moroccan story About a
Sheikh Who There was a self satisfied Islam
Who didn't like this Sheikh And he was
visiting once and he said You know, the
least of my students Is better than You
And the Sheikh said How is that possible?
And he said, I'll show you, come to
my madrasa tomorrow And I'll show you So
the Sheikh comes back the next day And
he tells all of his Students, when the
Sheikh comes in Don't say to him When
he says So the Sheikh comes in So
the Sheikh comes in And he also told
him And when so and so comes in
Who was a student of his Don't say
salamu alaykum to him So the Sheikh comes
in I
seek refuge with Allah These are your students
They're ignorant Didn't they hear what he said?
Or what Allah said?
Right?
Haven't you heard Allah say If you're given
a greeting Or better than that So that's
what he did And then he told him
usually And then his student came in and
he said Salamu alaykum Nobody said Salamu alaykum
Salamu alaykum O brothers Forgive me I made
a mistake in your rights I did something
Forgive me Why don't you agree with me?
Did I do something wrong?
Excuse me, whatever I did And that's a
completely Those are the two, one self satisfied
And the other he's looking What did I
do wrong?
And that's the It's a haq For the
self The man who came in, he saw
I have a haq And my haq is
you return my salam The other one was
saying What haq didn't I fulfill That these
people aren't saying salam to me You see,
so he's looking from the opposite And one
self satisfied And that's why Even though he
was the least of his students He's the
jahil That's why Ibn Ataylah is saying What
knowledge does a man Who's self satisfied have
even if he's an alim And what ignorance
Does an ignorant man have if he's not
self Because he's going to ask and want
to learn And be taught, right So it's
a hikmah, I don't know if it ever
happened Inshallah it did, but you know There's
meaning in it So that's the first one
The second one is The second
one is He
says The second one is ignoring
the fault Of the self By deeming the
self to be already In a state of
purity Even if it's by interpretation So for
instance Somebody gets angry Or somebody's And he
says Well the hadith says And that's just
his nature But he's using You know, pretending
something Or like that, you know So or
he gets angry And he says Angry even
gets the worst of my ummah In other
words I mean the best of my ummah
So I'm from the best of the ummah
And I still get angry So it's that
idea of seeing the faults But interpreting them
In ways that you don't deem them as
false And this is what he said The
poet meant when he said The eye of
contentment An eye that's content Is always doesn't
see the fault Right Like the one who's
in love They can't see the fault One
of the signs they say of falling out
of love They start noticing all the faults
of the person I never noticed One ear
is bigger than the other Right So
The eye that's angry Begins to show The
wrong actions of that person And then So
those are And then Having compassion for the
self Poor me You know I'm really having
a hard time And complaining And that type
of thing So those are the three signs
that somebody's content with themselves The three The
three signs That somebody's not content with themselves
Is the first one Is He's always He's
always Checking the self Accusing, being suspicious about
the self's intentions And this is Sayyidina Yusuf
A.S. who's a prophet Masoom There's a
khilaf about the statement Sayyid Ahmad Zarroq and
others Sayyidina Yusuf A.S. said I will
never Declare myself Innocent The nafs By its
nature Commands to evil So always being suspicious
Of the self, what were my intentions there
Wondering what it is Am I doing this
for riyah Hazrat Abu Basr he said The
only one Feels safe from nifaq is the
hypocrite So the mu'min Is always checking the
self Being careful Of the blemishes of the
soul And this is This is the You
know in the dua the prophet said Don't
leave me to my soul Even for the
blink of an eye or less than that
Don't leave me to the soul And then
the final one is Forcing the self To
do difficult things Things it doesn't like And
he mentioned them You know Eating less Spending
some time It's a makraha It's difficult to
do those things Jihad is a makraha Jihad
is a hard thing to do All these
type things Forcing the self to do Giving
out money It's a makraha Self doesn't like
it You want to save your money We
want to save our money And get whatever
we need Or put it away Whatever Now
Abu Uthman said Whoever sees anything good about
himself Has not seen the faults of his
soul In other words If you think there
is anything good about you Now obviously The
question is going to arise here See part
of the whole western discourse Is this idea
Isn't this all self loathing And low self
esteem And all these This is very antithetical
To the modern thing Of feeling good about
the self Of feeling Right It is Now
a couple of things This is not going
to make people If you have been around
The real shiur They are not these people
They really do They have that humility They
have all these qualities Because like Aisha We
read this morning Aisha She is the wife
of the best of creation She was a
beautiful woman Physically She was an intelligent woman
One of the most brilliant women Certainly in
Islamic history And in human history She was
from an excellent family Aristocrat From the tiny
clan of Quraysh All these things And yet
When she is desiring Allah To absolve her
of To actually declare her innocence She said
وَكُنتُ أَرَى نَفْسِي حَقِيرًۭا I deemed myself As
so insignificant That I would never think Quran
Would be revealed about me So this Despite
all of those things She was not a
woman with low self esteem She was a
woman She was a very Excellent woman With
self confidence She is one of the few
people She asked the Prophet When he said
يَدْخُلُ الْجَنَّةِ بِلَا حِسَابٍ وَلَمْ يَخُلُ اللَّهُ فَسَوْفْ
يُحَاسِبُ حِسَابٍ يَسِيرًۭا But they will get an
easy حساب How is it now you are
saying So she is actually questioning the Prophet
With her knowledge on Quran Nobody else would
do that Only a woman with great self
confidence Or a man Sahaba wouldn't do things
like that So Aisha had great She took
an army out She regretted it She took
an army out She said Let's go He
is wrong, we are right Let's go and
solve this situation She went out in her
hodaj And went out to the battle of
the Jaman And when the mayor of Wadham
said يَا أُمِّن مُؤْمِنِينَ She said لا أُمِّنك
Does the Arab say that To like Really
it's kind of an insult لا أُمِّنك You
don't have a mother Don't call me your
mother You don't have a mother So she
was a strong lady But Still Her understanding
Of her You know Herself was that she
was insignificant And that Is what this is
talking about It's not talking about being in
this state of self loathing And being Without
any confidence Or things like that You should
be confident But you should not be content
with yourself That's all they are saying Don't
be content with yourself Don't see Always want
to change There is always room for improvement
And that's the point No matter how If
you are a master calligrapher There is always
somebody better than you There is always somebody
If you are the perfect There is always
more mastery of the Quran to be done
So you always deem I haven't done enough
That's all And that is because we are
human beings And I never saw A fault
From amongst the people Like the The inability
For people capable of achieving human perfection Why
they don't do it And the reason they
don't do it Is because they are satisfied
You get to a level of You know
I recite the Quran reasonably well I don't
really feel a need To go and sit
with a Tajweed teacher anymore You are self
satisfied And that's the level you will get
to Because now you are pleased But if
you say no Right You want to go
and increase it more Alhamdulillah I studied enough
I am not going to make any mistakes
You are not going to learn anymore And
the thing is all of these things They
are endless All of these sciences are endless
All of these knowledges are endless All of
these abilities are endless And the master Is
not the one who actually Achieves the mastery
It's the one who is committed constant to
constant improvement Right That's the person who has
mastery Because they are always improving They are
always improving their technique There is always room
I can do better But if he feels
content I am self satisfied There is no
more improvement And then you are dead So
that's what he means Alright And then he
says Because when a man is self satisfied
This acts as an impetus To seek virtuous
character And to vigilantly avoid What is unbecoming
of him So you are always vigilant about
it Alhamdulillah So we will stop there And
then next week We will finish this section
And then what I am going to do
We have how many more classes?
Three Three?
Or two Is there three?
Yup, you are right I am wrong So
InshaAllah we will do this next week And
then I will do the Khawater The week
after that Or what I will do actually
is I am going to go through the
The Adhkar of the Sabah and the Masah
The week after that Which everybody should be
doing And I will get you a copy
Of that And then And then we will
do the Khawater And then that's the Khawater
Jazakumullah Khair
Arabic
The
The There was a question here about I
think from the previous class Just about Women
Having male slaves Women A bondsman Which is
an Adh Is permissible for One to own
But they are not They are still They
are still So they can't They can't be
alone with them Same type rules And there
certainly can be no Sexual relationship between the
two That was the question In
This last section Before the Did I do
the Mifatih The keys Last week Let me
do that because Mifatih is a key In
Arabic And if you look at the word
This root word Is what?
Mifatih Mifatih And the The wazn that it's
on Is Mifad And this is a wazn
That's used for Tools Right Like Meknas would
be Meknasah Something that you use Medras would
be We need to change that So the
Mifatih is the tool that you use To
open something up And obviously it's a key
In Arabic The point is that a key
Which unlocks a door In Arabic the word
for key Means That thing that opens That
causes an opening Right Which is different from
unlocking If you think about that Right In
other words The metaphor is much stronger In
Arabic than it is in English You can
say he had the key which unlocked The
secret But the idea of Right Related directly
to one of the names Of Allah which
is Mifatih The one who opens So in
other words people that have Spiritual keys And
Allah says he has The keys to the
unseen A person who has These keys There
are things that they can Open up And
there are many hadiths which indicate This is
a key to this Right Sabr is the
key To getting the faraj Or the opening
So that's a hadith In other words if
you want faraj from Allah Then the key
is sabr In other words If you don't
have the Mifatih you can't Open it So
like right now The ummah is There is
no faraj but if you look at the
ummah There is no sabr If there was
sabr then you could have the faraj And
part of sabr Patience is that you don't
Complain So you have to stop complaining And
literally be patient Because man batha lam yasbir
If you are complaining You haven't been patient
Unless the complaint is what they call Arbhal
You are not complaining You are just letting
somebody know what the conditions are That's different
If it's like where is me, why is
this happening to me This is horrible Now
Imam al-Mannawi says That this is one
of the most important babs of knowledge It's
called Bab al-Mifatih So I am going
to give you The Mifatih that he laid
out Miftah al-Salah The key to prayer
Is tahor The key to prayer is wudu
So Sidi Ahmed Zarruq says If you have
presence in your wudu You'll have presence in
your prayer If you are heedless about your
wudu You'll be heedless about your prayer And
one of the things about Modern Muslims is
that they don't do wudu As an ibadah
anymore They do it hurriedly In a bathroom
And they just want to get it over
with so they can go pray And the
point is Wudu is a spiritual preparation For
prayer So it's a Miftah for prayer Miftah
al-Hajj Al-Ihram The key to Hajj
Is entering into the state of Ihram So
if you do the Ihram Properly Then you've
opened the door to the Hajj Miftah al
-Bir Al-Sadaqah The key to righteousness Is
charity Lantanalu al-birra Hatta tunfiqu minma tuhibboon
You won't get righteousness Until you give out
In charity So Miftah al-Bir Al-Sadaqah
Miftah al-Jannah Al-Tawheed The key to
paradise is Tawheed Now obviously Every key has
Asman Right In the old keys Right
So the key itself Like the key to
Hajj Is Ihram But then there's teeth to
it So there's obviously other things But that
is the key that opens it up So
Miftah al-Jannah al-Tawheed Miftah al-Ilm
Husam al-Sual Wal-Isra The key to
knowledge Is asking intelligent questions And learning how
to listen attentively Miftah That's Miftah al-Ilm
Miftah Al-Zafar Al-Sabar The key to
victory is patience Or the key to gaining
what you want Is patience With
patience you will gain whatever you desire And
with Taqwa you can bend iron Miftah al
-Mazeed Al-Shukr The key to increase in
this world Ta'adhana Rabbuka La'in shakartum
La'zidannakum Allah has declared If you show
gratitude to Allah Allah increases in you So
Miftah al-Mazeed In khair of good is
shukr Gratitude If you want increase in good
of this world and the next Then the
key is shukr Miftah al-Wilaya The key
to Wilaya Becoming a Wali of Allah Al
-Mahabba With dhikr Is love and remembrance of
Allah That's how you will enter Into a
state of Wilaya Love of Allah's messenger And
Allah And dhikr of Allah And dhikr of
his messenger as well Miftah al-Falah Al
-Taqwa The key to success Is Taqwa Ulaika
Right?
The people of Taqwa are the people of
Falah Ulaika hum al-Muflihoon So Taqwa Falah,
success in this world And the next is
Taqwa Miftah al-Tawfiq Al-Raghba wa Rahba
The Key to Tawfiq From Allah which is
where Your will is in accordance with Allah's
will is Rahba and Raghba Is understanding, desire
What you should naturally desire And incline to
and what you should naturally Have an aversion
to, so the Tawfiq When it inclines to
what Allah has commanded it To do and
Like prayer, Allah Encourages us to pray, so
that's a And if you pray on time,
you're In that thing, in prayer Allah Calls
us to fear Certain things, so if you
fear them, you're Muwaffaq, in Fearing the right
things, so Raghba and Raghba, desiring the Right
things and fearing the right things Leads to
Tawfiq from Allah, you're considered Muwaffaq And then
Miftah Al-Ijada al-Dua The key To
getting a response From Allah is calling on
Allah That's the Miftah If you call on
Allah, Allah Says, He'll answer you Miftah
Al-Dukhood al-Allah, the key To entering
into the presence of Allah, in a Non,
you know, no Anthropomorphism there Is Istislam al
-Qalb Wal-Ikhlas lahu Fal-Huddi wal-Buhud
It is the key To being aware of
The divine presence Is the heart entering into
Submission to Allah And then love And then
sincerity In what you love and you hate
In other words, you love things for the
sake of Allah And you hate things for
the sake of Allah That's the key to
being Present with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
And then Miftah Hayat al-Qurub This is
a really important one The key to life
of the Hearts, bringing the heart to life
Tadabbar al-Qur'an Reflecting on the meanings
of the Qur'an, Tadabbar al-Qur'an
Wattadarra Andar ashar Calling on Allah sincerely before
dawn Watarq al-dhunoo And stopping wrong actions
And if you do any one of those
three You'll see a difference And if you
do all three Khalas The second one Tadarra
ila Allahi Andar ashar Like Tadarra andar ashar
means Yatadarra ila Allah To really call on
Allah Out of desire Of need, intense need
of Allah Tadarra So
Miftah Hayat al-Qurub Tadabbar al-Qur'an
Reflecting on the meanings of the Qur'an
Tadarra andar ashar Tadarra means to Really to
To fervently seek help Or Like one of
the reasons Allah says in the Qur'an
that He gives people Tribulation is La'allahum
yatadarra'oon In order for them to yatadarra
'oon Really to plead with Allah To really
change me, help me Save me And so
doing that at dawn Before dawn, pre-dawn
time Is Shaykh here?
Ok And then Tarkadh an-Nur Is leaving
Wrong actions Wrong actions And then he said
Miftah Hasura al-Rahma Al-Ihsan fi Ibadat
al-Haq Wa al-Sa'i fi Nafa'
al-Khalq The key to gaining Mercy from
Allah Is doing Ibadah properly And helping Creation
That's where you get the Rahmah Because Allah
said That His Mercy encompasses everything But He'll
write it for people who have Taqwa And
Taqwa is Ihsan and Ibadah When you have
Taqwa you have Ihsan and your Ibadah And
then also Al-Rahimoon Yarhamahum al-Rahman Yarhamu
man fil-ard Yarhamukum man fil-sama Al
-Rahimoon Those who show Mercy The Rahman shows
Mercy to them And then show Mercy on
those in the Earth And Allah will show
Mercy on you So that's the key to
Rahmah Is to have Ihsan in your Ibadah
And then to benefit The Creation of Allah
To show Mercy and have Rahmah The key
to having Rahmah is Ihsan In Ibadah of
Haq And striving to benefit the Creation And
then The key to Rizq Is striving with
Istighfar The key to provision Is to go
out And get it, but do it with
Istighfar So that's the key to provision To
go out and search for it, look for
it But do it with Istighfar Because the
nature of going into the world Is you're
going to get Zanub And so if you
make Istighfar It will counterbalance The Zanub That
you acquire in the world Miftahul Izz Attaa
'ah The key to dignity In this life
is obedience to Allah That's the key And
Sayyidina Umar said Nahnu qawmin a'izzanallahu bil
-Islam Faydaa qarabin al-izzah bi ghayrihi Azallanallah
We're a people that Allah Gave us Izz
with Islam And if we seek dignity from
anywhere Alaykum salam wa rahmatullah Thank you I'll
just, there's only three more So I'll finish
them and then I'm going to let Sheikh
Khatri Do the rest of the Section here
And then he said Miftahul istighfar al-akhirah
Qasrul amal The key to getting ready For
Akhirah Is having Short hopes In other words,
don't think you're going to live long If
you want to prepare for Akhirah Don't think
I've got lots of time Believe that you're
going to die any minute And that's the
key to preparing for it And then Miftahul
kulli khairan Al-raghbatu fil-akhirah The key
to every good Is desire of the next
world Just like the key to every evil
Is desire of this world Ra'asul khataih
hub al-ajila Right And then Miftahul kulli
sharran Hub al-dunya So that's it, those
are the mifateeh And I'll tell you there's
a lot of knowledge in those Mifateeh, there's
a lot of knowledge there So inshallah we'll
let The key to every evil Is Love
of dunya Now where did we get to
last week?
What's that?
The sources, yeah Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic He said the source Before, the session
we did before He talks about the roots
And he said that the root of The
diseases of the heart Is a human being
being self-satisfied And he said so if
you have a human being That's satisfied with
himself Then he has a diseased heart He's
maryab Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic So he said that a
human being He's not going to be able
to acquire any good As long as he's
content with his self Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic So the human being he knows
He said the origin really Of the good
is knowing yourself Because if you know yourself
you can't be content with it And if
you're not content with it It's going to
encourage you To do things that are going
to improve your soul Which is good actions
And acquiring good character So by knowing your
soul You'll actually set out To do something
about it Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic Arabic
then what happens is you actually deem wrong
actions to be good things, because the nafs
by its nature will make wrong look good,
appear to the self, and that's often in
the Quran, right, tazyin of shaitan, of nafs,
of hawa, and he said, so the hawa,
the nature of your hawa, which is your
caprice, is that it inclines towards ma'asiyah,
and if you don't, if you're unaware of
your own soul's natural inclination, the soul's inclination,
not the ruh, but the soul is inclining
towards wrong action, if you don't know that,
then the soul will convince you, if you're
satisfied with it, that what it's inclined to
is good for it, right, like in this
culture, it's the best example of that.
So he said that the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the soul, when it's not
satisfied with itself, then, will seek what is
good, and what is good is what Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala told it to do,
and in the ibadat al-dujammah, which is
a poem on the aqidah, he said that
what is good is not what the aql
thinks is good, but what Allah says is
good, just like what is ugly is not
what the aql or the nafs or anything
says is good or ugly, it's what Allah
says is ugly.
So the shari'ah tells us what's hasan
and what's qadeer.
So the, the, what he's saying is that
the shari'ah is what tells us what
is good, and the shari'ah tells us
what is bad or ugly, and the intellect
has no access to that.
You know, it can sometimes get it right,
but not always, and so it's, it's not
an absolute source of guidance, right?
I mean, the intellect is a relative or
limited source of guidance.
So shari'ah indicates what's hasanah and what's
sayyah, and then the human being who recognizes
now that his nafs is not going to
save him or help him, then he looks
to what will help him by recognizing it's
what Allah told him to do, and so
that will lead him to doing the actions
that are in accordance with Allah and His
message.
So he said that, what, what, what he's
saying in the poem here is that the
origin of, of those two, right, the disease
of the heart and the good things of,
of, that are going to happen is the
company that one keeps, because the hadith says
that a man is on the deen of
his companion.
So the sheikh said that if you keep
company with a person who delays his prayer,
if you keep company with a person who
doesn't pray zakat, if you keep company with
a person that does wrong actions, then you
will be doing those things that he's doing,
and in the same way if you keep
company of a good person, then it's going
to affect you also, so that the person
is on the deen of those he keeps
company with, and that's why people have to
look at who they're keeping company with, because
the company is indicative of the state of
a man.
So he said, for example, if you sit
at the door of a bar, then you're
going to be smelling the foulness of the
alcohol in the bar, and if you sit
at the door of a perfumer, then you're
going to be smelling the good scents of
the perfume.
So whatever you're in proximity to, you'll be
affected by it.
That's the point.
So if you're in the proximity of a
good person, you're going to be affected by
his goodness.
If you're in the proximity of a bad
person, you're going to be affected by his
foulness.
So if you're in the proximity of a
bad person, you're going to be affected by
his goodness.
So if you're in the proximity of a
good person, you're going to be affected by
his foulness.
So if you're in the proximity of a
bad person, you're going to be affected by
his goodness.
So he said that, for this reason, Luqman
al-Hakim, R.A., mentioned in the Quran,
that he, in the Muwatta of Imam Malik,
he mentioned that Luqman al-Hakim said to
his son, sit with the ulama.
Keep the company of the ulama.
And the ulama are people who know things
and act according to their knowledge.
And he said, sit with those people because
they're like rain that comes to earth and
brings it back to life.
They are like that rain to the earth.
The sitting with them is like the rain
to the earth of your heart.
In other words, it will bring your heart
back to life.
And it will bring it in a way,
he said, that you're not even aware of.
In other words, just by sitting in the
company of righteous people, in the company of
knowledge, the heart begins to become alive.
And iman begins to grow in it until
it increases and gets more and more.
So he said, the sitting with the aalam,
of the aarifi, the people who have knowledge,
will take you from six things to six
things.
In other words, you'll go from six bad
things to six good things.
In other
words,
you'll go from doubt to certainty.
From doubt to certainty.
You'll go from doubt, doing things for others
than Allah, to doing things with sincerity, with
ikhlas, for Allah.
From heedlessness
to remembrance of Allah.
From heedlessness in this world to heedlessness
in the hereafter.
So you'll go from desiring this world to
desiring the next world.
Yes, the hereafter.
From arrogance to repentance.
So from a bad internal nature to a
good one.
So from a bad character that has bad
intentions to a character that is sincere to
people, it has good intentions for people.
And also in the hikm of Ibn Atayla,
he said, don't keep company of someone who
does not elevate you his state, his hal,
his condition, does not elevate you, raise you
up.
In other words, by seeing him, you get
elevated, your himmah gets higher, you desire Allah,
or whose speech does not direct you to
Allah.
Don't keep company with a person whose either
his state is not elevating you, or his
speech is not directing you to Allah.
It's a bad company.
So the, really of all these diseases that
we've looked at in the Mathara, the comprehensive
cure for all of them is remembrance of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
More than anything else, that is the thing
that will cure your heart.
So dhikr is recitation of Quran, prayer, of
salah, that's a dhikr, prayer.
Dhikr is saying subhanallah, all the types, subhanallah,
alhamdulillah, subhanallah al adheem, all those type things.
Dhikr is saying la ilaha illallah, dhikr is
saying alhamdulillah, allahu akbar, la hawla wa la
quwwata illa billah.
Those ad'ia that the Prophet has given
us, those are all dhikr of Allah.
And then, qiraat al Quran, which is the
highest and the best of them.
The best dhikr, the best dhikr is qiraat
al Quran, a
person
who is in a state of dhikr, his
heart is going to be tahir, it will
be pure.
So Sayyidi Ahmad ibn Hanbal, he saw Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala 99 times in his
dream.
And in one of them, he was asked,
of all of the things that draw a
slave near to Allah, which one is the
greatest?
And he said, and Allah answered him, recitation
of Quran.
And he said, ya Allah, with understanding or
without understanding?
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, according to
the Imam, answered him, bi fahmin or bi
ghayri fahmin, with understanding or without understanding?
In other words, even an Ahlulbayt, who doesn't
understand what they are reading, they are drawing
close to Allah with the Quran.
So in Sahih al Bukhari, the Messenger of
Allah s.a.w. said, the likeness of
the one who remembers Allah in the present
is like the living and the dead.
That's the analogy in the dunya.
Somebody who remembers Allah is khayt, qalbuhu khayt,
his heart is alive, so he is alive.
And the one who doesn't remember Allah, qalbuhu
mayyit, so he is mayyit, his heart is
dead, so he is considered dead.
And in a hadith, and it's a good
hadith, it says, make remembrance of Allah until
they say he is a mad man.
Because one of the things mad people do
is they talk to themselves all the time.
So if you see a person remembering Allah
all the time, they look outwardly very similar
to people walking around talking to themselves.
So somebody who doesn't know what he is
doing, like if some of these non-Muslims
see you walking down the street doing dhikr,
they will think maybe he is crazy, he
is talking to himself.
So that's what the hadith means.
And the hadith which is also sound, and
it's in different narrations.
Should I not tell you what the best
of all of your actions is?
And the most pure in the sight of
your Lord, your King?
And the most exalted in all of those
things that you do that are in degrees,
it has the highest degree?
And better for you in spending wealth of
gold and silver?
And better even that you go out and
meet your enemy in jihad?
And by going out and meeting them, you
strike them and they strike you, you kill
them and they kill you?
They said, of course, tell us Ya Rasool
Allah.
Dhikr Allah, ta'ala, remembrance of Allah.
And in explanation of that hadith, because people
say how could that be better than jihad
or something like that.
The ulema, Rabbul A'lam, say dhikr Allah
is a ghaya, it's the end, that's why
we were created, to remember Allah.
Whereas jihad and everything else is a waseela,
it's just a means.
And there is no means in the world
that is better than the end.
And so the reason we were created is
to remember Allah.
And that's why it is the highest thing
in the dunya, dhikr Allah.
Allah says, adkuruni adkurkum.
So whoever remembers his Lord, Allah remembers him.
And whoever Allah remembers, He's enriched him in
the dunya and the akhira, he's in need
of nothing.
And one of the things about dhikr, which
is not the same as other ibadah, like
hajj or suyam or things like that, or
prayer even.
Is that dhikr can be done with all
of your acts, and there is no specific
time that limits it.
All of the human acts, including going to
the toilet, having sexual relations, eating food, all
of these things have dhikrs related to them.
And they say that the one who is
in a state of remembrance with Allah, he
is never afflicted by calamity, ever.
Because whatever afflicts him, that he was in
a state of remembrance of Allah, only raises
him in rank.
If he dies and he's remembering Allah, he's
a martyr.
So this is the treatment for the foul
soul, the foul nature.
That's its treatment, is to remember Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala.
This
is
the treatment for the foul
soul.
He says...
So he said...
So he said when you want to do
dhikr, you begin with istighfar.
Because dhikr is to purify yourself, and obviously
the reason that you need purification is because
of wrong actions that have been acquired.
So you begin that process by asking Allah
to remove those wrong actions.
And then, if Allah removes the wrong actions,
then the dhikr after that that you do
will remove the bad effects of those wrong
actions.
Because the wrong actions have effects.
And so you pray on the Prophet, sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam, because prayer on the Prophet
acts as a murabbi for the heart itself
and purification of the heart.
Which is why also most of the later
ulema all encourage those two specifically, because of
the wrong actions that so many of us
are engaged in, but also because by ijma'
of the ummah, the only dhikr that's absolutely
guaranteed to be accepted by Allah is salah
on the Prophet.
Anybody who says Allahumma salli alayhi wa sallim
Muhammad is maqbool.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded a
command that He himself began with.
Which you don't see that anywhere else in
all the things Allah has commanded us to
do, he doesn't begin with it, except prayer
on the Messenger of Allah.
So he, Allah himself said, Innallaha wa mada
'ikatu, and then he seconded it with his
own hands.
They do this.
And then Allah said, Jalil al-ladheena shaddu
alayhim wa sallim wa taslima.
Pray on the messenger of Allah and do
taslim.
Allahumma salli ala Sayyidina Muhammad wa sallim.
So whoever prays on the Prophet of Allah
one time, Allah prays on him ten times
according to the sahih hadith.
And he said, whoever Allah has prayed on
ten times, what else do they need in
this world than the net?
So just pray on the Habib, sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam, marra wahida.
Allah ya akbar.
As-salatu alayhi, alayhi nuru hi qadri, wa
nuru hi qadri, wa nuru ala siraat.
So the Prophet of Allah said that prayer
upon the messenger of Allah is light in
this world.
Light in the grave and then light on
the siraat.
So in other words, it will give you
light, guidance, when you need it.
It will give it in the grave.
It will make your grave light instead of
dark.
And then it will make the siraat light
so you can see to get across it.
As-salatu alayhi, alayhi nuru hi qadri, wa
nuru hi qadri, wa nuru ala siraat.
Light in the heart.
Yeah.
That's what the Prophet said.
So he
said,
no one else we've been commanded to pray
on the Prophet of Allah.
And therefore when you pray on the Prophet,
and that's why usually it's good to begin
with the actual ayah, because by beginning with
the ayah, then you're actually, it's called intifad
amrillah.
You're in fulfilling the command of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala.
And you have to do it as a
rajab at least once in your life to
fulfill that command.
But you can do it every single time
that you do the prayer on the Prophet.
And so the one who prays on the
Prophet, he should have the same adab that
he would have if he's remembering Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala.
It's mandeen for him to be in wudu.
It's mandeen for him to be facing the
qiblah.
It's mandeen for him...
So those things that are mandeen for prayer,
are mandeen for prayer on the Messenger of
Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
And also istihbar, that's what he said.
And then that you have istihbar of the
Messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam, that
you pray as if you were in his
presence.
You should...
In the same way that when you pray
to Allah, you pray as if you're in
the presence of Allah.
That's ihsan.
With the prayer on the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam, you should pray as if you
were in the presence of the Messenger of
Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
These are courtesies of the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam.
And when he was in the presence of
the Messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam,
he was in the presence of the Messenger
of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
And when he was in the presence of
the Messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam,
he was in the presence of the Messenger
of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
And when he was in the presence of
the Messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam,
he was in the presence of the Messenger
of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
And when he was in the presence of
the Messenger of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam,
he was in the presence of the Messenger
of Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
These are the adab that you do when
you do the prayer in the presence of
Allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
Like you're going to pray, these are the
adab that you should do.
Tahara, siwak, cleaning the mouth, perfume, things like
that.
These are all good things to do.
So every dhikr has things that are appropriate
for that dhikr.
So for instance, when you say la ilaha
illallah, what's appropriate for it is that you
negate other than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And that you negate shirk completely.
That's appropriate for la ilaha illallah.
When you say alhamdulillah, then what's appropriate for
that is that you are reminded of the
constant overflowing bounty from Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala of His blessings.
Because He is mahmud, there is hamd for
ihsan and for the things that Allah has
done for you.
And then if you say la hawla wa
la quwwata illa billah, then what you should
be doing is, you should have a takhalas,
which is a removal or completely disengaging from
any power or any strength.
You're basically admitting that you have no power
and no strength before Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala.
When you say la hawla wa la quwwata
illa billah.
And therefore when you pray on the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wa sallam, what's appropriate for it
is that you are aware of the presence,
that you bring the presence of the message
of Allah as if He was before you.
And all the wonderful things that He did,
the guidance that He's given us, and all
of those things that we owe to Him
as our wasila for teaching us la ilaha
illa Allah, for teaching us about Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala.
And then to remember that it is Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala Himself that gave prayer
on this messenger of Allah and His angels.
And that you're participating in something that Allah
Himself says that He has done and His
angels.
So another
thing
about dhikr that you should avoid is what's
called lahm, which is an incorrect pronunciation.
You should avoid it to the best of
your ability.
Obviously some people do not have the ability
to pronounce everything in Arabic properly.
But you should avoid it and you should
try to learn how to say things properly.
He said some of these things, mispronunciation is
considered a ma'siya or a khappa.
But others are actually ridda, that it can
take you into getting out of Islam.
So the ajamiya, for instance, the people who
can't pronounce dhad and dha, things like that,
they don't make a tamweez, they say like
dhaloon instead of dhaloon.
Those people, if they really can't pronounce it,
there's a faql in their tongue, a heaviness,
that's ma'dhur.
He has an excuse by sharia.
If he's done all that he can to
not pronounce it like that and yet he's
still incapable, then he's ma'dhur and he still
would do the dhikr, even though it's pronounced
incorrectly.
And he gets the reward and there's no
wrong action that is entailed by doing that.
And then one of the greatest of also
of the worship is meditating on the creation
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala makes mention
in the Quran of those people who remember
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala standing, reclining, standing,
sitting and on their sides, reclining on their
sides.
And then he says those who reflect on
the creation of the heavens and the earth.
And so Allah is coupled with dhikr, thikr
or tafakkur.
And so it's said that the action of
the heart, which is tafakkur, that's why the
heart is there to be able to do
this tafakkur.
The action of the heart is better than
all of the actions of the limbs.
And this is why in one narration there
comes a tradition that says to reflect for
one moment's reflection is better than a year
of ibadah.
So he says that the signs of reflection
are four directions.
One of them is reflection in the signs
of Allah.
And another is reflection in the creation of
Allah and its signs and this leads to
love.
So that leads to love by reflecting in
the signs that Allah has made and in
his creation and the sign that the creation
indicates about Allah leads to love of Allah
because you see all that Allah has done
for the human being.
And then the next one is reflection in
the promise of Allah of the rewards that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has promised for
his creation and those signs that are related
to that.
And each sign leads to a desire of
akhira and of these things.
Because Allah promised you jannah, so the sign
that you've reflected on that promise is that
you have a raghda, you have a desire
for jannah.
And then there's also reflection in the punishment
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has promised
creation and the sign of that is that
there is raghda or fear engendered, so the
person avoids disobedience.
And then there's also reflection in the weak
nature of the self, the jafa of the
self, the harshness of the self towards Allah
despite Allah's ihsan to him.
So when you think of all that Allah
has given you and then you see how
you respond in the middle that you actually
do for the sake of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, then this is a type of
reflection that leads to shame before Allah.
In other words, the sign that somebody has
done this type of reflection is they have
a hara with Allah.
They feel a shame before Allah that Allah
has done so much with them and they
have not done anything for Allah.
Arabic Arabic
Arabic So
the heart is the thing that differentiates between
good and evil and the source of all
of these matters is related to the inrushings
that occur to the heart.
So the heart has these inrushings that occur
to the heart.
It's like a guest that descends upon the
heart and there are different types of them.
Arabic Inshallah because we are not going to
unfortunately have much time with Shaykh Khatri, so
we will just open it up for the
last section, about 15 minutes before we fill
it up for some questions.
People have questions?
Arabic Arabic Arabic
So the question that Qais asked was about
people like now, what they call mutasawifa.
Imam Al-Maqari differentiated between Sufiya and Mutasawifa.
Mutasawifa are people that they claim to be
Sufis.
And so one of the signs often of
those people is that they do a lot
of dhikr of Allah but they ignore wajibat.
And so he asked what's his opinion and
the Shaykh said that the first and foremost
obligation on every human being is to learn
knowledge.
Before anything.
And a human being is nothing until he's
learned the fardaeen.
He has no maqam, nothing with Allah.
He's nothing, it's like an animal, it's the
same.
Because Allah has commanded him with a very
minimal amount of taqleef to learn how to
do certain things.
And the fardaeen, if he hasn't learned them,
then he's living the life of just like
worse than animals because he's astray and he's
not doing anything to get out of his
error.
And those people who learn knowledge, and Shaykh
Wabd Al-Khadim mentioned many of the ulama.
Imam Sha'rani, Imam As-Suyuti, all of
the great imams of the science of the
outward and tasawwuf all say that before tasawwuf
there has to be fiqh.
And if you don't learn fiqh before tasawwuf
then you'll go astray.
There is no tasawwuf with the knowledge of
fardaeen.
Tasawwuf is after the knowledge of fiqh.
So even showing filial piety to one's parents,
learning the farda is before that, the fardaeen.
In other words, the highest thing after tawheed
of Allah that Allah mentions in the Qur
'an is birr al-warideen.
And yet, learning what Allah has commanded you
to do as a fardaeen is over birr
al-warideen.
If you have not done that and you're
taking care of your parents and that's preventing
you from learning, then you're doing something that's
wrong by leaving something's right.
What is the best thing a woman can
do for a man?
A woman can do anything for a man.
That's why every type of Qur'an has
a woman in it.
Every type of Qur'an has a woman
in it.
That's because she didn't do anything.
She didn't do anything.
She can read all of the zikrs that
men can do, but she can't read from
the Qur'an.
And then the khidaf in that, of how
much, like from memory, if she memorizes the
Qur'an, then she can read what she
needs to keep her Qur'an, or if
she's studying the Qur'an.
But she cannot touch the Qur'an during
her hajj, and she should not read it
extensively, unless it's to maintain what she's memorized.
Or like ta'awwud, or ayat surat al
-tabarak, for instance, she's reading, or if she
reads like that.
But other than that, she can read any
of the ayats, of the adhkar, la ilaha
illallah, qara' an-nabi.
We were talking about the previous question.
In America, I know a whole community, I
know a whole community, and I wonder what
you think of this, because I know that's
a part of the zikr, and I know
that's a part of the zikr, They're
not Muslim, but they hear about the spiritual
meanings of Islam, They're not Muslim, but they
hear about the spiritual meanings of Islam, and
about these things, and this brings them closer
to Islam.
And he said, how for them is the
best way?
And the best way for the people of
the world is to always submit to the
will of Allah, and to always submit to
the will of Allah, and to submit to
Allah with these Ahkam and that's what Allah
has made binding upon us.
And people who enter into Islam, the first
thing the Prophet taught people was Tawheed and
then he told them that Allah has made
five prayers incumbent upon you.
Once they accepted Islam they were told you
have five prayers.
So he called them first to the unity
of Allah and then he called them to
prayer.
And that's the methodology of the Messenger of
Allah and that's what we should be calling
people to, is to pray.
In this culture there's a whole false or
pseudo-spirituality which is the idea that you
can have Haqiqah without Sharia.
And it's a Dajjalic phenomenon.
It's misleading people and it's taking them away
from the truth.
So it's actually anti-spirituality because real spirituality
is protected by the Sharia.
In other words the fruit is protected by
the, the orange is protected by the shell
on the orange.
And if you take that shell off before
it's ripe you ruin the orange.
And so if you try to get spirituality
before you've protected yourself with the Sharia then
you'll destroy your soul.
And you become a false, you know and
this is why they have all these false
people who they're Mutamali to them.
In the photos of that he calls them
Mutamali to them.
They're like people who pretend that their ears
are dead but yet they're filled with all
the diseases of the heart and they only
outwardly pretend to do that.
So he said, you know that if you've
done things wrong you should veil them.
And if you veil them and make Tawba
Allah will forgive them.
If you do them manifest or openly then
it's much worse because it lead to the
tribulation going all over and that's bad.
He said, he said, he said, he said,
he said, he said, he said, he said,
he said, he said, So
he said that people should veil their fault
and he mentioned a hadith that a man
came to the masjid and it was Allah
s.w.t. he said, I did something
wrong, meaning zina, so punish me with the
proper punishment.
The prophet turned away from him, he left,
he got up, he walked out, the man
followed the messenger of Allah s.w.t.
he said, I'm outside the masjid and he
told him again and finally the messenger of
Allah looked at him and he said, didn't
Did you just do wudu and pray with
us?
In other words, you are staring at me.
That's what Islam is for, to purify your
wrong actions.
And the men had punishment.
And he said that the Prophet s.a
.w. said, whoever does any of these wrong
things, these foul things, let them veil themselves
with the veiling of Allah, and let them
make tawbah.
And he said, whoever comes to us, to
our faces, and admits them, then we will
punish him.
So the point is that, he is commanding
us to have sitr from Allah s.w
.t. There is a person who asked, regarding
the fact that you are in Jerusalem, it
is not difficult for you, but when your
condition deteriorates, Allah s.w.t. will punish
you.
He said that, would they be content to
sit with whoever is among them?
In my opinion, in the case of obedience,
Allah s.w.t. said, Allah s.w
.t. said, In this world, Allah s.w
.t. will not punish you with water, because
it is the children's fault, that the world
is destroyed.
Because it is the children's fault, that the
soul is destroyed.
The soul is destroyed, if it does not
exist.
In the case of obedience, Allah s.w
.t. said, In the case of obedience, Allah
s.w.t. said, In this world, Allah
s.w.t. said, and
you will feel, like they have something that
you don't have, you want a bigger house,
you want a better car, you want these
things, and that leads to love of dunya.
And the same with the, but then he
said that for akhira, you should always be
with people better than you.
Because if you are always with people lower
than you, then you will start thinking that
your deen is ok, and you are better
than them.
And, the thing about the people of Allah,
is that, they tend to, look at themselves
as being less than everybody else.
So they don't really have the danger, of,
you know, if somebody is keeping company with
them, they actually see them as better than
them, and not the opposite way around.
Which is why you should keep their company.
Because, it will make you feel like, if
that person has that type of humility, then,
you will feel much, see.
And so people who have takabbir, and see
themselves as better than somebody else, and this
is why they say, Don't belittle people, because
they might be a wali of Allah.
And you never know, if a person's maqam
is higher than yours.
Even if they look like they are worse
off than you now, he might be drinking
alcohol, but, maybe in a few years, he
makes a tawbah that Allah accepts, and then
he becomes a wali of Allah, and then
down the road, you do something wrong, and
the opposite happens to you.
So, you should never feel, that you are
better than anybody, in the dunya.
And that's why, when you see people of
akhira better than you, you should always want
to be with them.
those are rightly guided, if they really follow
what those imams came, because those four imams
وَالْمُؤْمَى عَلَيْهِمْ أَرْضَعَهَا وَقَفُوا غَيْرِهُمْ جَمِعُوا مَنَعَهَا it's
مُؤْمَى عَلَيْهِمْ, those four imams is مُؤْمَى عَلَيْهِمْ
it's absolutely by consensus that they're rightly guided
and so people calling to other than that
and then in aqeedah, you take very simple
aqeedah from a simple method like Ibn Ashar,
Imam Tahawi, any of those and don't go
into فروع, فرعيات, where is Allah, what's the
hand like, all these type things all that
is, somebody came to me and they asked
me, somebody came to me and said what
do you say about the ayah الرحمن على
الأرش استوى and I said the fact they're
asking that question is a sign they have
deviation in their heart by the shahada of
the Quran, because the Quran says anyone that
asks about those verses that means their hearts
are deviated so anytime you hear people talking
about the verses of Allah that relate to
متشابهات, hazy things, I don't want to read
that, I don't want to read that you
just leave them, and that's guidance the question
was about, like what do we do in
a time when shiukh have disappeared and there's
really not much of the people of tarbiyah
and so what sheikh hafri said, may Allah
bless him was that, that question is a
sign that the person is concerned about their
soul so it's a good question, and it's
a true condition and he said, you know,
if you're in this country, then it's good,
like the classes you're taking now these are
good classes, things like this, it's a good
thing to do he said that, that is
the best thing to study and make sure
the source of your knowledge is good and
he said, you know, that the things that
we're teaching, like these mutoon these are mutoon
that are thabit, that are part of our
tradition and they come from a chain of
shiukh and the people, like his sheikh and
my sheikh is murabtar haj and murabtar haj
is somebody, you know, whoever's seen him, seen
him, he knows who he is his knowledge
is pure, the source of knowledge is pure
he's never known by anybody to have done
a makruh nobody who has lived with murabtar
haj for over 70 years can say they
ever saw him do a makruh he's never
been, ever heard to speak a bad word
about anybody by name, anyone he's never mentioned
anybody with shiukh his knowledge is pure shariah
and he teaches people, remembrance of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala because he's in a state,
like one of the people said al jurusu
anduhu, kal jurusu andar habar al ghaib sitting
with him is like being with somebody who's
present and absent at the same time he's
present in that he'll teach you and answer
your questions he's absent in that his heart
is moved from this world it's not in
this world anymore so, people like that, who
are far to find there's a question here
Alhamdulillah, he's a murabtar we love him there's
a woman who asked you is it possible
for a woman to come to you and
learn from you?
and to study with you?
and is it possible for her to teach
you the language?
no you
live in a civilization which is the most
beautiful civilization in the world and it's the
most beautiful civilization in the world therefore, it's
close to your home and it's your home
but, it's important the most important thing is,
of course, to learn in order to do
that there's a new issue we'll talk about
it later and we're going to talk about
him now, in the hour of the interpretation
there's a conversation and there's a love yes
he's a friend we love him we love
him he's a friend we don't know he's
a friend just a friend just a friend
He said that anybody can go to Mauritania
that wants, he said that the hidden aspiration
of a mu'min is aqta'u min as
-saif, it's more cutting than the sword.
So if the hidden is strong, then people
can do amazing things.
He said, for example, Yahya, the American man
that became Muslim here, he's a young man,
he was, I think, 19 or 20, he
became Muslim.
He said he was a spoiled American from
Mudallab, that's what he said, spoiled American, wealthy,
from wealthy family, lost brothers.
And he became Muslim, and he wanted to
go seek knowledge.
He had a scholarship to, yeah, not scholarship,
but he paid, expense paid, Berkeley, everything.
And he actually came to me, he'd already
done two years of college, and I said,
initially, that just finish the university for your
parents' sake, and then go.
And my sister, and I told Shaykh Haddameen
this, my sister Nabila said, you did an
injustice to him.
I said, why?
It's only two years, it'll go fast, and
then he can go do what he wants.
She said, how do you know what will
happen to him in those two years?
Maybe he'll get a fitna in Berkeley.
Maybe he'll lose his desire for knowledge right
now that the fuel's, you know, in the
heart.
And I realized, when she said that, Nabila
told me that, I realized that she was
right.
And I went and I told him, you
know, that advice I gave you, I was
wrong.
And he said, I'm really glad you said
that, because I wasn't going to take it
anyway.
That's what he told me.
And then when I told Shaykh Haddameen, who's
the cousin of Shaykh Khatri and Murad Al
-Hajj's cousin, who's learned all his knowledge from
him.
When I told him that, he said, when
I told him what I said, and when
I told him what my sister said, he
said, Subhanallah, I wanted to tell you you
were wrong, but my respect for you prevented
me from doing that, but I'm glad your
sister did.
And he said, and I have love for
her because of the good counsel she gave
him.
Because, and so he said that, he's the
son of Murad Al-Hajj, he said he
lives in a little hut, with a, made
out of tree branches, with some rags tied
together.
He said, you learn one year, you can
learn four times, it's not very much.
And once you learn four times, you go
where you want, do what you want.
Once you learn your four times, practice it
in your house, do your job, do whatever
you want.
But if you only learn four times, don't
waste your time with other things, because it's
all, تквيض
تجويد تجويد تجويد تجويد Hadith should be
transmitted with Tajweed and when you do the
Adhkar like of the Sabah and Musa, you
should do them with the proper Makharijul Huruf,
where the Huruf comes from and also the
rules that apply to them.
And then the best of Ibadah is Tafakkur,
and the highest is what is called Al
-Fana, and Al-Fana comes from Imam Al
-Junaid, and Imam Al-Junaid called Al-Fana
'u, which in Arabic literally means extinction.
And this comes from the idea that the
nurse experiences separation.
In other words, each one of us has
an experience of separation from other people.
And one of the things that you notice
about a child is that a newborn does
not have that experience.
There's no mass, there's no eye, there's no
focus of the self.
And you can see it because even the
way they look around, there's no centralization.
And what happens is they begin, as the
child comes in to its identity, which is
its eyeness, then it begins to see itself
as separate.
Now, Imam Al-Junaid said that what happens
in deep spiritual practice is that there can
be experiences.
One type is called Ahad, which Ahad is
when somebody is overcome with a spiritual state
that often is uncontrollable.
I mean it is uncontrollable.
And the ulama of this science differentiate between
Hal and Maqam.
And Maqam is actually higher than Hal.
The Maqam is where you're fixed in a
state, a condition.
So Maqam of Tawbah is where you can't
do Masiyah, because you're in the Maqam of
Tawbah.
And now you're in a Tawbah and you're
in a Maqam now, and so you can't
do things wrong-wittingly.
The Hal of Tawbah is when, for instance,
somebody is doing wrong actions and suddenly an
intense state of remorse overcomes them and they
ask Allah for forgiveness.
Right?
So that's a Hal, but it's not a
Maqam.
And the Maqam is better because it continues.
Maqam of Zuhr is when somebody is in
a station.
Hal of Zuhr is a Hal that takes
them, and it doesn't last.
So a person might go into a Hal
of Zuhr, or they might go into a
Hal of Tawbah, but it doesn't last.
So the Maqam is over the Hal.
And then you have what's called Awarid.
And Awarid is an inrush that comes into
the heart, very powerful, and it usually floods
the heart with light.
And there's an incredible expansion that can happen
from that.
And that's also a temporary type state.
What he's saying is that the highest, and
there's something after Fana which is called Baqab.
But imagine, I'd said, and Fana is when
the self is no longer aware of itself.
In other words, there's a Reba that takes
place.
There's a loss of the experience of the
self.
And this does not last because if it
lasts, you call it insanity.
Right?
And that's why spiritual psychosis is real.
There are people that actually go into experiences
that they can't control or understand, and they
get sick.
And it happens all the time in this
culture.
There's a lot of people that do meditation
and go, like, get into Zen Buddhism or
get in, and they start doing a lot
of meditation, and they literally can lose it
completely.
And that's why it's so dangerous to be
doing these things without the protection of prayer,
without protection of wudu, without protection, because Islam
is all grounding.
We're not trying to get these spiritual experiences.
We're to be grounded.
That's what Allah has commanded us to do,
to be grounded.
But if you do the thing which Allah
commands you to do, and you do it
properly, then often there are certain things that
will happen interiorly in the inner self.
And those things, there's a science of understanding
them, which is part of the science of
the Khawater, knowing if it's from Shaytan, because
Shaytan has a lot of games that he
can play on people that are doing these
things, or if it's angelic, or if it's
from the nafs.
And this is one of the things about
New Age people, is that most of the
stuff that happens to them, because they do
have these experiences, like people that go into
New Age religion, or go into Zen, or
go into Kundalini, they have, like, fire yoga,
you do this Kundalini breathing, things like that.
In this culture, there's a lot of people
that do these type things.
And they do have experiences.
But they can't distinguish between the satanic, the
nafsanic, and the angelic, and the rahmanic experiences.
They can't.
They don't know how to distinguish between them.
And most of what's happening to them is
from Shaytan and the nafs.
What's that?
Possession.
Absolutely, yeah.
Possession is very real.
Like, people open up themselves to a jinn,
to come in, absolutely.
Yeah?
Doing dhikr?
They do what?
Ah, group dhikr.
Yeah, I'll talk about that in a second,
about group dhikr.
So anyway, this idea, this, what Sana'a
is, is simply, is that the experience of
the self, the person who's doing dhikr, is
no longer aware of the self.
And that can happen.
And he's saying that is the highest tafakkur.
And this is why when Sayyidina Ali's son,
not Hasan al-Husayn, but one of the
other sons was stuck with an arrow and
they wanted to take it out from him,
they waited till he went into prayer.
And when he went into prayer, they pulled
it out and he didn't feel it.
And that's somebody who's really in that state
of the self is absent.
Right?
The self is completely absent.
And there are people like in India, yogis,
that can do very radical things through meditation.
They can endure incredible pain and things like
this.
So this is not limited to the Muslims
in terms of the thoughts.
You know, the psyche has extraordinary powers.
But what the Muslims recognize is that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, if a person is
sincere and a person is remembering Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala, then Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala can put them in a state of
absolute witnessing with Allah where they're not aware
of their surroundings.
And many, many of the sahaba, obviously, many
of them were in that state.
And this is one of the interpretations of
the hadith that my slave does not draw
near to me by anything more beloved to
me than the fall.
And he will continue to draw near to
me with the marafil until I love him.
And when I love him, I become the
eye with which he sees, the ear with
which he hears, the tongue with which he
speaks, the hand with which he grasps.
And if he seeks refuge in me, I
give him refuge.
If he asks me, I give him.
That hadith never means that God becomes man,
which is called huloo.
Huloo is haram to believe that.
And if you believe that, you're outside of
Islam.
Huloo is the idea of incarnation.
And that hadith, it never means that.
And anybody that believes that is a zindiq,
they're heretic, out of Islam.
So we don't believe in divine incarnation.
We don't believe in that.
We don't believe that God becomes creation.
That's like Christian, Hindu, all those types.
But we do believe that the human being
can be in such a state of awareness
of the fi'al of Allah.
Because there's a fi'al of Allah that
is part of creation.
In other words, it's actually when Allah, like
the whole world is a fi'al of
Allah.
But we don't say it's Allah.
And there are people that go into a
state of absolute witnessing, where they see everything
being the fi'al of Allah.
In other words, they're seeing Allah behind all
of creation.
So they don't see otherness in the same
way that other people are in this world
of separation.
And that's why they recognize that everything is
from Allah.
The good and the bad.
And so they see it as all good.
And that's why, for the moment, everything is
good.
That's what that hadith means.
Even though there is good and bad, it's
all from Allah.
And because it's all from Allah, it has
to be all good for the moment.
Because even the bad, there's a wisdom in
it for him to grow, to be purified
and to draw nearer to Allah.
So he sees the bad even as good.
And that's why Allah says, أَعْسَنْ تُحِبُّ شَيْئًا
وَهُوَ شَرٌّ لَكُمْ Maybe you love a thing
and it's bad for you.
وَأَعْسَنْ تَكْرَهُ شَيْئًا وَهُوَ خَيْرٌ لَكُمْ And maybe
you hate a thing, but it's good for
you.
And Allah knows and you don't know.
So that's the idea of being in the
state of مشاهدة or مراقبة with Allah.
Now what you have
to do is just go through and you
have that sheet in front of you.
Now obviously you're going to find many different
versions of this.
Which is, these are called أَرْكَرُ الصَّبَاحُ وَالْمَسَاءُ
And my recommendation for myself and all of
you is to the best of your ability
to try to do these every day.
If you can't do all of them, there
are certain ones that you definitely should do.
And I'll point those out.
Now this particular one, we do not have
a specific word from the Messenger of Allah
ﷺ.
In other words, we do not have anything
that he left that says he did this
and then he did this and then he
did this.
So whenever you see these, they are going
to be, the formulations are different.
And Sidi Ahmed Zarouk has one, سَفِينَةٌ يَجَاءٌ
مِنْ إِلَى اللَّهِ الْتَجْزَاءُ Which is a very
nice one.
It's all from the book in the Sunnah.
And one of the things that Sidi Ahmed
Zarouk says is that you should do the
أَوْرَاد that came down from the Messenger of
Allah.
Before you go to any Du'as that
are written by other people.
So it is permissible to read Du'as
written by other people as long as they
knew what they were saying.
In other words, if they were known to
be Ulama and to be people of Allah,
then the Du'as that they wrote, the
Sahaba had Du'a, the Tabi'un had
Du'a, and they come down to us.
So there are Salawat that come from other
Musharraf.
But what Sidi Ahmed Zarouk said, if you're
not doing the Du'as and the Zikrs
that the Prophet told us we should do
every day, and you're preferring other people's over
theirs, then something's wrong.
That's what he said.
And Qadi Abu Bakr Ibn Arabi said at
the end of his book, Qanun At-Tawil,
he said that usually, he said that Shaitan's
first and foremost task for the Muslim is
to get them away from the remembrance of
Allah.
But he said if he finds them doing
much remembrance, then he will try to get
them away from doing the remembrance of Allah
that's from the book and the Sunnah.
And to get them doing remembrance that is
from other people or others.
So that's the strategy of Shaitan.
And so, the nice thing about, this is
the world of Shaykh Abdullah Al-Haddad, who
is from the Sahaba.
He's one of the Shurafa from Yemen.
And he's considered a Mujaddid also of the
12th century.
And his grandson was one of my teachers,
Shaykh Ahmad Mashhood Al-Haddad, who wrote Muftah
Al-Jannah, which is translated into English.
And so, I took this from him.
And he took it from his father.
He took it from his grandfather.
He took it from the author himself.
And he begins it by Bismillah Ar-Rahman
Ar-Rahim.
And that comes from the Hadith that anything
worth doing, if it does not begin with
Bismillah Ar-Rahman Ar-Rahim, it's cut off
from Barakah.
So, anything that's worth doing, you should always
do in the name of Allah, in the
name of compassion.
And then he begins with Qul Huwa Allahu
Ahad, three times.
And this comes from a Hadith in which
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said, Ayyajuzu Ahadukum
Al-Yakhtamul Qur'ana Kullayoun.
Is one of you incapable of reading the
Qur'an every day, one time?
And they said, who could do that, Ya
Rasulullah?
And they said, if you recite Ikhlas, Ikhlasu
Adilu Firath Al-Qur'an.
It actually is the equivalent of one third
of the Qur'an, in its weight and
meaning.
And so by reading it three times, we
hope for the reward of reading the entire
Qur'an.
And so it should be read every day,
preferably after every prayer, but at least in
the morning and the evening.
And then the next two are called the
Mu'awwilatain.
And Mu'awwil means the thing that gives
you refuge.
Ta'weeda.
And Ta'weeda is protection.
So the Mu'awwil gives you protection.
And the Mu'awwilatain are Qura'udu Bi
Rabbil Faraq Wa Qura'udu Bi Rabbil Naq.
And you should do those every day.
And there is a Hadith saying you should
do them before you go to sleep.
Right?
And then you cover yourself, which is a
protection from the jinn.
Jinn and Shayateen.
So he says to do that.
And then, Three times there is a Hadith
that says people should do that three times.
This is seeking refuge in Allah from the
Hamazat of Shaytan.
And Hamazat, Hamazat means like to goad somebody
on.
Like, come on, do it, do it.
So the Hamazat of the Shayateen are those
whisperings in the soul, which is telling you
to do things that you shouldn't do.
And so you are seeking refuge from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, from the Hamazat of
Shaytan.
And one of the signs of the end
of time is Taqthirul Hawsat.
That people's minds will become just, it's all
whispering, that's all they hear is whispering.
And it's really interesting now if you think
about this, is that so many people hear
all the time, music, films, television, all these
things, and all of that is from Shaytan,
I guarantee you.
All that stuff is from Shaytan.
The whole lot of it, lock, stock and
barrel.
And so what you are allowing Shaytan to
do, go in and go out, is to
literally not only whisper, but give you visual
images as well.
And those are all going into the heart.
And so what you are doing now, by
exposing yourself to that stuff, is you are
destroying your heart.
And so people are walking around with all
these images, that come to their mind, and
all these songs, and all these jingles, and
advertisement jingles, and music, and everywhere you go
now, in stores, and department stores, all these,
it's all house acts.
It's all this shopping, constantly bombarding people.
So this Du'a is a protection from
the Hamazats of Shaytan.
Yeah.
The Nafs have impulses as well.
Three times.
رَبِّ أَعُوذُ بِكَ مِنْ هَمَزَاتِ الشَّيَاطِينِ وَأَعُوذُ بِكَ
رَبِّهُمْ يَحْضَرُونَ So I seek refuge in you,
from the girding of Shaytan, or the insinuations
of Shaytan, of the Shayateen, and I seek
refuge in you my Lord, that they should
become present.
You say it all separately three times?
Yeah, separately.
You say it, رَبِّ أَعُوذُ بِكَ مِنْ هَمَزَاتِ
الشَّيَاطِينِ وَأَعُوذُ بِكَ رَبِّهُمْ يَحْضَرُونَ and then go
back and say it again, like that.
What do you mean by the sports?
What's that?
You mean like the sports in any of
the ways?
Hmm?
Sports, you said, if you're watching the TV?
Well, most sports has aura involved in it.
The majority of sports has aura.
They have people's flesh that you shouldn't be
seeing.
Huh?
You know?
So like, shorts, you should not see the
thighs of another human being.
Right?
I mean this is all, this is their
deen.
Yeah, Allah said, لَكُمْ وَلِيَ دِينٍ And Allah
says, don't be with people who take their
life as a لَعِبْ وَلَهُ play and pastime.
In fact, they call baseball in this country
the national pastime.
Right?
اللَّهُ الْدَيْنِ Huh?
That's what it is.
اللَّهُ الْدَيْنِ ها الوَطَنِ Right?
The national pastime.
So, go out, I mean if you want
to, to go out and play some sports,
at least you get some bodily exercise.
But to sit on a thing, I'm sitting,
and I'll tell you, I'm telling you, in
all honesty, when I was growing up, baseball
was like, I mean that was like my
life through high school.
And all I cared about was baseball.
You know?
And it's just, it's a waste of time.
That's all it is.
I cannot, I couldn't watch a game.
You couldn't pay me to watch a game
now.
I'm really serious.
And I used to, I loved baseball.
You know?
And football.
You couldn't pay me to watch it.
You know?
And I went to somebody's house, and they
were watching the Iranian-American soccer game.
Right?
And I did unfortunately indulge a little bit.
But it was at the person's house.
I wouldn't do that on my own.
I would not waste my time.
But it was a company, it was at
somebody's house.
But those type things, it's just a waste
of your life.
That's all.
And you need to decide how much you,
how much is an hour of your life
worth?
You know?
How much is it worth?
How much is two hours of your life
worth?
How much, if you could sell it, if
I could buy a year from you, people
are selling their kidneys now.
You know, they're selling their kidneys.
If I could buy a year of your
life, how much would you sell it for?
You know, how much is it worth?
It just depends.
You know, people, once you start realizing you're
going to be accountable for your life, and
not only for your life, but for every
minute, and it's the greatest gift that Allah
has given you after Iman, is hara, you
know, life itself, and akhira, and health, then
what do you do with what Allah has
provided you for?
We were created to utilize our time.
Which doesn't mean you can't enjoy yourself.
But it should be in mudahat.
Because Allah said, there's mudahat things that you
can do.
Right?
And that's why the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa
sallam, when there was a wedding, he asked
them, did you bring some entertainment?
And they said, yes.
And he said, because the Ansar, they like
entertainment.
And they said, and I like to show
the Jews and the Christians that we have
some fusha in our religion.
In other words, we've got some meaning, we're
not prudes, we're not people that, you know,
don't enjoy ourselves, and we're out of time
for things.
But what's happening in your life now, this
whole country is just, it's one big no.
It's all just for entertainment.
The whole thing.
These people have all they do.
They work to be entertained.
They work so they can have money to
go out and entertain themselves.
And so you, you know, we all need
to disengage from that.
Wean ourselves from this society.
We need to do it.
Just wean yourself.
Cut the nipple off.
You know, stop sucking from the breast of
Dunya and the breast of Lahut.
Right?
And it's nice.
You know, it's nice.
Sit back, watch a good movie for a
couple of hours.
And then what?
And there's always an empty feeling afterwards.
Right?
Like you just wasted two hours of your
life.
Right?
And everybody, if that's the end, in the
end of it, you watch it, and then
what?
Why would I do that?
Right?
It's all a trick.
It's just they trick you into it So,
أَفَحَسِبْتُمُ or أَفَحَسِبْتُمُ in the next one أَنَّمَا
خَرَقْنَاكُمْ عَذَثًا Do you see it right there?
Do you think we created you عَذَثًا just
for fun?
Did we create you in vain?
Right?
أَفَحَسِبْتُمُ أَنَّمَا خَرَقْنَاكُمْ عَذَثًا وَأَنَّكُمْ إِلَيْنَا لَا
تُرْفِعُونَ And you won't be returned to us?
And you're not going to come back to
us?
Exalted is Allah, the King, the Truth.
There is no God but He.
رَبِّ الْعَشِدْ كَرِيمِ The Lord of the...
Knoweth Whom.
وَمَنْ يُدْعُو مَعَ اللَّهِ وِلَهِ الْآخَرَةِ لَا تُرْهَمَ
لَهُ بِهِ فَإِنَّمَا حِسَبُوا عَنْدَ رَبِّهِمْ وَهُمَا يَتْرَحُوا
الْكَفِرُونَ That is an ayah of Quran that
it came that the Prophet صلى الله عليه
وسلم used to say it every day.
وَقِرَّبَكُ فِي الْوَرَحَمُ وَإِنتَ خَيْرُ الرَّاحِمِينَ And say
another ayah and this is a dua Oh
Allah, forgive, have compassion and we are the
best of those who show mercy.
And then another ayah which the Prophet used
to say every day فَسُبْحَانَ اللَّهِ حِنَ تُمْسُونَ
Glory be to Allah when you come into
the evening وَحِنَ تُسْبِحُونَ and when you come
into the morning and this is the idea
of doing adhkar at those times مساء والصباح
this is the time to say subhanallah وَلَوْا
الْحَمْدُ فِي السَّمَوَاتِ وِالْأَرْضِ وَعَشِيًّا وَحِنَ تَظْهِرُونَ and
he has praise in the heavens and the
earth and in the evening and at dhuhr
time and this is the proof for also
the ayah that looks at the five prayers
because the prayer of حِنَ تُمْسُونَ is asr
prayer حِنَ تُسْبِحُونَ is fajr prayer and then
عَشِيًّا وَحِنَ تَظْهِرُونَ the evening prayer is the
maghrib and the isha prayer وَحِنَ تَظْهِرُونَ is
the dhuhr prayer is the dhuhr for رَبِّ
الْخَيْرُ الرَّحْمِينَ does that mean for oneself or
is that a dhuhr for all for all
muslims that رَبِّ الْخَيْرُ رَبِّ الْخَيْرُ الرَّحْمِينَ وَرَحَمْ
وَتَخَيْرُ الرَّحْمِينَ forgive and show mercy and you're
the best of those I mean it's a
general but it's اغفر لي when you're asking
this is just for yourself and then يَخْرِجْ
الْحَيَّ مَنَ الْمَيْتِينَ وَيَخْرِجْ الْمَيْتِ مَنَ الْحَيِّ He
brings the living from the dead and the
dead from the living one of the meanings
the nafasirin mention is like chicken comes from
an egg but you know the human being
came from a dead inanimate source but also
meaning is he brings iman from kufr and
kufr from iman so that's also the spiritual
meaning that dead hearts come to life with
iman and living hearts can die by going
into kufr and then the prophet and he
said and you bring the earth back to
life after it's died and like that you
will raise us up so that's also an
indication that the heart can come back to
life because ard in the Quran is used
also مَجَازٍ بِالْقَلْبِ and that's a traditional tafsir
so Allah brings the heart back to life
with the remembrance of Allah after it died
from his forgetfulness and then the prophet used
to say this ta'weezah with سَمِيرْ عَلِيمٍ
عَلِيمُ بِاللَّهِ سَمِيرْ عَلِيمٍ مِنَ الشَّيْطَانِ الرَّجِيمِ that's
one of his ta'weezah three times and
then this verse of the Quran was recited
by the prophet it comes that he used
to say this also in the morning and
in the evening and that is the ayah
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
لَوْ أَنزَلْنَا هَذَا الْقُرْآنَ عَلَى جَبْلٍ بَرَأَيْتُهُ خَاشِعًا
مِن تَصَدِّعَ مِنْ خَشَّةٍ دَاءٍ had we revealed
this Quran to a mountain we would have
seen the mountain humbled, shattered from the khashya
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and khashya
is fear with knowledge right, unlike khawth khawth
is fear like a rat can have fear
but a rat cannot have khashya so the
khashya the ulama are those who have khashya
of Allah and that's why the messenger of
Allah said because khashya is only the people
who have knowledge and he was also اَنَا
اَعْلَمُكُمْ دُنْيَا I'm the most knowledgeable of you,
of Allah so he was اَخْشَاكُمْ so what
Allah is saying is this Quran has so
much knowledge in it that if it was
even revealed to a mountain which is an
inanimate thing that you would see that mountain
shattered and humbled from khashya from a fear
that resulted in a knowledge that came from
the meanings of the Quran so that's why
تَبَدَّرَ الْقُرَانِ will lead to khushuwa will lead
to humble awareness of Allah and then Allah
says these are analogies or likenesses that we
strike similitudes that we strike for humanity so
that they will reflect so does it mean
that the mountain has knowledge?
some of the scholars say the mountain is
a scholar because that's one of the words
for a scholar mountain هو جبل من الجبال
like they'd say امام شافع كان جبلا من
الجبال he was a mountain from the mountain
so it means if it was revealed to
anybody who was powerful in their knowledge and
understanding that the Quran would shatter them but
Allah also in the Quran He said we
gave this opportunity to the heavens the earth
and the mountains and they say Allah began
with the heavens first because it's His greatest
creation greatest in terms of its awesomeness the
messenger of Allah is His greatest in terms
of maqam but in terms of the awesomeness
the heavens are greater than anything and only
the astronomer is the only one that can
really understand that and then the next is
the earth itself and then the mountain so
Allah said that and that refusal they say
is not a refusal of imam and then
Allah says He is Allah there's no doubt
in it the knower of the seen the
unseen shahada means the seen it also means
the testimony and that's because all of this
shahada everything that you can see is testifying
la ilaha illallah that's why the prophet said
how wondrous is it that a man can
disobey Allah or a man can disbelieve in
Allah what a strange thing و في كل
تحريكة و في كل تحريكة و تسكينة other
than shahid and in every movement and stillness
always there is a shahid a witness and
everything in creation is testifying that Allah is
one so the shahada is this world and
the meaning of this world is la ilaha
illallah that's what the whole world is saying
to the human being and he is the
one that can decode that right and that's
why Allah said the king the
holy the sanctified the complete it doesn't have
peace peace salam here does not mean peace
and it's wrong to call Allah peace like
we mean in that's not what it means
the believer and the overseer the guider right
mu'min means really the one who makes others
safe right, who gives them amin the one
who oversees everything is in control the great,
the powerful the compeller the one who compels
people and things to do what they do
the exalted, the magnified, the great glory to
Allah above what they associate and subhan in
Arabic means tamzeeh what you're doing is you're
saying Allah is not like anything when you
say subhanallah it's tamzeeh you're saying Allah is
not like anything these three attributes and khaliq
is the one the closest approximation I don't
like to use these words because it's problematic
in tawhid but al-khaliq the three stages
of creation is khalq, bar' and taswir khaliq
is that Allah decides to create and he
has the qudra the ilm and the irada
to do those and when those three come
together then we get the tamzeeh of creation
in his ultimate reality Allah has that sumahiya
it's always there his power to be khaliq
is always there when he decides to create
he is al-bari in other words the
decision is khaliq when he actually brings it
into existence that's al-bari the one who
brings it this is called bari'ah creation
is like the prophet has called khair al
-bari'ah bari'ah is the thing that
the bari'ah has brought into existence musawwir
is the fashioner in other words like for
a fetus you would see it that the
khaliq is the one that determined that there
would be a human life the bari'ah
is the one that formulated the semen in
the man the ovum in the woman brought
them together and then the musawwir is the
one who fashions the creation makes all the
cells emerge the liver becomes a liver the
brain becomes a brain the backbone becomes that's
musawwir now all of these in reality are
there's no linearity to Allah so Imam al
-Ghazali says these are only facets and because
you are him they can only look at
things from we can only see one part
at any one time Allah is telling us
what he has in a multi-faceted reality
but it's only multi-faceted from our limited
perspective in reality it's all one it's Allah
so attributes are only approximations for human beings
to understand because we're in time and our
intellects are limited and so these are just
facets of the same creational process that's is
that clear?
lahil asma'u l-husna Allah has the
most beautiful names yusabbihu lahum lahil samawati wa
l-arbi everything in the heavens and the
earth and now there's nighayru l-aqal everything
even rocks atoms everything is praising Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala wahul azizu l-hakim and
he is al-aziz, al-hakim and then
salamun alamuhi fi al-alamin inna kabarika nizdi
muhsinin innahum min ibadina muminin now I don't
know if this came in I don't know
if he got that from a hadith it's
an ayah in the Quran but I don't
know if he got it from a hadith
or that's his own ishtihad and one of
the wisdoms I think behind this this ayah
being in the word is that in a
sense we are for the moment he is
like this is an age of nuh in
other words there's a massive flood coming really
and all of us know it right and
when you start telling people most people are
going to laugh at you and you start
building an ark in this age which is
trying to get ready for the akhira people
think you're a fool so what nuh alayhi
salam was doing in his time the movement
in this time it's very similar people if
you're if you're concerned about akhira now people
think you're stupid what do you there's no
akhira why are you wasting your time and
do this work and even muslims remember they
won't say it literally because they don't want
to say they don't believe in akhira but
all of their actions would indicate they don't
believe in akhira because all they're concerned about
is dunya and when they see muslims that
are concerned about akhira they tell them ya
khi why don't you do something you know
get you know for your dunya right i'm
only dunyata ka ammaka ta'ishu abada right
so right oh
allah i have come into this morning with
ni'ma in a blessing wa aafiyatin wa aafiyatin
allahummin yasbahtu minka bi ni'matin wa aafiyatin and
aafiyat good health wa sitrin and veiled from
my wrongs by you fa atimna or atmim
there's two riwayah fa atimna ni'matika aliyya wa
aafiyatika wa sitrika fi dunya wa akhira so
for full for full your blessing upon me
and your aafiyah and your veiling in the
dunya and the akhira three times allahummin yasbahtu
minka bi ni'matin wa aafiyatin wa sitrin fa
atimna ni'matika aliyya wa aafiyatika wa sitrika fi
dunya wa akhira three times the next one
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam said whoever recites
that four times it's as if they freed
a human being from bondage that's the equivalent
of the reward of doing this so allahummin
yasbahtu ushiduka oh allah i come into the
morning calling you to bear witness wa ushidu
hamarat arshika and the angels that carry your
throne wa malaikatika and all of the angels
wa jamila khalqika annaka anta allahu la ilaha
illa anta wahdaka da sharikara wa anu muhammadan
abduku wa rasuluk so four times to say
that oh allah i come into the morning
calling you to witness and calling your throne
bearers your angels and all of your creation
that you are allah there is no god
but you allahum without partner and that muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam is your servant and your
messenger and then this one alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen
hamda yuwaafi ni'mahu wa yukaafi mazeeda this hadith
also this is fulfilling all the hamd and
shukr for all the ni'mah of allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and when maradtar hajj habibullah
when we asked him for like a wasiya
to give to people that's the dua that
he gave and he says that one i've
heard him say that a lot alhamdulillahi rabbil
alameen hamda yuwaafi ni'mahu i praise allah the
lord of all the worlds a praise that
is appropriate to all of his ni'mah wa
yukaafi mazeeda and also reciprocates this hamd is
recompenses all of the increase that he gives
us and then this one is a dua
that the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam said that
if you say it then it removes all
of the shirk and a protective dua which
is i believe in allah the magnificent and
i disbelieve in anything which is magical anything
that is associated or worshipped with other than
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and i have
clung to the firmest handle which is the
quran and the sunnah and the way of
islam and this handle will never break off
as long as you cling to it then
you are safe it does not separate there
is no separation that occurs and allah is
and then the next one the prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam said whoever says this three times
then allah subhanahu wa ta'ala this is
a ridwan so that you get the ridwan
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala because what
you are saying is raddaitu bindahi radda i
am content with allah as my lord wa
bi islami dina and with islam as my
deen wa bi muhammadan or bi sayyidina its
not in the warid but the shirk this
is mukharafah ta'duban which we talked about but
its permissible to add sayyid out of ta'dub
like sayyidina ali refused to remove muhammad rasulallah
so you will see them both but the
actual that comes warid is bi muhammadan sallallahu
alayhi wasallam nabiyya wa rasulallah so i am
content with the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam muhammad
as my prophet and my messenger and then
again the next one comes down in may
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam said that we
should say this seven times in the morning
in the evening and i can't remember if
it goes with this and i can't remember
what it is hasfi allahu laa idha hu
aree talakaz wa hu rabbil aashid azeem seven
times allah is enough for me there is
no god but him i have put my
trust in allah and he is the lord
of the magnificent throne seven times and then
allahumma salli ala sayyidina muhammad wa alihi wasallam
this is a very short dua of the
prophet a prayer on him and we know
in the hadith the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said that jibreel gave him bushra that whoever
says prayer on the prophet one time allah
says prayer on him which is rahma right
allah gives his rahma on him ten times
so he is saying do that ten times
which would be the equivalent of a hundred
times of allah's rahma upon you and it's
preferable you should at least try to do
prayer on the prophet a hundred times in
the morning a hundred times in the evening
and shaykh muhammad for a long period of
his life did it five thousand times a
day as a practice right and and he
used to do for fourteen years he did
dua twice a day and khatm of quran
once a day and a hundred and fourteen
thousand times bismillahirrahmanirrahim every day he did that
for fourteen years and they said when he
came out of his khalwa people made tauba
just by seeing him he lived in fars
at madras for the people that were there
he was there that was his room and
in fact he was in that room so
long and he memorized one of the really
difficult books of madaki fifth there which is
several volumes he memorized it by heart he
was a great madaki scholar as well he
was a faqih but he they were saying
that he had a treasure up there that
he was hiding you know people talk and
they think why is he up there and
he never leaves he must have some gold
up there that he doesn't want anybody to
get and so they went to his father
to convince him to go up there because
he wouldn't let anybody come up and there
was a ladder to get to it so
his father came up to come up he
let him up and when he came up
he had written mot which means death all
over the walls and there was nothing in
the room and he just he said he
realized his father said he realized some people
are not valid and other people are not
valid you know he was just in a
completely other world Allah Akbar if you say
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam then you would do
it if you do it like that there
then it would be sallama with a fatha
but if you did it like that Allahumma
salli ala Sayyidina Muhammad wa sallim like that
there are two different ways this form in
Arabic is a form of dua even though
you're using the past tense it's actually a
dua like when you say rahimahu Allah what
you're saying is may Allah have mercy on
him but you do it in the past
tense tafa'ulan that Allah has already done
it it's just accepted so you say radiallahu
anhum sahaba in past tense but you could
also say Allahumma ardi'an Abi Bakr wa
Umar wa Uthman wa Ali you could say
ardi'an to do it in the dua
that's a dua so when you do it
like this suddenly you're doing a dua a
different way you're doing it with the shirat
al-dua or shirat al-amr this is
shirat al-dua right and so there you
would say sallim with a kasra and that's
the way he's doing it there yeah there's
different ones that you can do that's a
very common one this one's easy because it's
shorter so you could do a lot of
them and this is actually the shirat I
think the shir who used and then after
that this is the dua to say that
the prophet used to say which means oh
Allah I ask you for good surprises and
I seek refuge in you from bad surprises
right fujaa is something that happens suddenly like
a surprise so it's asking Allah to make
good surprises happen in your day and not
bad ones and then now this is called
sayyidul istighfar and the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam said and it's in the sahih hadith
that this istighfar is the sayyidul istighfar it's
the least lord of all the ways of
asking forgiveness this is the best way to
ask forgiveness and so you say oh Allah
you're my lord there's no god but you
you created me and I'm your servant and
I'm on your ahad the ahad of Islam
and your promise to forgive and to enter
me into jannah as best as I'm capable
of so in other words as best I'm
able I'm doing what you commanded me to
do and then I seek refuge in you
from the evil that I have perpetrated from
the evil that I have perpetrated I go
it's like I return an admittance that all
my blessings is from you so I'm admitting
to you or returning all my blessings to
you they're all from you and then and
I take full responsibility for my wrong actions
in other words I did them they're mine
I admit them so forgive me because only
you can forgive wrong actions so that's this
is another dua that's worth it whatever
Allah willed was and whatever he didn't will
was not and this is sometimes to do
when situation misiba calamity you just it's
just admitting that and then I know I
know that Allah is powerful over all things
and that Allah encompasses all things in knowledge
I seek refuge from the evil of my
soul and from the evil of every creature
that you have taken by its forelock so
this is a reminder of tawhid that every
creature is has Allah has them by the
forelock so their evil is only because Allah
brought them to you because Allah has them
by the forelock so if you seek refuge
in Allah from the evil of others then
Allah will protect you from their evil what's
that?
yeah there
are many hadith that indicate is the you
get about it but it's a powerful dua
to call on Allah there's a hadith of
doing it before fajr 41 times also so
it's a powerful those two names are very
powerful names I'm seeking through your mercy and
I'm seeking which is safety from your punishment
rectify all of my affair and do not
leave me to my own soul and don't
leave me to anyone from your creation even
the blinking of an eye so you be
the one my tiklam don't make me depend
on anybody else other than you this does
not mean that you won't get help from
others but you only see that it's Allah
so what he's saying is don't make me
think that other Jabir Sadiq R.A and
who once a an atheist told him he
didn't believe in Allah and Jabir Sadiq said
to him have you ever been on the
sea and he said yes and this was
probably cursed from him or something but the
man said in fact I was once on
a boat that a storm came and it
was such a heavy storm that the boat
actually was ripped to pieces and all the
sailors drowned and I was left clinging to
a board and he said but then the
ocean took the board from my hands until
there was nothing left and then he said
Ben what did you do he said I
was flung by the ocean to the shore
and I survived and so Jabir Sadiq R
.A said to him when you got on
that boat you put your trust in the
boat and in the sailors and then when
Allah took those away from you you put
your trust in that little piece of wood
that you were holding on to and he
said when you lost that wood where did
you put your trust then he said did
you hope that you would survive and he
said yes I hoped that I would survive
he said who did you hope for where
was the Raja in other words you are
there about to drown and you have this
hope that you are going to live and
what did you put the hope because hope
has to have an object in the Arabic
language there has to be an object to
hope right Rajautu it's muta'addi there has
to be so he was in Arab he
knew so he said from whom were you
hoping for safety from whom and then he
said Ya Abdullah he told him servant of
Allah the one that took away all your
means and then saved you in spite of
all the means being taken away from you
that was Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala right
so that that's what he's saying la takilni
ila nafsi wala ila ahadin min kharaqil ka
tarifata a'inin and there's a real wala
aqal min dharik and not even less than
the blink of an eye Allahumma inni a
'udhukum min alhazm alhazm this is something that
the Prophet and Sheikh Khatri told me that
somebody came to him once and told him
he didn't have a job and he gave
him this dua and he got a job
a few days later and that comes from
a dua in which a man came to
the Prophet and he said Ya Rasool Allah
I have all these debts and I'm in
hum I have all this worry and huzn
and the Prophet gave him this dua and
he said he started reading it and Allah
took care of all his debts and then
he he lost his grief right so Allahumma
inni a'udhukum min alhazm alhazm wa a
'udhukum min alajzi walkasal so in other words
I seek refuge in you from hum is
from the past or hum actually is from
the future hum is where you're worried about
the future so it's anxiety about the future
and hum is where hum is where there's
a concern and ram is where there's no
concern ham and ram are similar but one
has an object and the other doesn't there's
no real reason so hum and huzn or
hazm hum is for the future and huzn
is for the past so you're seeking refuge
of Allah from grief about the past and
from anxiety about the future and there's another
in the Quran Allah says ara inna awliya
Allah la khawthun alim wa rahum yahzanun they
have no fear about the future nor do
they have grief about the past right so
getting out of you know this is about
getting into the present tense because there's no
past and future for Allah right and so
if you're in a state where you're in
a state of awareness of Allah the past
is of no concern and the present is
of no concern because the past you can't
do anything about it and the present is
in the hands of Allah you don't know
if you'll I mean the future is in
the hands of Allah you don't know if
you'll make it to the future all you
have is the present so there's no point
in worrying about the past or in having
anxiety about the future so this is seeking
refuge min al-hamni wal-hazm wa a
'udhu bikum min al-'ajzi wal-kasal and I
seek refuge in you from the ajiz is
the one who's incapable of doing something but
he has irada he has desire but he
doesn't have qudra so irada bila qudra the
kaslan is the one who has qudra but
no irada he has the ability but he
doesn't have the will so the manju' Allah
was seeking refuge in both those conditions you
don't want to be in either one you
want to be somebody who has qudra and
irada you want to have the ability to
do what you need to do and you
want to have the irada to do what
you should be doing so seeking refuge from
ajiz and kasal are two important things wa
a'udhu bikum min al-jubli wal-bukhli
and you seek refuge from juban and bukham
juban is jabaran is a coward and the
word in Arabic jubna is curded like a
coward is somebody who is they are not
firm when they need to be firm they
turn into like curded cheese right they don't
have stability sabat so it's seeking refuge from
the inability to give yourself with shaja'a
when you need to bukhal is the the
cowardice of money so juban is the cowardice
of your wealth of your body and bukhal
is the cowardice of your wealth and those
are the two things Allah asked you he
bought from you wa la-llah ash-shara
min al-mu'mineen anfusuhum wa amwaduhum bi-anadahum
al-jannah Allah bought from the believers their
selves and their wealth and against it is
paradise right so they have to do jihad
with what amwaduhum wa anfusuhum and mazina al
-hazana he said bi-anwaduhum wa anfusuhum if
you're jadaan you can't do jihad with your
body because you're a coward if you're dakhian
you can't do jihad with your wealth because
you're a miser so by having juban or
bukhal you won't be able to fulfill what
Allah has purchased from you and that's why
it's really important to seek refuge in Allah
from juban or jubani or bukhal wa a
'udhu bika min ghanabat al-dain wa qahar
al-rijal and I seek refuge in you
from overwhelming debt and from being overpowered by
people by men and the reason these two
are put together is because if you look
historically in fact one of the reasonable law
items if you look historically the muslims the
way the kufar overcame us was through debt
I guarantee you anybody study the history you'll
see this the first thing that the kufar
started doing was loaning the muslims money and
when they were incapable of paying they got
them to a point because they were interest
loans they got them to a point where
they couldn't pay the loans and that's when
they started demanding concessions that's when they started
demanding concessions and so debt is a way
that people get control over you and that's
why in this country this whole country is
designed to get people into debt I guarantee
you the tax laws are designed for people
to be in debt and the bankers did
that because they want control and they now
make people economic slaves and they were slaves
because most people will not accept to be
physical slaves right they'll rebel people don't like
to be taken into slavery they'll rebel but
economic slavery people feel guilt and in fact
the word for debt in German Schuld is
the same word that we get for guilt
because when you're in debt I'm indebted to
you we use it as a metaphor I
owe you something so by being in debt
people are felt to be you know weak
and they become slaves so this is a
very important wisdom in seeking refuge from debt
and from being overpowered by people because they
go together right and that's why there's a
hadith the
ulama said if there was anything after Islam
better to ask for and Aafia actually includes
Islam as well but if there was anything
better to ask for than Aafia the prophet
would have told his uncle Adas so asking
Allah for Aafia which is a well being
spiritual physical economic everything it's a well being
Aafia right And
this is why when Sayyidina Umar went to
Sham, Sayyidina Mu'awiyah was wearing a very
excellent robe, a Shami robe.
And it was all ornamented and Umar got
upset about it.
And Sayyidina Umar, Sayyidina Uthman said, These are
people, if you wear what we're used to
wearing in the desert, they'll treat you like
you're nothing.
So what he was indicating there, there's a
hikmah in that.
Now Sayyidina Umar did take off his robe
and put on a good robe.
And then he was on a donkey, he
got on a barzoon.
And then when he got on it, he
got off and he actually put it back
on, his other robes.
He refused to do it and he just
said, Allah gave us dignity in our Islam,
not in all this outward trapping.
And if we seek the Izzah in other
than that, Allah will humiliate us.
So that, I mean Umar...
And interestingly in Jerusalem, in their books, they
know that the man who predicted it would
open it up, had I think 73 patches
on his robe.
And they counted the robes on Sayyidina Umar
and he had 73, the number that was
in their books.
So, how, 72?
17?
How, maybe, I'm not sure.
Just about the last thing, somebody asked me
about zikr in the group.
There's a khiraf about zikr in jama'ah.
The umar considered it to be a bid
'ah makruha.
In other words, it wasn't haram.
The thing that troubled him was that he
did not have a nasr that indicated that
the messenger of Allah, or the sahaba, did
it.
Umar Shafi'i considered it to be permissible
and there was nothing in it.
And he used the proofs from hadith that
indicate that there was...
There was a teacher and a group learning
and he sat with the people learning and
he said...
I was sent a teacher.
But he didn't make inkar out of the
other group.
Because of the weakness of that hadith, it's
hard to get a hukm on it.
But there is another absolutely sound hadith which
says that Allah has mala'ika sayyara, traveling
angels, that look for hilaqa zikr.
They're looking for the circles of zikr.
And when they come upon them, they descend
on them.
And then when they go back to Allah,
Allah asks them, how did you find my
servants?
And then the hadith says...
Allah knows better.
He's just...
this is to teach us.
And they said...
We found them saying...
And it says that they were in a
halaqa.
Now, some of the ulema said it's permissible
to come together but not to do it
on one voice.
Because the hadith does not indicate that there
was one voice.
Other of the ulema said, there's no prohibition
of doing it on one voice.
And zikr is permissible.
And so they don't see that there should
be any prohibition.
Because there are definitely hadith that indicate that
they did say things together.
Like takbir and things like that.
So you're gonna get khilafi issues.
The majority of the scholars, particularly the later
scholars, permitted it.
The mu'hideen actually encouraged it in Morocco.
And they actually encouraged reading the Quran from
one voice together.
And they created a sunnah in Morocco that
continues after this day.
Which was having the Quran completed every month
in the masjid of Morocco.
And they do that to this day.
And the mu'hideen started that.
And the reason they did it is because
they said people have stopped reading the Quran.
And if we have a huzb in the
masjid, then there'll be many people that will
read it just because it's there and it's
a good thing to do.
So it's like encouraging them to do it.
And so they said it was better that
people read and do khatm of the Quran,
than that they don't read it.
Ibn al-Hajj disagreed with them in his
madkhal.
And said, instead of khatm of the Quran,
he liked to hear poetry.
And he did say, tell people to recite.
And this is many hadith sahih.
And he used to listen to it and
say, ee-wee, let's hear some more.
And they used to sing their poetry, the
alhan al-arab.
They used to sing it in things.
So an-ashid, like in Palestine, Syria, and
in Morocco, they have ways of singing poems
about Allah, about the Messenger of Allah.
Things like that.
That's permissible.
And that is a type of entertainment even,
that would definitely be permissible.
Because it's very beautiful to listen to.
You know, if it's done well and they
have good voices.
I mean, that is, you know, people should
listen to that, and not listen to music
and things like that.
Do you have a translation of it?
No, I don't have one.
But I just gave you one, pretty much.
So it's on tape.
And it would need to be worked on,
because I did that just...
I would learn the meanings, but they're beneficial
even without the meanings.
Muhammad, what does Abu Hanifa say about dhikr?
I don't know.
I mean, as far as I know, I
think Abu Hanifa, may Allah bless him and
grant him peace, his madhab accepts dhikr and
group, you know.
So, and traditionally Muslims did it.
If you study the early books, they definitely
did group dhikr and...
Murad al-Hajj doesn't do it.
But Murad al-Hajj is like Ibn al
-Hajj in the madhhab.
He, anything that even smells of bid'ah
or something that's not, but he won't make
inkar.
He doesn't make inkar, because he's an alim,
and he knows the hukm.
But he himself, yathawarra, that's all.
But if you spend time with him, all
he does is dhikr.
So he doesn't need to do, you know,
being in his company is in group dhikr.
Because everybody's in dhikr, you know.
So, alhamdulillah.
You know, but...
People, the point is, remember Allah.
Those who remember Allah standing, sitting and reclining
on their sides.
And there's a hadith which he mentioned, Sheikh
Khatri.
You know, that the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said, Shall I tell you what the best
of all your actions is, and the most
pure with your love, and better than you
that you should go out and fight jihad?
He said, we did not.
Striking the necks of the enemies and then
killing you.
They said, tell us, Ya Rasulallah.
He said, dhikr Allah.
Remembrance of Allah.
And the ulama stipulate that if, if the
city is being attacked, then jihad is over
everything.
So, again, you have to see those things
contextually.
In other words, you know, if there's people
out defending the city, and there's a group
saying, Oh, it's better to do dhikr.
Don't you know that, Habib?
That's just stupidity and ignorance.
So, everything is contextual.
But dhikr is the highest thing.
And that's why hajj, fatawa'an, is better
than jihad, according to the ulama.
In other words, to do hajj, voluntarily, and
fulfilling the fard kifaya, is better than going
out on voluntary jihad.
Because, see, the point is, jihad, don't forget
this.
Jihad is a means to an end.
But the end is worship of Allah.
So, an end is always over the means.
And that's the point.
We weren't created to kill people.
We were created to remember Allah.
But if there's people stopping us from remembering
Allah, and they're killing us because we want
to remember Allah, then we have to go
out and stop them.
And that's the point.
So, jihad has the high status that it
has.
And Allah says in the Qur'an, يَا
أَيُّهَا الَّذِينَ آمِنُوا أَسْتَجِيبُوا لِلَّهِ وَلَا الرَّسُولِ إِذَا
دِعَاكُمْ لِمَا يَحْيِيكُمْ Answer Allah and His Messenger
when they call you to what brings you
back to life.
The ulama, almost by consensus, say, the tafsir
of that ayat is jihad.
But that's what brings this ummah back to
life.
So, in no way should we belittle jihad
or the maqam of jihad.
You know, really.
And the mujahid is honored in this ummah.
You know, and all of us should have
a desire for shahada.
And the Prophet said, whoever dies and he's
never even inside himself had an inner discourse
of saying, I wish I could go on
jihad, he dies a monarch.
Yeah, so, jihad is big.
So, I'm not in any way belittling jihad
by that.
But, you know, I just think people have
really forgotten.
And the other thing about it is what
will give the Muslims the yaqeen when they
go to fight and also what will give
them the ability to fight for the sake
of Allah is dhikr of Allah.
Because there's a lot of Muslims that want
to go out and fight just because they're
angry.
Seriously.
They're just angry.
They're angry at the world.
They're angry at the Americans.
They're angry at this.
And there's a lot to be angry about.
But that's not, that's not spirituality.
That's not, it's not for the nafs.
Right?
So, and that's, and by doing dhikr, that's
what you do to your heart.
You'll put it in a state where it
will be for Allah, not for its own
self.
Uh-huh.
Well, maybe, the Mawlid is a khidr.
I mean, I personally think that we on
CO3, that women have resolved those issues centuries
ago and it's really sad that we're even
talking about it anymore.
The Mawlid is, the celebration of the Mawlid
was not something that they did in the
first community.
But they were celebrating at every single day
of their lives.
There's no doubt about that.
I mean, they were celebrating at every day
of their life.
And there's a sahih hadith that the man
asked the Prophet, said, can I fast on
Mondays?
And he said, fihi, we did too.
I was born on Monday.
In other words, that's an excellent day to
fast because I was born on that day.
And that's a sound hadith.
There's another hadith in which the Prophet said
that Abu Lahab is given a tiny bit
of water what's between his thumb and his
forefinger every Monday in Jahan because he freed
a slave girl the day that he was
born.
Right?
So Abu Lahab gets repose in Jahan every
Monday because he celebrated the Prophet's birthday by
freeing...
So I would never say we don't celebrate
the Prophet's birthday.
And I've heard people say that.
And there's a hadith that says Inna ahadithum
la yuqid bi karima la yuqidahadala A man
will say a word and he doesn't even
think about it.
And I've heard people say we don't celebrate
the Prophet's birthday.
I don't think they do that.
You should never say that.
I mean, if you want to put it
into a fiqh context, you can say to
celebrate his birthday on a specific day is
something the Salaf didn't do.
But to say we don't celebrate his birthday.
You know.
No.
We celebrate his birthday.
We should be happy every day of our
lives that he was born.
Because it's only through him that we got
to know Allah.
It's only through his sacrifice that we have
the doom today.
So we celebrate.
We should celebrate every day that he was
born.
Doing it on the 12th of Rabi'ul
Awwal is...
That is a later innovation.
Most of the ulama said it was a
bid'ah hasana.
That's what they said.
And they all bid'ah hasana.
There are some ulama that were against it.
And that's the truth.
They were.
The majority of them weren't.
Imam Suudi read a fatwa and said it
was a good thing.
And that people should do it.
You can look at the fatwa in Al
-Haram al-Fatari.
It's in his book of fatwas.
So, if you don't want to, that's fine.
But making people who do halawa and don't
pray and don't do and then they celebrate
the birthday of the Prophet.
His priorities were all wrong.
If you want to celebrate the Prophet's birthday,
then do what he told you to do.
And that's what's going to make him happier
than anything.
But once a year, getting together and celebrating
his birthday and then the rest of the
year you don't do anything he told you
to do.
It's just shameful.
To hear the seerah is good.
And traditionally that's what they used to do
at the moment was recite his birth and
his manaqib.
They would recite the noble qualities of the
Messenger of Allah and that's a good thing
to do.
Do you mean that if we celebrate the
Prophet's birthday on the actual birthday of the
Prophet of Islam?
That's the difference in the party of East
and West.
No, that's one of the arguments against it.
Yeah, so...
The Time magazine had an article about that
and they showed a picture of a guy
celebrating his birthday literally.
Yeah.
There you go.
We should pray Asr.
Allahumma la ilaha illa ma a'allamtana innaka
tala hakeem al-'aleem Allahumma iftah alayna hikmatak wa
inshura alayna rahmatak ya zan al-jalali wa
al-ikram Allahumma iftah alayna hikmatak wa inshura
alayna rahmatak ya zan al-jalali wa al
-ikram Allahumma iftah alayna hikmatak wa inshura alayna
rahmatak ya zan al-jalali wa al-ikram
wa salillahumma ala sayyidina Muhammad wa alihi wa
sahbihi wa sallim taslimah wa la hawla wa
la quwwata illa billahi al-'aliyyi al-'azim wa la
hawla wa la quwwata illa billahi al-'aliyyi al-'azim
wa la hawla wa la quwwata illa billahi
al-'aliyyi al-'azim Bismillah
ar-Rahman ar-Rahim Bismillah ar-Rahman ar
-Rahim Alhamdulillah I think it is a blessing
that we came to an end of the
Maghahara for most of us I think it
is the first day of Ramadan which Ramadan
really is the month of Madhahara so it
is feeling that we should end the study
of the Madhahara tul Qulub on the beginning
of the month which is really the greatest
practical month for implementing all of the things
that we have learned over the last 12
weeks about the heart because the purpose of
Ramadan is to purify the heart with Allah
subhana wa ta'ala that is the purpose
of Ramadan that is the blessing of Ramadan
and the secret of Ramadan is that it
is there to purify the heart and I
want to say something about I don't know
how many people were here last night but
how many people saw the moon last night?
how many people went out to look for
it?
about the same number so I think for
the people that were here last night I
think all of us had a very wonderful
experience were you here with us?
who was here?
I mean wasn't that a great experience?
and I was thinking also like this morning
about just yesterday and seeing the Hilal and
one of the things that came to me
and struck me about it and I actually
think it is a very interesting perspective and
that is that when we saw the Hilal
last night for the first time what was
happening is for me when I first saw
it I didn't know if it was there
or not and I actually thought my eyes
might be playing tricks on me because it
was coming into existence and then disappearing it
was coming in and out and I realized
when we first went out there there was
nothing there but the light of the sun
and we had to wait and then Venus
showed up and then after that it took
some time before we could actually see the
small sliver and what I realized is Allah
says that they ask you about the new
moons and Allah responded to the message of
Allah to tell them that really they are
there just to tell time but the Mufassirun
say that the reason they asked about the
Hilal is they were trying to understand the
mechanism how is it that this new moon
came into being and the reason for that
is that the the ancients actually believed that
every moon was a new moon that it
wasn't the same moon that was it was
literally a new moon that it disappeared and
then it started again and they wanted to
understand how that was happening and what I
realized is Allah didn't tell them in other
words He didn't negate their belief He just
explained why the moon is there which is
its mawaqis, the mass right it's just a
way of telling time for people will hajj
to tell the time of the Ramadan and
hajj and one of the things that Qabiyyullah
ibn Arabi said in his tafsir is that
the secret of this ummah using a lunar
calendar as opposed to a solar calendar is
that the sun is used for worldly benefits
but the moon is used for other worldly
benefits so the focus of time of this
ummah is about other worldly time not about
this world and what I realized is if
you look at it from a completely non
-abstract perspective what you're seeing when you actually
witness the new moon is you are seeing
what's known in philosophy as emergence and this
is what this is the real problem for
these people is how things come out into
existence out of nothing how does that happen
this is their problem in other words why
is there something as opposed to nothing and
what you do if you sit there and
you're looking at the sky and suddenly this
thing emerges out of nothing right before your
eyes because you can't see it initially and
the reason you can't see it is because
of the sun the sun's light is too
strong and the reason you're able to see
it is because the sun's light has dimmed
and what emerges is reflected light so what
you can see is the reflected light of
the moon and really what that is is
the entire creation is reflected light is Allah
Allah is the entire creation is reflected light
from Allah the only reason we can see
it is because Allah allows it to exist
and he's the one that brought it into
existence and he's the one that takes it
out of existence and so really what you're
witnessing is this incredible event which is Allah
is letting you see reflected light come into
existence and that is the new moon that's
why it's istihlal it's the birth right, it's
the same moon that you have to have
just for a child to be born it's
the birth of reflected light which is that
is creation because it's all reflecting Allah the
whole thing is reflecting Allah كيف يجحد الاله
يا عجب كيف يعصى الاله عن كيف يجحده
الجاهد ولله في كل تحريكة تسكينة أبدا شاهد
وفي كل شهر آية تدل على أنه واحد
how strange that we can disobey Allah or
even stranger that people can disbelieve in Allah
when for Allah in every movement and stillness
there is a clear sign and in everything
itself there is a sign so the creation
of these meanings that set up in these
images and what we're doing is we're there
to decode what these meanings are and it's
a real gift to actually see the birth
of the new moon it's a gift and
I think people felt that last night because
one you have instead of ilm al yaqeen
you have ayn al yaqeen and the Quran
says that there is ilm al yaqeen ayn
al yaqeen and haq al yaqeen ilm al
yaqeen is when you hear somebody Imam al
Ghazali's example is when you hear somebody tell
you that there is a fire in the
forest and you trust that person that's ilm
al yaqeen but it's not the same as
seeing the fire yourself so you go there
and you see it that's ayn al yaqeen
and then he said if you go and
actually touch it that's haq al yaqeen so
you actually touch so it's an amazing thing
the new moon and that's Imam al-Hakim
made a hadith that the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam was referring to he said khairu
ibadillah alladhina wara'una al-adhina wal-ahinna
dhikran lillah the best of Allah's servants are
those who are vigilant about new moons and
shadows for the prayer times as a way
of remembering Allah right and I think for
us last night that the natural impulse when
we saw it was to remember Allah right
to li-tukabbir Allah aramna hadakum Allahu Akbar
you know it's Allahu Akbar and then for
me personally you know there was like a
real nashab of Ramadan came into my heart
just of a feeling you know a lot
of energy because it was zayn al yaqeen
that's the Ramadan moon so it's a real
gift the Ramadan anyway I just wanted to
share that with you so we went through
the diseases of the heart we looked at
bukhal first of all we looked at the
he talked about adab and the importance of
adab and then we talked about the hukam
of knowledge of the amrad al-qulood wa
adhiyatiha and the treatments for it which he
said according to Imam al-Ghazali it was
farba'een and then he went through alphabetically
the diseases of the heart and he obviously
gives the most these are really the most
important ones sibi'ah min zarrook and qad
ayyab actually narrow them down to about four
or five ones if you can control those
all the other ones actually are removed easily
but he began with the bukhal and Ramadan
is a month to really to cure your
bukhal because they said the Prophet s.a
.w. he was the most generous of human
beings and he was more generous than ever
in Ramadan and they described him kareeh al
-mursida like a wean that brings gifts fecundating
weans so bukhal and then batar batar is
batarat ma'ishatum to be happy with your
the dunya or the livelihood massa'ili farhatan
right his farha is hinama yufthiru wahinama yalqa
rabbuhu when he breaks his fast and when
he meets his lord and so it's kind
of the opposite of that idea of batar
and then bughad Ramadan is a time where
you're supposed to actually he said s.a
.w. akhdaru sadaqa fi ramadan the best sadaqa
is in Ramadan and then in another hadith
akhdaru sadaqa yuslahu batil dayn the best sadaqa
is rectifying between people so the best sadaqa
would be rectifying between people in Ramadan that
would be the best sadaqa so this is
a time to remove bughad from your heart
about people and then baghi oppressing people this
is a time when you can't do any
it's you're fasting and the prophet s.a
.w. told us that if somebody tries to
yudha qatiraka right wa anta sa'in fa
qon Allahumma inni sa'in if somebody is
fighting you you say I'm fasting in other
words la tabghi don't fight with them say
I'm fasting tell them you don't want to
do that and then hubbir minhum love of
position right Ramadan is about gaining a position
with Allah because the reason the secret of
fasting is it's the only act of ibadah
that nobody can tell you're doing it when
you're doing it you see like if you
give charity it's an act right it's an
act if you do prayer it's an act
if you make hajj it's an act all
of the ibadah that Allah has given us
are things that can visibly be seen fasting
alone is you can be standing next to
a person who is not fasting and a
person who is fasting and the only one
that knows is Allah so you're out here
with all these non-muslims they see you
they don't know you're fasting you look like
everybody else right so the point is is
that the manzida that you want is with
Allah it's not with people and that's hubd
al-dunya Ramadan is also reaning yourself from
dunya right the nafs is like a a
child that if you neglect it it grows
up loving to suck meaning love of dunya
but if you wean it then it becomes
weaned so Ramadan is the time of weaning
the soul from dunya and love of dunya
and then hubd al-mubah dunya dam yafa
'ad to love to be praised for things
that you don't do Ramadan is the time
when you're supposed to witness the shortcomings of
your actions and to really to recognize that
you've wasted the whole year and now it's
time to catch up the ibadah the qiyamah
that you didn't do in the previous year
it's time to catch up in this month
all of the things that you neglected the
sadaqah all those things so what you're trying
to do is do actions so that you
warrant praise right so it's a cure for
that and hasad right envy to purify the
heart from envy but if you can conquer
the envy comes from desire right if you
can conquer desire then you can remove envy
from your heart and desire is based according
to Imam Al-Ghazali on destroying the two
the thabj and the batan if you can
destroy those two desires conquer them not destroy
them but master them then all the other
desires become easy and then shame that's not
praise worthy this is a time to have
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala right so
for people without seeing Allah is the
sake of Allah is intelligent and and
then another thing which is really important which
he says is because this is such you
are really defeating the envy of Allah which
is shaitan by taking control of all the
things that shaitan uses right to fight and
to fight Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala his
irada for human beings his will for human
beings which is to believe in him and
follow him and that's why he mentions that
Allah says if Allah if you give victory
to Allah through fasting and conquering shaitan Allah
will give victory to you and make you
firm and that's what you want sabr is
part of sabat right sabr so we're learning
that and then he said and by doing
that also Allah says Allah is with the
muhsineen and then he mentions that he said
that's one of the interpretations of that ayah
that Allah will not change a people by
taking away their blessings until they become preoccupied
with their shaharat so they they fall into
like this society I mean it's the best
example of a pleasure culture everything is is
geared towards pleasure there's no people here the
idea of fasting is so alien to them
now because they eat all day long and
that's not something in even not that long
ago people did not eat you didn't snack
all day long there weren't snack machines everywhere
this is all the grazing culture right the
cattle people right seriously it's like cows that
just graze out and this is life grazing
no yeah the shayateen it's only shayateen because
there's one in the hadith it says the
bad jinn so it's it's not the shayateen
and also some of the ulama like imam
al-qadisi al-farsi who is a maliki
scholar he was asked why is it that
people still get bad thoughts in Ramadan and
his explanation was that he said the hadith
indicate only the kafir jinn are locked up
the fissaq from the believing jinn are not
locked up but allah knows best because there's
no hadith he doesn't have textual basis for
that and he admitted that at the end
he said that that would seem a high
probability there and allah knows best but also
you have no i mean i think it
would be interesting to do i mean this
is when you have a khilafah and you're
controlling the world and there's no wars and
you can actually occupy muslims doing intelligent statistical
studies it would be interesting to see studies
done about crime rates and things like that
if they do go down in Ramadan i
mean i think that would be kind of
an interesting thing to do so there's somebody
has a phd thesis convinced a university to
give you funding for that now a
couple of things here imam ala ghazali r
.a mentions he goes into the fiqhi issues
and we covered that last night about the
fiqh of fasting there's two fiqhs there's the
outward fiqh which is the concern of the
fuqaha and then there's the inward fiqh which
is the concern of the qawm or the
sufiya and the outward fiqh is to make
sure that your outward fasting is acceptable the
inward fiqh is to make sure that your
inward fasting is acceptable and there's a hadith
that indicates this very clearly in which the
prophet s.a.w. said that many people
who fast how many fasters do nothing from
their fast except hunger and thirst so it
means in other words outwardly the fast is
correct but inwardly they're breaking their fast constantly
because if you're backbiting if you're doing all
these things now just a few things about
that he says there are three types of
fasters salman imam the fast the general fasting
salman khusus and then the elect fasting was
salman khusus and khusus and then the fasting
of the elect he says that the fasting
of the common people is basically leaving the
it's just preventing the stomach and the genitals
from gaining pleasure during the daylight hours that's
the fasting that any muslim is capable of
doing he said the fasting of the elect
is the fasting kafa al-samaa wal-basar
wal-lisan wal-yad wal-rijal because remember
ibn ashar r.a talks about the seven
right you have to protect the seven jawarah
right we're responsible for them you have to
protect the eyes you have to protect the
ears you have to protect the tongue you
have to protect the hand the stomach the
genitals and the feet so three of them
two of them are covered in the outward
fasting so a person who's fasting and they're
not eating or having sexual relations or any
type of sexual behavior whether it's masturbation any
type of that that person has taken hold
of two of those seven and those are
called the madakhir ash-shaitaan furoor ash-shaitaan
those are the entrances of shaitaan some of
the ilayah ibn al-qayyim r.a mentioned
that the body of the human being is
like a country and the capital is the
heart and the the borders the boundaries are
the seven limbs and you have to guard
the seven limbs with vigilance and the heart
is the one that sends out the command
to guard the limbs sends out the armies
to guard them so shaitaan comes in to
the heart through one of those seven things
so the point of the fasting is to
protect the boundaries during Ramadan and guard them
so that the heart has a chance to
draw near to Allah لعلكم تتقون كتب عليكم
السيام كما كتب على الذين من قبلكم لعلكم
تتقون it's in order to learn taqwa and
taqwa is نحن التقوى ها هنا وأشار إلى
قلبه the place of taqwa is here in
the heart the prophet s.a.w. said
التقوى ها هنا وأشار إلى قلبه ثلاث مرات
so taqwa is in the heart so you're
trying to learn taqwa and the taqwa is
the heart so what you're doing is you're
protecting the heart by stopping by protecting the
boundaries into the heart of shaytan and Allah
has helped you by locking up the shayateen
so he's put constraints on the shayateen so
Allah is giving us a great assistance in
this month and then he's helped us by
making it safar to not eat in other
words the two sources of the all the
troubles the most basic ones he Allah s
.w.t has commanded but then he left
us it's up to us because it can't
all be there has to be some mujahida
Allah left it up to us to guard
the eyes the tongue the ears the hands
and the feet and that's the fasting of
the ilah so they're fasting from all seven
limbs right so you're guarding your tongue you're
guarding your eyes you're guarding your hands you're
guarding your feet that's what you have to
do don't look at the haram don't speak
the haram and don't listen to the haram
Allah w.s. somebody starts to back bite
Allah w.s. you have to protect yourself
don't hear my fast the dua of the
prophet about Ramadan Allahumma salimna Ramadan wa salim
Ramadan minna oh Allah give us Ramadan and
protect Ramadan from our evil you know you
don't want Ramadan to get a portion of
your evil you have to get a portion
of Ramadan's good and you don't want to
give Ramadan anything bad and this is why
it has what's known as harma zamaniyah it
has the sanctity of time and that's why
wrong action in Ramadan is greater than wrong
action other times because Allah has given us
harma a sanctity and you have to guard
the sanctity of the month and you guard
it by not doing what Allah tells you
and this is Allah w.s. one of
the things that Allah said to the human
being is that he
told us that we are to to give
the amanat to its people to give the
amanat to its people that's one of the
signs of the believer right the believer gives
trust that have been entrusted with him to
those who own the trust so if you're
given a trust and somebody tells you I'm
entrusting you with this but this is mine
I'm entrusting it with you but this is
mine the mu'min is the one yu'min comes
from the same root of amanah he has
no iman the one who has no amanah
Allah has given us a trust those
things the sight the sound the hearing and
the heart itself which generates all of the
actions of the other men you are mas
'ool in other words they're amanat that Allah
has put you in responsibility for and you
have to bring back the amanah on yawmul
qiyamah he brings back the amanah sound he
hasn't destroyed it right he's been destroyed the
one who pollutes this trust that Allah has
given you because the nest is a trust
and like that children are a trust your
children are amanah right so we have a
trust Allah has given you and fasting Allah
is teaching us how to honor the trust
and give it back to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala the way Allah wants it which
is he wants your tongue to be free
of slander all these things he wants it
to be free of that he wants your
ears to be free of hearing the haram
he wants your eyes to be free of
seeing the haram he wants your hands to
be free of doing anything haram your feet
to be free of going anywhere haram and
your genitals free of going to a place
that's haram and your stomach free of taking
in and biting anything or eating anything that's
haram that's what Allah wants he wants us
to protect these trusts that he's given us
and the way he's teaching us to do
that is fasting that is this is the
madrasa to learn these things and then finally
the fasting of the elect of the elect
and he says it is the saam al
-qalb an himam ad-daniyyah wal-afqar ad
-daniyyah it is the fasting of the heart
on no aspirations from no aspirations or from
worldly thoughts so in other words the fasting
of the elect is that your aspiration is
not for dunya and that's why in Ramadan
intaq because giving out is for akhirah whereas
in the other months you're busy trying to
acquire wealth in Ramadan you should be busy
trying to get rid of wealth for the
sake of Allah you're not in a dunya
mode you're in a akhirah mode right you're
in a akhirah mode you have to change
in this month you have to change this
is the way you're thinking and then afqar
ad-daniyyah is one of the things about
the people one of the scholars of Andalusia
said that the first degree of wilaya with
Allah is muhasabat al-khawatir is to begin
to take thoughts to account right that's the
beginning of it that he begins to measure
the thought based on the meezan of the
sharia that's what that's what the wali does
and that's why he's a wali Ramadan is
a time to do muhasabah of your heart
in other words if you begin to think
about things that are genuine things because you
don't want to be none of us want
to be with Allah and ammi in Arabic
ammi means suqi right do you say that
in Arabic suqi suqi do they say that
in Sham suqi somebody who's like the himmah
is in the market place you have to
rise above that and the thing about Islam
an ammi does not mean that you know
there's a lot of scholars that think because
they're learned they're not awam but they're awam
because the ammi can be the street sweeper
who only knows and there's a few surahs
from the Quran but his heart is with
Allah that's why he asked how many people
are not fasting but with Allah they're fasting
and how many people who are fasting but
with Allah they're not fasting because there's people
during the year who are they're guarding their
eyes their ears their tongue their feet their
genitals their stomach so in reality they're doing
the purpose of fasting because fasting is just
an exercise to learn how to do it
properly whereas other people they're fasting physically but
with Allah they're not fasting so that's the
point so when he's talking about the khususi
don't think that's somebody who knows Imam Sibari's
Al-Kitab and he's a great grammarian or
he knows all the tafaseer or he knows
that's not what he's talking about these people
can be almost illiterate if the heart is
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala I mean
look at Imam Sahnun Muhammad bin Sahnun who's
the son of Sahnun who wrote the Mudawwana
he had a majlis in Al-Qayrawan and
in this majlis every day these he said
a man would come into the majlis and
walk over people's shoulders and go up to
the sheikh he was teaching in a chair
and he'd start whispering into his ear for
a while and then he would leave and
he was doing this every time the sheikh
would teach the sheikh actually told people to
move away so that he wouldn't have to
go over there helping out one day the
man stopped coming and Imam Sahnun Muhammad bin
Sahnun asked some of the people where's that
man who used to come here every day
and they said we don't know and he
asked somebody to go find him he found
him and he came and he said what
happened you stopped visiting me and the man
said subhanallah you know i have to explain
myself some people who envy you i'm a
very poor man and i have a lot
of daughters that i need to get married
some people who envy you because he was
a qabi and they said they came to
me and said go and bother him every
day in his majlis and if you can
make him angry and humiliate him in front
of all his students we'll give you money
so you can marry your daughters so i
used to come every day and i would
curse you in your ear and i would
say all those horrible things and i realized
it wasn't having an effect on you and
so i just gave up and muhammad bin
sahnun said why didn't you just come and
ask me for some money that i would
have given you but i mean that that
is that's where you want that's a thing
that you want to learn from that is
the sabr of the people of the messenger
of allah that's the sabr of the family
that's the sabr of salman salman is from
our family salman he he was patient he
was a zoroastrian he used to see them
blowing out the fire would get blown out
and they would light it and they would
tell the worshippers it never goes out and
his father was in charge of it so
he knew it was a lie so he
wanted to find where he went to the
christians he was with a monk serving him
for years and he saw the monk stealing
all the people's money and burying it in
his backyard and he went to another monk
and he said he was actually a good
monk he told him that there is a
prophet in the land of time coming so
basically in terms of this month here's my
suggestion to myself first and foremost do you
think that you should recite the next version
i think the next version is completely wrong
yeah yeah you should i mean i'm saying
in ramadan that would break the fact that's
all i was saying i think it's wrong
anyway i know but so is lying and
people lie and so is you know people
do things that are haram there's a khilaf
about it anyway according to the malikis the
dominant opinion is that it's prohibited according to
ahmad ibn hamdan it's considered mudah without any
fantasizing he considered it like hijama or something
like that so it's a khilaf issue but
i was just using that because some people
might think that fasting is just from sexual
relations with somebody else but it includes that
so any type even tafakkur like fantasizing you
know that would lead to that all that's
haram so anyway during this month and then
inshallah i'm going to close this group of
people it's leaving at 2.30 but during
this month my recommendation to myself and all
of you is don't do a lot of
talking utilize the time everybody should be appreciating
that all the other muslims don't waste your
time this is a month that the salaf
used to for 6 months before ramadan they
would beg allah to let this month so
this is not a time like other times
we all have to understand that and the
other thing is none of us knows if
this is our last ramadan and none of
us even knows will we make it to
the end of this ramadan so this is
seize the moment we utilize this time all
of us don't let the month pass and
then the last few days and you're regretting
i should have done more i mean we'll
do that anyway but hopefully it will be
it won't be as bad as some people
who will have done very little i mean
hopefully we'll do a lot and still there's
going to be a sense that we didn't
do enough because human being said the greatest
proof of the deficiency of man is that
he never does anything except that he realizes
afterwards he could have done it better anything
so i mean there's always improvement but the
point is utilize the time utilize the night
right the night it's mandatory to do khatm
of the quran in the taraweeh but even
one surah is effectual so even if you
did your taraweeh with qud hu allahu ahad
if that's all you know and you did
your rakats that counts as qiyam so you
want to do the qiyam every night even
if you're going to just do 20 rakats
with qud hu allahu ahad do qiyam at
night in fact walid al khadeem says towards
the end of time it's good to do
night prayers with like qud hu allahu ahad
the surahs that have a lot of reward
mentioned in them just because there's so little
time and most people don't have the himmah
to do a lot anymore so utilize the
time try to do the the duha prayer
right so basically try to get up before
the fajr do some qiyam before fajr and
then utilize the time after fajr try not
to sleep after that time because it's makruh
in any case but in ramadan that's we
should be gaining that time even more so
than other times and then try to do
the duha the prophet s.a.w. told
abu huraira to do the duha not to
leave it ever and so you should try
to do it it's a manduz and it's
a very strong it has a very strong
method because the prophet did do it continuously
2, 4, 6 or 8 rakaat before the
zawal all the way up to the zawal
for the manakees and the hanafis they have
the during the time of the hajra that
they can't pray the nafida and then prayer
on time prayer on time should be anytime
arabic arabic arabic arabic arabic
arabic arabic arabic arabic arabic arabic arabic
arabic so prayer and then we heard earlier
that the messenger of allah on his death
bed allah alaihi salam his wasiya to his
ulma as last words were as-sala as
-sala prayer is over everything guard your prayer
and use this time to discipline yourself to
be praying on time right use it to
discipline yourself if you If you weren't praying
on time before Ramadan, and you should have
been, but if you weren't, then use this
time to discipline yourself to pray on time.
If you're working, just stop, you know, because
your prayer is more important than your job.
I guarantee you.
Prayer is more important than your job.
Do your prayer.
And then, particularly the time between Asr and
Maghrib is a very strong time.
Throughout the year, it's a time of dhikr.
But during the time of Asr, it's a
very special time.
Except for the people who believe.
It's a time of love for other people.
And that's why in this culture, you see
people at the end of the day, they're
worn out.
They have to go and go drink, and
they call it happy hour in this culture.
No, seriously, they call it happy hour.
They have to have oblivion, so that they
don't have to think about how meaningless their
lives are.
That's a time when we're preparing for sunset,
which means death for us.
Sunset is a metaphor for death.
And Asr, from Asr to Maghrib, that's your
later years in the lives of man.
That period is representative.
And the fast, breaking the fast, is like
the messenger, There's two jurors.
So, there's an analogy being made there, that
the breaking of the fast is similar to
meeting your Lord.
In other words, when the day is over,
and death is over, you go back to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And then, after you break your fast, the
best thing is to break it on Rotab,
or Tamar, or Hasawat Minan Ma.
If you don't have any of that on
anything, you can just break the fast.
If there's no food around, then you pray
anyway.
And the delay of it is only Makruh
if it's delayed out of thinking that it's
better, right?
Then it becomes a bid'ah.
But if you had a valid reason to
delay breaking the fast, then it's perfectly fine.
But don't eat before you pray Maghrib.
And if you go to Muslim houses, a
lot of times they'll ask you, do you
want to eat first or pray?
Tell people, let's pray first.
Don't be shy about that.
Because people will eat, and the prayer Maghrib
goes out of the time.
Maghrib is a very short time, window, and
you don't want to delay it.
Because it's, most of the interval, it's the
early time, right?
After it comes in, time for Adhan, to
do your du'a, to find a pure
place, khadaf.
During the fasting, you're given a little window
of breaking the fast with drinks and water.
Do the du'a, right?
And then when you finish it, That's
a good thing to do.
If you eat at somebody's house, These are
good things to learn, and to practice them,
and to learn the du'as.
And then, the Isha prayer, if you have
a strong Azimah, then it's better to pray
in your house.
In other words, if you're going to do
night prayers, it's better to pray in your
house.
If you don't have a strong Azimah, and
you know yourself, or, there's a Muqri, who's
going to do Khatm of Quran, and you
want to do the Khatm with the, it's
Mandeen, right?
So, if you want to do the Khatm
in the Masjid, that's a good thing also.
Avoid, what unfortunately, a lot of our brothers
are afflicted with, is this idea that the
Tarawih has only 8 Rakaats.
And so, after the 8 finishes, they say,
you know, Alhamdulillah, we're following the Sunnah.
And let me go outside and talk, for
the next hour, right?
Outside, above the Masjid.
Be, you know, just admit, I'm lazy, you
know, it's really 20s long for me.
You know, but don't start justifying, you know,
Sunnah, brother, I'm following Sunnah.
Because Sunnah is not to sit around at
the door of the Masjid and talk.
I guarantee you that.
The Prophet, sallallahu alaihi wasallam, did not waste
his time.
And empty talk at the door of the
Masjid is, that's, that's Suqa.
I mean, that's, that's, that's Amr, really.
And we don't want to be part of
that.
And don't belittle people, don't look down on
people.
I'm not, you know, don't want to get
judgmental about people.
Everybody's where they're at, for whatever reason.
But the point is, don't see yourself as
better than them.
But thank Allah that He hasn't afflicted you
with that affliction.
Because it's an affliction.
And when the Prophet saw 50 people who
said, That's not the arrogance to recognize the
ni'mah that Allah has given you.
It's arrogance when you think that you deserve
it more than they do.
Because it's just a favor that Allah has
given you for whatever reason.
And who not?
And why?
Allah said, He could take that away from
you, and give your state to that person
or daughter, and put you there sitting at
the door of the Masjid talking.
And one of the men who accused Mu
'adh ibn Jabal of doing something haram, he
made a dua against him.
And Mu'adh was Mustajab al-Dua.
He was known for that.
And this man was seen in his old
age, punching girls on the streets of Medina.
They said his eyes had fallen over.
Like the eyebrow had literally fallen over his
eyes.
And he'd like, pinch.
And that was the iftila that Allah gave
him in his old age.
For falsely condemning Mu'adh ibn Jabal.
So, I don't want people to get self
-righteous or anything like that.
Myself included.
But the point is, don't really.
If people are talking, you know, greet people.
It's a joyous time.
It's a time that we should do that.
And then the other thing to remember is
our brothers and sisters who are in great
tribulation now.
The people of Palestine.
The people of Iraq.
The people of Algeria.
The people of Bosnia.
The people of India.
I could go on and on and on.
And I don't want to.
Those people really are suffering.
And so, temper your joy with some gravity
as well.
One of the things about light that I
learned a long time ago, and I think
it's really true, is that sometimes a people's
reaction to a lot of spiritual light is
to get giddy and laugh and get frivolous.
And you can see that in people.
And it's a way of spilling light.
And Ramadan can be that for people.
They'll get, because there's so much light, that
they'll end up kind of like laughing the
whole month.
Seriously.
I really mean this.
People will end up like just kind of
spending and having a good time.
And what they're doing is because they haven't
learned how to contain, you know, the benefits,
they just spill it all out.
So, try to contain the benefits of that.
I think we're going to.
Is the bus here?
Is that bus going to go?
Yes, you are.
You're supposed to do the Asa of the
evening.
Yeah, I'm going to come back after the
Asa.
Are they going to leave now?
Okay.
Then what I'll do before we pray, because
there's still a little bit more time, I
wanted to read from the section on fasting
from the Mu'affa for the Barakah of
it.
And.
What's that?
Okay, I'm glad you mentioned that.
The other thing, Imam Marek R.A., during
Ramadan, he did not like story telling and
didn't like, he said this is a time
of Qiyam and Qira'ah.
So, the best zikr during Ramadan is Quran.
That, you should still do the Sadah and
Masa.
Those are really important to do in Ramadan
as well as any other time.
But, you should have your read of Quran.
Imam Abu Hanifa R.A. said that Quran,
if you read it at least twice a
year, then you're not considered jazzy.
In other words, there's a ayah in the
Quran, where the Messenger of Allah complained about,
that his people have just neglected or left
the Quran.
And, Ramadan is a time where we should
be trying to spend a lot of time
with the Book of Allah.
And so, preferably, if you can do more
than one Khatam, that would be good.
There are people, and I know some of
you personally, but he did, I think, 26
Khatam in Ramadan.
But, that's mostly what he was doing.
Obviously, people that are working and things like
that.
So, it's difficult, you know, to do that.
If you're not as proficient with it, you
know, there's also the listening to the Muqri,
if you have the tape.
In other words, when you're driving, if you
don't memorize a lot of Quran, it's better
to read when you memorize, when you're driving.
But, if you don't, then just listen to
the Quran, the recitation.
And, also do some Tadabbur of the Quran,
during Ramadan.
In other words, don't just do the Ta
'abbud of it, but do some Tadabbur.
You know, if you can do, there's a
seven-day word of the Quran, which is
reading.
It goes three, five, seven, nine, eleven, and
then the Mufassab.
You go, you read the first three surahs,
for the first day.
And, then the first three, and then the
five, the next five surahs.
And, then the next seven, and then the
next nine, and then the eleven, and then
thirteen, and then the Mufassab.
So, in seven days, you can finish.
The Mufassab is from Adasa, to the end
of the Quran, or Hijarat.
And, with the thirteen, it goes to, not
Adasa, Qaf.
So, the point is, that's the way a
lot of Sadaf did the Quran.
They would do it by the odd three,
five, seven, nine, eleven, thirteen Mufassab.
Like that.
Question.
I wouldn't pray.
If you are a Fardh, I would not
pray Tarawih.
You should do the Fardh.
Use it as a time to gain all
your Fardh back.
Yeah, I would do, instead of Qiyam, do
all the Fardh.
Because, the only, if you owe prayers, I
mean, in Alhamdulillah, they don't make them up.
But, Ma'ruf al-Hadith and Shaf'i'
do.
If you owe prayers, then you have to,
in the Manakin, you would only do, Witr
and the Raghiba.
You do the Witr prayer and the pre
-dawn prayer.
Other than that, you do, and you should
do, according to, you know, the Akhbari, if
you do less than five at every prayer,
then you're in a Fardh, throughout the year.
If you owe prayers, and you do less
than five, then you're in a Fardh.
You're not doing enough.
Less than five at every prayer?
Yeah, at every prayer.
And, what you should do, is do the
minimal amount.
If you owe a lot, if you don't
owe that many, I wouldn't do this.
If you owe a lot, like years, then
do the minimal amount, for the prayer, to
be valid.
Alright?
It's a bet, that you owe.
You know, and, Insha'Allah, Allah will accept
the, Then,
what the ulama says, that you should do
the best to estimate.
In other words, if you left the prayer,
say, you remember that you were seventeen, or,
something like that.
I mean, people should know around when they
stop praying, hopefully.
It probably is a point, they start going
seriously astray in their life.
So, that should be, most people remember when
they go astray.
By minimal prayer, in other words, what you
should do, is do the Arkan, the Arkan,
and the basic, Suman, that is Mu'akkadah,
right?
And, that's it.
So, there's, you know, the sixteen Arkan, and
the eight Suman Mu'akkadah, and, you know,
and, Also, like, if you're learning quick, and
then you have a doubt about, like, the
phrase you're doing in the practice, about, like,
whether you're making a mistake, Yeah, I mean,
that, you know, I think, you know, you
just have, I know there's some people, that
would say you should make them up, and,
I think that you just, if you're learning
Fiqh now, then that's something you just make
Tawbah, and ask Allah.
If, in other words, you had a Farba
'een that you didn't learn, and now you're
learning it, I would just, you know, ask
Allah to forgive you.
Some people, you know, for a lot of
Muslims, they were not aware that Farba'een
was in their obligation.
In other words, their parents never told them.
They really didn't know.
And, so, in a sense, I mean, this
is an Itham that really was going back.
Right?
Because a Muslim, is, the child is an
Amanah.
And one of the Amanahs that you're supposed
to do, is teach them the Farba'een.
So, I know a lot of Muslims, who
were not told any of these things.
And they just thought they were doing right.
And, and I think those people, Insha'Allah,
I would just, you know, I would say,
make Tawbah, just ask Allah, Insha'Allah, to
excuse you for your ignorance, and to accept
those prayers.
But, you know, I wouldn't allow on them.
I mean, I wouldn't, I think that might
be.
Uh-huh.
Question.
Can a Rahiba include the two Rakat of
Maghrib?
Rahiba is, no.
Some of the ulama say you do the,
the, the, the Nafida of at least two
Rakat of Maghrib.
You know, there's a Khilaf about that.
Do you know anything?
Yeah, about the Rakat after Maghrib.
No, no, no.
To make them up, if you.
Not to make them up, but if you
should continue doing.
I think there's a Khilaf, I'm not sure
if it's mentioned or not.
But, but definitely the Witr and the Rahiba
should be done in spite of, of Fard
prayers owed.
Uh-huh.
Question.
If you, uh, if you're not doing the
Fard prayers, what about doing the Quran?
What do you mean?
Yeah, if you have time to make up
your prayers, that's what you should be doing.
A dad should go to the Fard.
You know, Question.
Question.
My servant doesn't draw near to me with
anything more beloved to me than the Fard.
So, Fard is over everything.
You know.
Really.
If you're doing Nafida and no Fard, you're
wasting your time.
No.
If they're, if they're less than five, then
you should do them in order.
Right?
If they're more than five, then, then, uh,
then you should, uh, you just do them
at the time like, uh, for instance, if
you owe, uh, Question.
If it's more than that, then you don't
have to do them in order.
And some of the others say, if you
owe a lot, then what you do is,
you just pick a certain amount, at least
five.
Uh, so you do five prayers at Dhur,
five prayers at Asr, five prayers at, uh,
Maghrib, five, like that.
So you don't have to do them in
order.
Question.
Is the bus here?
Okay.
Question.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Um, inshallah, a couple of, one, I want
to, this, cause this is the last class,
um, for people that are going on the,
uh, intensive.
Jazakumullah khairan.
And tofeeq, inshallah.
And I want to thank all of you,
uh, for the attendance, and, and the, the
respect, and, and, and the, uh, just the
general good spirit that's been, uh, present throughout
the whole, uh, course.
And, uh, you know, excuse me for any
shortcomings, or, uh, any breaches of courtesy.
Um, and make du'a also.
Bismillah ar-Rahman ar-Rahim.
By the blessing of Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala, we were able to go through this
text to complete it.
And we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
inshallah, to give us the ability to implement
what we, what we've learned.
And in ending this text, I would like
to give counsel that was written by one
of our great scholars, Sidi Ahmed Zarouk, who
died in 1492.
He was a great scholar from Morocco, and
he died in Masada in Libya.
And one of the things that he said
is that the fragrance of his teaching would
disseminate in the world, or diffuse in the
world, long after his bones were laid to
rest.
And so it's, it's one of his really
karamat or, or, uh, saintly miracles that his
teaching is still affecting us and influencing us.
He said, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala anhum,
Know, may Allah give you and us success,
and rectify our worldly and otherworldly lives, and
grant us adherence to the way of the
truth in our journeys and in our sojourns,
that repentance is a key, and taqwa is
vast, and uprightness is the source of rectification.
Furthermore, a servant is never free of either
blunders or shortcomings or lassitude.
Therefore, never be neglectful of tawbah, repentance, and
never turn away from the act of returning
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, and never
neglect acts that bring you closer to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Indeed, every time one of these three occurs,
repent and return.
Every time that you make a mistake, listen
and obey.
Any time you display shortcomings or show lack
of enthusiasm, don't desist in your efforts.
Let your main concern be to remove from
your outer state anything that is displeasing, and
then maintain its outward state through continuous counsel.
Continue doing this until you find that you
are fleeing from anything outwardly displeasing or second
nature, and that your avoidance of the boundaries
of prohibited things is as if it acts
like a protective net that is placed before
you.
At this point, it is time to turn
inward toward your heart's presence and to its
reality with both reflection and remembrance.
Don't hasten the end result before you have
completed the beginning, but likewise, don't begin without
looking toward the end result.
This is so because the one who seeks
the outset at the end loses providential care,
and the one who seeks the end at
the outset loses providential guidance.
Act in accordance with principles and the appropriate
legal rulings, and not in accordance with stories
and fantasies.
Don't even consider stories of how things went
with others, except as a tonic to strengthen
your resolve.
Certainly not as a reference based upon their
outward forms or what they seem to be
telling us.
In all of this, depend upon a clear
path you can refer to and a foundation
that you can depend upon in all of
your states.
The best of these is the path of
Ibn Ata'illah, given that in it is
a clear direction to Allah.
Do not take from others words unless it
is in accordance with your own path, but
submit to their implications if you desire realization.
Avoid all forms of vain and foul speech
to your absolute utmost.
Put aside anything that you cannot discern, its
benefit immediately.
Beware of being extremely hard on yourself before
you have obtained a mastery over it, but
also beware of being too lax with it
in anything that concerns sacred rulings.
This is because it is constantly fleeing from
moderation in everything, and it inclines towards extremism
in both matters of deviance and guidance.
To repeat, this is so because it is
constantly fleeing from moderation in everything, and it
inclines towards extremism in both matters of deviance
and guidance.
So, just to stop and look, this is
extremely important because what the Shaykh is telling
us is that the nature of the self
is extremism, and he is telling us to
be aware of this in both good deeds
and in foul deeds, in both obedience to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and disobedience to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So he is telling us, beware of being
extremely hard on yourself before you have obtained
a mastery over it, but also beware of
being too lax with it in anything that
concerns sacred rulings.
He continues, Seek out a companion to help
you out in your affairs and take his
counsel concerning matters that occur from both your
inward states and your outward affairs.
If you do indeed take his companionship, then
treat him in a manner commensurate with his
state and give him of your counsel based
upon his inabilities and abilities, because the perfected
friend is no longer to be found.
Indeed, in these times, even a suitable companion
who is agreeable rarely lasts.
And beware of the majority of people in
matters that concern your religious and your worldly
states, unless you have ascertained he has some
sound relationship with his Lord based upon a
knowledge that is free of his caprice or
love of leadership and a sound intellect free
of the pitfalls of hidden agendas.
Do not be heedless of the machinations of
others or their hidden states.
Consider these two from both their origins and
their actions.
A person of character and family distinction rarely
affects you with other than good, and yet
a person of low origins' roots usually cause
him to disregard you when times get tough.
Be extremely vigilant of the dominant qualities of
a given people in any given land and
don't be heedless of the divine wisdom in
the creation and notice gatheredness and separation.
Some of this we have already covered in
our book Al-Qara'ib, so take a
look at it there.
Only have time in a matter appropriate to
the time's specific needs using gentleness and toleration
and be very wary of either harshness or
laxity.
This is so because too much laxity concerning
permissible matters pulls the heart backward in its
journey until even a man of resolve ends
up looking like a foolish boy.
Work for this world as if you will
live forever, but work for your next life
as if you die tomorrow.
Thus, do not neglect the externals of your
worldly needs.
In the meantime, do not be heedless of
your end and final resting place.
Be extremely vigilant about avoiding positions of leadership,
but should you be tried with such matters,
at least know your own limitations.
Be absolutely sincere to allow the sincerity of
one who knows full well who is placing
demands upon him.
Surrender completely to his decree with the submission
of one who knows he can never overcome
him.
Have a firm foundation for all of your
affairs and you will be safe from their
pitfalls.
Organize your devotional practices and you will find
your time is extended due to the barakah
or blessings in it.
Never be fanatical about anything, whether it is
the truth or whether it is false, for
your heart will then remain in a state
of soundness towards others.
Never claim anything you are entitled to, not
to mention what you are not entitled to,
and you will be safe from tricks and
treachery.
This is so because anyone who claims some
rank above his own will fall in humiliation,
whereas those who claim a rank they warrant
will have it stripped from them, while those
who claim a station less than their true
rank will be elevated to even higher levels
than they actually deserve.
Never give your companion anything of your state
other than what his own state warrants.
This is so because if you go down
to his level, he will show you contempt,
whereas if you attempt to raise him up
to your level, he will abandon you.
Never demand a right from anyone, whether an
intimate or a stranger.
The reason for this is a stranger in
reality owes you nothing, and someone close to
you is too precious to direct your blame
to him.
Never assume that anyone in this world can
really understand your circumstances other than from the
perspective of his own circumstances.
This is so because in reality, everyone only
sees things in accordance with their frames of
reference and their personal path.
However, when aims, purposes, and aspirations are similar,
people tend to work together toward a common
goal.
Never belittle any talk that involves absent people,
even if there is no harm in it,
due to the possibility of harm entering into
it.
Guard your secrets even if you feel safe
with someone, because the one you divulge your
secret to is not a safer place than
your own heart from whence it emanated.
Never leave an atom's weight of your regular
devotional practice.
Never be lenient with yourself in either lax
times or times of high resolve.
Indeed, should you miss some of your practice
at a given time, redress it in another
time.
If you are not able to do your
usual practice, at least occupy yourself with something
else similar.
Never obey your ego, even for a moment.
Never believe any of its claims, no matter
what it tells you.
Be vigilant about your resolve in all of
your affairs to your utmost.
In fact, should you resolve to do something,
then do it immediately before the resolve wanes.
Examine your soul constantly in matters that you
are obliged to do or are needed to
be done.
Anything you are in no need of doing,
leave it, even if it is something that
is recommended.
That means not involving yourself in anything other
than absolutely necessary things, and real discernible needs.
Treat others just as you would want to
be treated, and fulfill to them what is
due to them.
All of this is really epitomized in the
words of the poet when he said, If
you desire to live such that your religion
is safe, and your portion is full, and
your honor is sound, guard your tongue, and
never mention another's faults, remembering you yourself have
faults, and others have tongues.
Watch your eye.
Should it ever reveal to you the faults
of others, say to it, O my eye,
other people have eyes too.
Live treating others well, and avoid aggression, and
should others aggress against you, leave them, but
in the best way.
The source of these words is in fact
nothing other than the traditions of the Prophet,
when he said, Be vigilant of Allah wherever
you are, and follow a misdeed with a
good deed, and it will remove it, and
treat others with the most excellent of character.
In another he said, Peace and blessings of
Allah be upon him, Every child of Adam
makes mistakes, and the best of those who
make mistakes are those who seek to redress
them.
Again, the Holy Spirit inspired my heart's core,
that no soul will die until it fulfills
its decreed portion of this world, and its
appointed time here.
So be conscious of Allah, and make your
requests with dignity.
In summation, repentance, awareness of Allah, and uprightness
are the foundations of all that is beneficial.
The truth is clear, and its details are
weighty and significant.
The affair belongs only to Allah, success is
in His hands.
Peace be upon you.